And then also in Zoom. There we go.
All right, so welcome everyone to the big second brain mini course workshop. I have been putting so much prep into this. I have a ton of resources available for you guys that we'll get right into. We are going to be building a second brain completely from scratch today.
So I've been working on my second brain over the past three months at this point, and it has gotten to the point where it legitimately saves me at least 20 hours of work every single week. And trust me, I've been running a very similar business for… For the last year and a half. Like, I have a good sense of how long different things take me that I've started to automate with my second brain, either fully automated or partially automated. So I'm not just exaggerating for the sake of this workshop. That is, like, measurable outcomes for me that I have with my second brain. So I've packaged it.
all up together, and I'm giving it all the way to you guys right now. And so going to the browser here, first of all, for our workshop here, we have the event with the description. I have a single link in there right now. The recording of this workshop will also be available here.
in the description after, but right now, I have the repository, which is our reference for everything for today. So my entire second brain.
I have packaged it up, and I've taken out some of, like, the sensitive stuff and things that are, like, really specific to me. So, what we're looking at right here is a more general implementation of my second brain.
Um, but it still has everything. Like, all of the core architecture, everything that we'll talk about today, this is all in the resource for you guys. The point is not for you to take my second brain and run it as is. The point is for you to use this for inspiration.
and even point your coding agent to look at what we've built here to take ideas from my second brain. And so another really big thing that I want to be clear on here in this workshop is even if you already have a second brain, like you built your own on top of Claude code, or you're running an open claw second brain or a Hermes.
Whatever it is, you can still take a lot of ideas from what I'm going to show you here in the workshops. This is not just if you want to build completely from scratch, though if you are, then you're definitely the luckiest out of everyone, because I'm going to get you such a good starting point in this workshop here.
I use my second brain for so many different things. I'll give you just, like, a little sneak peek of some of the things I do with it. So, I have my Slack interface where I can talk to it remotely. I have my second brain even deployed in a VPS, just in the cloud. So I'll talk about that at the end of the workshop as well.
I have it help me with task planning, using Archon for coding. I have it help me do, like, research for content, YouTube videos, managing my inbox, it drafts replies to everything in my inbox. Obviously, there's some things I can't show super clearly here, because it's just really… you know, personal information, like, I'm not just gonna show my entire Gmail inbox in our workshop today, but just giving you some examples of, like, conversations at a high level that I have with my second brain. I have it help me with thumbnail generation, PowerPoint generation, diagram generation, like this diagram that you're looking at right here.
Of course, I put a lot of my own touch into it, but I used an Excalidraw diagram skill that I've shared with you guys before. I used it very heavily to build the entire diagram. So the second brain understands itself. So it was able to build this diagram really well.
Which, that's part of the important thing with our second brain, is it evolves itself over time. We'll talk about what that looks like with the memory system and the daily reflection, how we have our different capabilities through skills, and there's a lot of resources that I have for you guys there as well.
A lot of the skills that I have in the resources for you here, this is the folder that I link to in the description, a lot of these, you can just take directly as is, and use them immediately. Like, this is one of the biggest value adds out of everything in our workshop today. Like, the Excalidraw diagram skill that I was talking about just a little bit ago.
PowerPoint generator, this is probably the most elaborate out of all of them. So, about halfway through the workshop, that's when we're going to get into skills. So I have things broken up by modules here.
So, like, Module 2's gonna be, like, our memory layer, getting into how we use Claude hooks for the lifecycle of our second brain. And then we'll get into, you know, like, our direct integrations in Module 4, Module 5 will be skills. I wanted to split it up in this way, because when you're watching this right now, you might be in the course version of our workshop, because after this four-hour live event here, I am planning on editing things, splicing it up and making.
making it so that we have eight distinct modules for this course. So, a lot of structure that I put into, a lot of planning that I put into this up front to make it as smooth as possible for you guys, because there is a lot that we're building here. So I put a lot of effort into making sure that it's really easy to follow along, and.
grasp the core different components. I don't want everything to just kind of mush together and feel like this massive build that we're doing, but I wanted to really be like, if you already have your second brain, and you're just really interested in the skills part, or you're really interested in the daily reflection that I built, then there'll be, like, a really distinct part of the workshop where we focus on that, and we build it, because we are building the second brain from scratch.
I hope that makes sense to you guys, and sounds good.
Uh, let me go back to my browser here.
So, uh, yeah, for our workshop here. Um, I want to say that… If you want to create your second brain completely from scratch, you can just point your Claude code over to the repo here and say like, Hey, I want to build this for myself. Go and do it.
But you might not get the best results from doing that. And so I have created a Claude code skill that'll walk you through creating an entire PRD for creating your own second brain. And so it'll give you a full document, like full scope of work. Here's everything that we have to do to build out the second brain in phases.
And this Create Second Brain PRD skill, this is the first thing that we're going to dive into today. And then we're going to use the PRD that we generate today, and I'll talk about how we can customize it to our own applications and integrations. We're going to take that, and we're going to use it to build the entire second brain from scratch.
And so the way this workshop is going to go, and don't worry, we'll get into the meat of it like really quick here, is I want to first talk about why we care about building our own second brain in the first place. So compared to things like OpenClaw and Hermes. Then we'll cover the structure of the second brain at a high level.
So just really high level at first, because then we're going to get right into creating the PRD. So I have a repository that has nothing in it besides some of the commands from the agentic coding course. Like, that's it. So I have our commands for, like, priming and.
implementing and validating all these things that we have for our core PIV loops. We're going to be using everything I teach in the Agentic coding course to build this today. And then I have the Create Second Brain PRD skill. So, I'm going to go through live what it looks like.
to fill out the template. This is a resource that I have for you guys to get started with your own second brain. So there's different questions that you can answer, like how you want your second brain to help, how much autonomy you want it to have. We'll fill this out, we'll create the PRD, and then the rest of the workshop is just going to be building in phases.
So breaking it down nice and simple, and then as we wait for Claude code to build each of the phases, I'll have a lot of time for Q&A. So it's going to be built in throughout the workshop. I always say that it's really convenient when these workshops are relying on live coding, because then there's time for questions built right in.
And I know that you guys are gonna have a lot of questions, because you guys are always so good in the community at just being really engaged and asking the right questions. So we'll have time for that for sure. And you don't have to use Claude code. It is really generally considered the best AI coding assistant right now, and so that's what I'm using. Like personally and what I'll showcase in.
our workshop today, but if you wanted to use something like Codex or OpenCode to drive the entire system, you definitely can use that as well. So, you're not limited to the coding agent that I use, you're not limited to the tools that I use. Like, if you don't want to use Obsidian, or you want to use Telegram instead of Slack, or if you want to deploy to.
you know, Hostinger instead of DigitalOcean, you can easily do that, and we'll talk about what it looks like to.
you know, customize the PRD here so that your coding agent knows exactly, you know, how you want to integrate your second brain into your life. I always say that your second brain, you want it to work where you already work. That's why there aren't really, you know, prerequisites for our workshop today. As long as you have a coding agent, and you have all these platforms where you already do your.
task management and file storage and things like that, you're already good to go.
Um, yeah, so let's go ahead and kick things off right away.
with why should you build your own AI second brain? I want to address the elephant in the room here, because when I, you know, talk about building my own second brain on my YouTube channel or just to people in person, wherever it is, a lot of people say, well, you know.
I like open claw. I just have my open claw running.
And that is really legitimate. Like, OpenClaw is genuinely an impressive application. Like, it blew my socks off when I first saw it. You know, despite of all of the security issues that we'll talk about in just a second here. So, when I built my own second brain, I did take a lot of inspiration from OpenClaw.
I'll be totally transparent with you guys, I literally, you know, took my Claude code when I was first building my second brain, um, or at least, like, when I was still evolving it quite heavily. I pointed it to the open source repository for OpenClaw, and I said.
This repo is genius. What are the takeaways we can have from this? To build something like their memory system, or the proactive nature of their agent?
And that worked really, really well. In fact, what I did for OpenClaw, you guys can literally do for the implementation that I have as the reference. You can point your Claude code to reference a lot of the things that I have here. So you can go through the whole PRD process that we'll cover in a bit.
plus pointed it to my implementation. It's going to save you dozens and dozens of hours building your second brand. You don't have to build it from scratch, but you can still build something that you control.
And so, the reason we care about building our own second brain in the first place is because of something called the lethal trifecta. I've covered this once before in the community.
But this is what makes personal agents very dangerous. And so the lethal trifecta, it applies to more than just second brains or personal agents. This applies to all agents.
There are three parts to the trifecta here. Obviously, that's why it's called a trifecta. We have private data access, we have untrusted content, so there are other people that are able to give inputs into our agent. And then we have what is called an exfiltration vector.
And exfiltration vector, it's kind of a fancy phrase. All it means is there's some way for the agent to send information back to a malicious attacker through, you know, making an API request or sending a message on Telegram, something like that.
The thought process behind the lethal trifecta is your agent is at most risk of being compromised if it meets all three of these criteria.
So if it can access private data, receive untrusted inputs, and have some way to send information back out. Because think about it this way. If your AI agent is able to access things in your email, you know, access private data, and it can receive incoming emails, so theoretically there could be a prompt injection attack that comes in through an email.
But if there's no way for it to send private data back out to the attacker, your agent is a lot harder to compromise. If it only matches two out of the three criteria in the lethal trifecta. And just to give you another example here, let's say that there is an exfiltration vector. Your agent is allowed to make arbitrary API requests so it can send data out to the internet, and it could theoretically have a prompt injection attack.
But there's no access to private data, then it doesn't really matter if there is a prompt injection attack, because what is it really going to access, even if it could send something to an attacker? Not that your agent is fully secure at this point, but just saying that, like, we really need to hit on all three of these points.
In order for there to really be a big, big security concern with our agent.
And the thing is, in order for a second brain to be useful for us, it really has to have all three of these criteria met by default.
Like, if there's no exfiltration vector, it means that it's not possible for my agent to make any kind of API request. It can't even build Python scripts for me, like, it'd be very limiting. And obviously, we want our agent to deal with our inbox, and deal with, you know, searching the web, so pulling in.
other information from the web. We want it to help us manage our life, so it's going to have access to our tasks and our calendar and our email, and I'll show you what it looks like to set up all of that. And so, all this means that, like, we have to be very, very careful about bringing an AI agent as a second brain into our life.
And to me, this is where I make the connection here, so bear with me. To me, when you bring in an application like OpenClaw, it isn't being very careful. Unless you spend a ton of time auditing and customizing, and I would argue at that point it would be easier to just build it yourself anyway. And I think you'll agree with me after we go through this workshop, I have the foundation laid for you so much that it is going to be easy to build it and then.
evolve it over time. So OpenClaw, they've been doing a pretty good job improving a lot of their security issues over the past couple of months, but it's still not perfect. And okay, this is the craziest part. Did you guys know? I think OpenClaw fixed this at this point.
But did you know that when OpenClaw first came out, whenever you wanted to set new integrations, the agent would literally ask you to paste API keys into the prompt for the large language model. So you would just be giving your keys in plain text to OpenClaw.
Which is just one of the most ridiculous things I've ever heard, and so many people are doing that. And people were installing malicious skills from the open marketplace that they had called Claw Hub. There were so many crazy problems with OpenClaw, and a lot of them still exist here. So many security vulnerabilities.
companies like Cisco calling it a nightmare, like, hey, you should never even install this.
I think that's exaggerated to an extent, but you get the idea here. The main thing is, when you build your own second brain, you have full control. You actually understand the code base, and you can use Claude code to help you understand what you're building, even if you're not quite as technical, while you build it.
You get to define every permission, so we start more with a zero trust policy. And if you come from the software engineering industry, you know what I mean by that. If you think of something like you're working in AWS and you're setting up your IAM policies or your firewalls, like, you start with zero trust, and you build.
permission over time as you trust your system and you set up the guardrails and the other things for security. And so OpenClaw is the opposite of that. There's so much power. Openclaw literally has its own computer, and there is a lot of risk that comes with that. Like, it has computer access, it can pretty much do.
Anything it wants to. And you can't just rely on your prompting to give it guardrails. Like, you might say, like, never delete an email in my inbox. Well, it might not always listen to that, so just because you prompt it doesn't mean that won't end up happening.
We've heard of cases, horror stories on the internet, where people have literally had their entire inbox or Google Drive just wiped off the face of the earth from OpenClaw, even though there were explicit instructions to not do that. And so when we build our own second brain, that is our opportunity.
to build in guardrails and have more strict permissions around what our integrations can actually do, so that, for example, we can draft emails in Gmail. If we want to, you know, automatically draft replies and help us handle our inbox, but we can never send an email.
or delete an email, or mark it as spam, because we might not want to give power to our agent to do that like OpenClaw. I mean, maybe you do, and that's great, and you can add that in, but the point is we start with no trust, and we build that in over time. That is why we want to build our own second brain.
Your system, your rules, and your data actually stays at yours. That is very important.
And in the end, our code base is going to be a lot simpler than OpenClaw. I don't know exactly where it's at now, but when OpenClaw was first released, there was 175,000 lines of code in the OpenClaw code base. Pretty crazy. It's gonna be very hard to maintain that, and really, as a user of OpenClaw, actually understand it. So we're going to build something a lot simpler, but still just as capable.
for our own needs. And so, it goes with the advice of Anthropic when building AI agents. This really applies to all agents, but especially second brains. It's good to just build with simple, composable patterns. We're going to be using Claude code, we're going to use the Claude Agent SDK for all of the autonomous tasks our second brain will be doing. I'll show you how to build all of that.
And then most of the capabilities that we give to our agent is simply through Claude Code skills. And so, as we go through the architecture of the second brain here.
I think you guys will, like, really see quickly and grasp quickly how simple this actually is under the hood. I mean, there's a reason that I'm going to be able to build most of this second brain with you guys in just 4 hours. We might go a little bit over because of questions, and I'm totally good for that, with that, by the way.
Um, and it's not like in 4 hours, we're gonna get something that's just as good as my second brain that I use for myself, but the point is more that, like, we're gonna have a foundation that would be good enough to call a second brain, and it would immediately be useful to you guys. And then.
kind of how I see it is, like, after this 4-hour workshop, you guys have a starting point, or you've taken inspiration from certain components here, and then over the next couple of weeks or couple of months, you just continue to evolve it. And we're creating the foundation here where it's very easy to evolve.
our second brain. That's another thing that I'll be sure to hit on with you guys quite a bit as we're building things here. And I'd love to answer questions on that as well.
Because one of the things that I'm really gonna have you guys guide in our workshop here is, um, by asking questions about, like, how do we actually evolve this for ourself? Or how do we make this even more personal to us? I want to hear from you guys.
During the Q&A time, like, what do you guys want your second brain to do for yourself? But I'd love to give you suggestions, and we can talk about that together. I'm sure there's ways that you guys want to use a second brain for yourself that I haven't even thought of for myself before, so I would love to just have.
time for that, at least a few times throughout our four hours here, to just talk about use cases, right? Like, I shared at the start some of the ways that I like using my second brain, but there are certainly a million ways that we can use it. Even just some random things, for example.
I don't show it here in the core layer, because this… I wanted to keep more general, but I actually use my second brain to help me, um… it keeps me accountable for my habits. There are 5 core habits that I want to, you know, kind of check off every single day, and it keeps me accountable.
I have it, like, help me manage my investments, and, like, uh, things that I have to take care of at home, so it does things for my personal life, not just my business. Like, over time, I've just built more and more capability over time, and it's very easy to do so, because I have things created in a very general way, where it's easy to add new skills.
It's very easy to add new integrations. I'll talk about the templates that I have for that as well. And so, yeah, just, I want to talk to you guys about use cases for Second Brains as well.
So, alright, that's an overview of why you should build your own, what we're going to get into today. So, yeah, like I said, I want to really just cover the infrastructure at a high level, and then we're going to immediately get into using that PRD skill.
And so we'll fill out this template, and then we're just going to start building. It's gonna be a blast.
All right, and so before we do that, I'm just going to take a pause here and see what kinds of comments and questions we have. So, mostly I'm going to be doing that while Claude code is running, but just because we're not getting into that quite yet, I want to make sure that we have a chance for this here.
And then one other thing that I'll say… Is that, um, on my right monitor here, so I have the chat on the left monitor, that's when I'm looking there, and then on my right monitor, I have some notes here, uh, just to make sure that I hit on everything during the 4 hours, because trust me, guys, 4 hours is a lot of content to prepare. I want to make sure that I don't miss anything.
In fact, there is one important thing that I wanted to say, and that is… This whole process of building the second brain from scratch, I actually already did it. So I did a dry run of the entire workshop yesterday. I've built my entire second brain, and then I had Claude Code compare what I just built to what I have, like, running for myself, and make sure that it's not missing anything.
So, like, what we're doing today is the real deal. Like, I literally built it from scratch and made sure that the whole, like, Claude Code PRD skill that we're gonna walk through, like, doesn't actually miss anything, um, from what I built for myself. So, yeah. A lot of work I put into it.
Alright, so let's see what we got in the chat here.
All right. Funny Cole, I just built a massive PRD generator for helping people become full stack builders. Very cool. Including a PRD generator from code for older projects where the PMs have disappeared or the PRD was not kept up to date.
That is very cool. That's awesome. All right. Jeffrey said open claw is just hype. I mean, to an extent it is. I will say, though, that like a lot of my second brain, like I mentioned earlier, is taking inspiration from OpenClaw. So I would not recommend running it yourself.
But taking ideas from it is totally valid, and taking ideas from Hermes and NanoClaw and Ironclaw and all these other agents out there, it definitely is a good idea.
Also, Sean, I love the memes. Keep them coming. Let me address the elephant in the room. Man, I don't know how you do it, they're always so good.
And yes, OpenClaw is definitely vibe coded. I mean, we know that what's the guy's name? Peter? Peter Steinfeld? Isn't that the name of the creator of OpenClaw? The guy that got brought into OpenAI. Um, he has, like, 13 Codex instances running in parallel, like, any given time. He is pushing PR after PR, which is… It's cool to see in one sense, but in another sense, it is… when you look into the code base, it's pretty clear that there's a lot of over-engineering. It's one of the things that I try to avoid when I'm using AI coding assistants, and it's a big part of, like, what I talk about in the agentic coding course as well. It's like, here's how we build a system for not just, like, reliability, but avoiding some of the common pitfalls.
of coding agents like over-engineering. Um… lost some respect for Jensen when I saw him pedaling open claw in GTC.
And comparing it to the Linux kernel, oh, I know, yeah, I cringe a little bit when I saw that too, Sumit. It's unfortunate, because, like, from a marketing standpoint, like, I get it, I get it, but there has to be, like, a fine line of, like, how far you'll go to just, like, jump on whatever's gonna get the most attention.
And, um, I try to respect that line in my content a lot, which is why I never shared anything for, like, you know, Open Claw is amazing, let's run it, you know?
Alright. Jason said, Claude code deleted my entire program data folder on a Windows 10 system. Oh, when I was using it to help clean up an old Windows installation, after telling it to explicitly never touch that folder. Rules are one thing, but enforcing specific file permissions, exactly. That's what we'll talk about with hooks in this workshop.
And configuring Claude to use a specific user based on the terminal login is the safest thing I found to protect after that. Yeah, that's a good lesson, Jason. I'm sorry… I'm really sorry you had to learn that the hard way. But yeah, when we talk about how we use hooks, especially when we get into the security layer that I have towards the end of our workshop.
We'll talk about how we can enforce deterministic checks to prevent Claude from accessing folders outside of its working directory and, you know, reading environment variable files. We'll get into all of that, because that's a really, really important part of a second brain, is making sure that we enforce things through rules, deterministic rules, not just prompting, because prompting.
is not enough. Like, that unfortunate example that Jason just gave us here.
Uh, Roman said, can this second brain agent work with local LLMs instead of Claude code? And the answer is 100%, because actually, you can run Claude code with local models, because you, um, Ollama actually has a direct integration with Claude Code.
I don't want to dive into this right now just for the sake of time, but if you just do a little bit of Google searching or ask Claude about the Ollama integration, you can run your models through Ollama and then have Cloud Code use that instead of going out to the frontier Anthropic models. And then I believe there are ways to use other providers. If you want to use, you know, like Llama CPP or Light LLM or something instead.
of Ollama directly, then you definitely can as well. And so, everything that I cover here for building a second brain, I, um… I mean, security is important to me. I'm okay, personally, just having everything go out to the Anthropic API.
But if you do want to… be really careful about, um, you know, working with your private information. I totally respect that, and so it's not going to be a big focus of our workshop here, especially because I knew that people would be asking questions like you are right now, and I appreciate that. And so, I just want to address it more briefly and say, like, it is 100% possible, because even Claude code itself can be used with local models, so.
If you want to keep your entire second brain running locally, there is absolutely nothing stopping you from doing that. It's very easy to make those changes, and that's one of the things that you can even customize in the PRD that we'll go through in a bit.
Um, Carsten said, I'm having my second brain agent suggest my most valuable next to do. That is right. That's the beauty of a second brain, is not only does it save you time right when you first build it, but it saves you more time over time, because it can literally tell you.
Like, based on what I see you doing day to day, here's how I think I can help even more. And we can build a proactive part of the agent that will, like, literally self-evolve itself, be like, oh, I noticed that I could, like, help you draft a lot of emails here, and you don't have that built in yet. Like, let me go ahead and just build that in, validate it, and now going forward, I'll help you draft emails.
It's really cool what you can do for just the self-evolution.
All right. Very cool. So, yeah, there's a lot of questions that.
That we got in the chat here. I do want to make sure… I want to make sure that I get through things at a good pace, so I don't know if I'll be able to ask all questions. Um…
So, yeah, I will say that, like, going forward, when you guys have a question, make sure, uh, what I want to do for this workshop here is make sure that you ask it in the Q&A part of Zoom. So, I'll show what it looks like, um… well, actually, I'll just explain it really quick. So, if you click on the More.
And the three dots that says more in your bottom middle in Zoom, then you can open up the Q&A.
And this is just gonna be easier for me to organize all the questions, so that, like, you guys can still chat with each other just, like, directly in the Zoom chat, and then it doesn't have to, like, convolute with all the questions as well.
So, like, one example here, we actually do have a question from JG. Can we use the second brain, a second click like answer live here. Can we use the second brain in a team? In your opinion, what should we change so that several users in an organization can use it safely and effectively?
So, that is a really good question. I'd love to address that before we get into things here. So, I use my second brain just for myself, but there's nothing stopping you from having multiple people with access to it, and.
I've kind of done that to an extent. It's a bit different because she's my wife, and so I kind of want to give her access to everything. But Sydney, my wife, she can talk to my second brain through her own Slack account as well.
So one of the things that I built into my second brain is, uh, there's, like, an environment variable, like a configuration option that just has, like, a comma-separated list of the Slack user IDs, the people that are allowed to converse with my agent. So if my… if my second brain receives a.
message in Slack, it's gonna check it against that list, and only if it matches in that list will it, uh, you know, give a response. Now, when she talks to it, it doesn't really know that it's her versus me, and that's okay, because I kind of just want her to use it as an extension.
uh, like, kind of, like, she using it just like I use it. But if you wanted to make it so the second brain would, like, actually recognize, like.
you know, this is team member A, here are the things they're working on. This is team member B, here are the things they're working on. Then you'd have to have some kind of separation of memories between users. That's outside of the scope for our second brain here, but it would be pretty easy to extend everything that I built right now.
to make that possible. Like, when we create the PRD together, you'll see how you can, like, talk to Clonako and say, like, hey, I actually want, like, a whole team to use this, and I want to be able to, like, have the second brain understand, like, this is Jeremy talking, or, you know, like, this is Pavel talking, like, it is different people.
Um, and so then they maybe could even have, like, separate memories, because it could basically be, like, your database could have a filter, um, based on the Slack user ID, so you'd only search through those memories, or access these folders in your Obsidian Vault or Notion, or wherever you're storing information for your team.
So, definitely possible. And then, um, for the starter repo, Bart asked about the repo. Yeah, so in the description, and Rasmus asked about this as well. So in the description for our event, I'll put a link to this in the the Zoom chat right here.
I have a link to the full implementation of my second brain for your reference. This is a more general implementation, but it has, like I said, literally everything that I have in my second brain. I even verified it when I built it fully from scratch. And so this is something you can reference if you want.
But also, I am going to show you how to build it fully from scratch with the whole PRD process we'll get into. So, yeah, all right.
And if the link doesn't work for you for whatever reason, then there is a form that you have to fill out to get access to the GitHub repository, so I just saw your comment there, Ben. I'm going to go ahead and paste in the link, so you have to fill out this form in order to get access to.
the GitHub organization for Dynamis, and then all the links will work for you. So, if it says 404 not found, it doesn't mean the link's broken, it means you don't have access. I don't know why GitHub doesn't just give you a access error. It's a little annoying. But just make sure you fill that out. Yep, you're welcome.
Yeah, and so once you do that, fill that out, you're going to get an invite sent to your email, and then also, if you go to the home page of the GitHub organization, it should auto-direct you there. Then there's a banner for you to accept the invite, and if something doesn't work, you enter in the wrong GitHub email or something for… by accident, you can just feel free to message me, and I'll take care of it for you after.
All right. Cool. So, uh, yeah, a lot of questions that I'll get into once Claude Code is working for us here, but let me go back to the diagram, and we'll dive into a brief overview of everything that we have. I just want to give you guys an introduction to the different components.
And then, obviously, we'll expand on things a lot when we actually build it. And so, while we're waiting for Claude Code to finish, I'll be answering questions, but then also, like, getting into some of the nitty-gritty details that I think are really, really important. There are so many, even, like, smaller lessons that I learned that made a huge difference for me.
that I want to pass on to you guys. Like, for example, how we do the whole memory promotion process. So, if you guys have heard of the Claude Code Dream feature, and, like, the auto-dreaming, we actually have that built into the second brand. It's one of the things we'll build, so I'll talk about what that looks like as well.
So, the first thing, and this is actually heavily inspired by OpenClaw. We have our memory layer. This is one of the things that we're going to cover first. I store all of my memory layer within an Obsidian vault.
So, Obsidian, this is the platform that we're looking at right here. It's my local note-taking second brain application. It's very similar to Notion. You don't have to be using Obsidian for this workshop. You probably already have some place where you're storing documents, like Notion.
or Google Drive, whatever that might be, you can certainly integrate your agent to work anywhere. The reason that I use and recommend Obsidian is because everything is simply stored as markdown documents in our local system, which makes it very fast to access and easy for us to manage, and Obsidian gives me the canvas.
to view things really easily. Like, my diagrams and research and everything that I'm producing with my second brain, PDF documents, PowerPoints, I can view it all right in Obsidian.
So that's my recommendation, but the larger point here is regardless of where you're storing your memory layer, we have core files that dictate how our agent operates, and this is the biggest thing that we evolve over time, because we want our agent to remember all of our interactions.
We want it to extract lessons automatically from tasks that we assigned to it or things that we did with it. That's what we're going to be building at the start of our workshop here, or the start of, like, the live build part. And so we have our soul.md. This is the core identity file for our second brain.
And so we're going to actually use a Claude code hook, a session start hook, so that whenever we begin a new session with Claude Code, either on our computer or even remotely in Slack, it's going to automatically inject these core markdown documents, its core memory.
The soul.md that speaks to its nature. We get to, like, kind of describe its nature.
And then also all the core information about us.
And so the user.md is also very important, because it's essentially our user profile, so it knows our name, our time zone, our email, core IDs for our platforms, like here's my project ID in Asana, or here's my folder ID in Google Drive, where I store all my YouTube videos, like whatever that might be.
We get to store that core information here. And we could just shove all of this into a claude.md. It could just all be global rules. You can think of a lot of this like global rules, but it's useful for us to keep things more organized into files that have a very clear purpose, right? So that's why we have this separation here.
And then the memory.md, this is a really cool file because we're going to automatically build this over time. Every single conversation we have with Claude Code or with whatever coding agent for your second brain, we're going to extract the key lessons and things into a daily logs file.
So we build up this log over time. I'll even show you guys what this looks like. Like, for every single day, all of my conversations, we have a daily log where it remembers the key decisions that we made in our different conversations. The problem is the daily log gets very, very large, so we don't want to just, like, dump everything into the memory.md.
Because this is loaded into the coding agent up front, so this is where we only store our most important memories, the really crucial decisions that we've made and lessons that we've learned.
And so this is where I have something set up very similarly to the Claude Code Dream feature, where we have this daily reflection process that runs. So I run it once a day. You could run this overnight, so it's literally dreaming, but what it does is it looks through the raw daily logs. This has, like, all of the information from our conversations.
And it figures out what's worth keeping? What are the super critical decisions or lessons or important facts, and then it puts that in the memory.md. And so over time, we build up the very key information. But then, the other thing is we can still search through our daily logs if we want. So there's a little bit of RAG that happens in our second brain. This is how OpenClaw actually works as well.
So we have a hybrid search, it's both semantic search through a vector database, and then also keyword search.
That is how we're able to still look through all of our daily logs. So, it gets very informationally dense over time as you're using this day in and day out, and so that's why we want RAG, and not just having it look through all the files, because it's going to be hundreds of thousands, millions of tokens.
As you're using your agent for months and weeks.
And so, with the search, it is able to access everything that we've done in the past, but then it still has very quick recall for core decisions. That's the distinction that we are making here.
And then, um, what we are also doing with Claude Code hooks is, um, every time we're about to compact a conversation, or right after a session ends, and again, we're doing this both when we talk to our agent on our computer and also remotely through Slack or wherever you want to hook it up.
Well, we do at session end and memory compact is we're going to send the conversation into a separate Claude Code instance using the Claude Agent SDK.
So right here, we gather the conversation history, right? Like, we read the transcript, and then we have what I call the memory flush system. We take our summaries of the conversations, that's what we put in the daily logs. So we're not just dumping the entire conversation, because that'd be way too much even for daily logs.
And that's one of the things we'll build together. Like, I'll show you what that actually looks like.
And then we have our direct integrations, so this is Module 4. We'll get into that towards the end of the first half of our workshop here. This is how we give our agent the eyes into our life, right? Like, being able to access our email, our calendar, task management, whatever you want.
We'll talk about what it looks like to build any integration into our second brain. And there's even, like, a template that I have in the repository to give you guys a starting point, like a template for Claude to build any integration for itself. So the second brain, you can just say, like, I want to add this new integration, and it can just do the web research.
do the implementation, do the validation, and add in any integration without you really having to lift a finger at all. You probably just have to handle the authentication, and that's about it.
And then, um, through the integrations, it's kind of tied closely to the skills, because the skills are how we give capabilities to our agents. So the integrations is connecting it to the platforms. Now, the skills is defining our workflows. How do we want it to help us research or create YouTube scripts?
or build diagrams, right? And there's a lot of examples that I have for you guys for skills. So, getting into the second half of the workshop, that's when we'll talk about adding in skills, and we'll even have a skill that tells our second brain how to work with our integrations, right?
That's how we make that connection there. And skills are very common in Claude code, so I'm going to assume that you guys in general understand the basics of Claude Code skills. If anyone has any questions for how that works when we get to it, we definitely can, but I more just want you guys to, like, use the references that I have, the starting points that I have for all of my skills, and then build your own on top of that. Just taking inspiration from these ideas.
Again, I want you to really personalize this as much as you want. If you're building live with me here, or just taking ideas. Everything here is really for your inspiration.
And so, as far as the memory search pipeline goes, we'll talk about that when we build the whole searching functionality. So, I'm going to keep the RAG pretty basic. We're literally just using SQLite, so you don't have to go set up some other database or anything, there's no prerequisite for that. I'm keeping things as simple as possible. Openclaw actually also works the same way, where they just use SQLite.
There's no need to overcomplicate things with setting up, you know, like, Quadrant or Pinecone or Postgres or something like that. You definitely can if you want, but you don't have to.
And then we also have the chat interface. So this is going to be in the second half of our workshop as well, where we'll create the chat interface. I use Slack, but it's going to be very easy for you to adapt this to use something else like WhatsApp or Telegram if you would like.
And then the last, like, really big part of our second brain here is the heartbeat. This is the proactive part of our agent.
And so you can do whatever you want with your heartbeat, but mine, it checks all of my platforms every half hour. So it looks at my email, my calendar. It looks at our community here in Dynamis, and it alerts me for anything that really, really needs my attention.
I'm generally good at being on top of things, even without my second brain, but man, this has made it even easier to manage things and help me sift through, especially with my inbox, like, things that I don't necessarily want to pay attention to.
And it even will do things like draft replies to my emails. And I haven't done this yet. You could if you want, but you could, like, create issues in a GitHub repository and then have your agent, like, proactively create pull requests for those issues. Like, you could have it so your second brain handles that automatically.
Maybe even using the Archon CLI. So talking about Archon with the second brain, that is outside of the scope of our workshop here, but I will be doing follow-up workshops talking more about how we can integrate our second brain with Archon to handle coding tasks proactively.
And you could, of course, build that without Archon as well, just trying to give some examples here. But the cool part about the heartbeat is I actually load context from my integrations deterministically. It's very token efficient, because as much of the process as I can take away from the agent, I actually do.
And so it finds my latest emails that I haven't replied to, the latest posts in our community, things like that. It gathers all that context, and then it sends it in as a large prompt to the Claude Agent SDK. So you can see that I color-coded everything in the diagram, like this is in purple.
Uh, because it is using the client agent SDK. We're not talking to Claude code directly, because this is running as a background task, as a cron job. So we gather information from the APIs, and we have Claude reason about that, performing actions on our behalf, and then I always have it send me a notification in Slack, and so I call that my heartbeat.
Because it's giving me a pulse on my business and on my life, and helping me know, like, things that it just took care of, and things that need my attention. And I've made it very, very efficient.
I've actually tracked the cost of things. However, I am also using my Anthropic subscription, so it's not like this is really costing me anything beyond what I just pay normally monthly to cloud code in the first place. But I have done a lot for my second brain to optimize the cost of things as well.
And then we also have the Vault sync, so when I get into the remote deployment of the second brain at the very end of our workshop, we'll talk about this. And so that way I don't even have to, like, pay for the Obsidian Sync subscription or anything, I just have it use Git to sync the changes to my vaults remotely, like whenever I'm talking to my second brain in Slack and changing things there.
It automatically syncs to the vault that I have running locally. Like, what we are looking at right here. Like, this is my vault, these are all my memories running on my local machine.
Um, so yeah, and then we'll get into the security as well. I'm going to actually knock out the security and infrastructure in parallel at the end of our workshop here, just for the sake of time, and both of them are actually pretty simple overall to implement, following the PRD.
All right. Cool. So that is an overview of everything that we're going to build here. And hopefully, like even just seeing the different components here already gives you guys some inspiration and some ideas for things you can do like how I built in the whole dream thing automatically and how I'm using.
integrations and skills, and even using skills to tell my second brain how to use my integrations, and the whole, like, RAG thing for the daily longs, like, I hope you guys can see a lot of good stuff there, but obviously throughout our workshop here, I'm going to make it extremely concrete for you guys, because you get to see it built live, and ask all the questions that you need.
And so, um, the last thing that I want to cover… Before we get into our PRD here.
is I want to cover the… kind of, I guess, like, a second elephant in the room. So I talked about OpenClaw, but I also want to talk about using your Anthropic subscription. Just really quickly here, because I know that people are going to have questions on this.
So within the last couple of months. There have… there's been a lot of controversy around using your Anthropic subscription with the Claude Agent SDK.
This is how we invoke Claude code programmatically. for the more autonomous parts of our second brain, like our heartbeat and our memory reflection. So this is a core part of what we're building today.
And the Anthropic docs, they had some update that made it seem really clear that we were banned from using our Anthropic subscription with the Claude Agent SDK. As in, we had to use an Anthropic API key and pay per token, which is a lot more expensive. We don't want to have to do that if we don't have to.
Um, so it looked a little doom and gloom. But then Tariq, he's on the team from Anthropic.
he made a clarifying statement through X, and I'm kind of just taking his word for it here. I think we really can, though. I'll talk about that in a… I'll talk about why in a second here, but he said that nothing is changing how you can use the agent SDK and Mac subscription.
We want to encourage local development and experimentation with the Asian SDK and Claude-p. And building a second brain, it is a personal application. It falls under local development. And so I am very confident, and this is what I do for myself, you are allowed to use your Anthropic subscription with the Agent SDK.
As long as other people aren't using your second brain. So if you have a team member that wants to start using your second brain, or you're building it for a team, then I would actually argue that you do have to use the API key instead. Like, they say here, if you're building a business on top of the Asian SDK.
Then you should use an API key instead. Because at that point, what they mean by building a business on top is, like, this is a product, now you have other people using your subscription, they don't want that kind of abuse. And they have left their documentation very vague and kind of contradictory, and I think that's more just so they have an excuse to ban people that are using their subscription through OpenClaw and open code and those things that they're not allowing.
But I've been using my subscription with the Claude Asian SDK for the last 3 months now, and even beyond that, before my second brain, with Archon and other applications, and as long as it's running on your own machine, then it's local development, or running in a machine in the cloud that you control, and it's your code base, then you are good.
And there is certainly some gray area with that.
But, um, to my knowledge, everything that I have in the second brain, you are 100% good to use. And if there's anything really specific that maybe you would have to use your API key instead, or you have other people using your brain, it's certainly going to be easy to use your API key instead.
That's just a configuration change. There's nothing you have to change in your code itself, and I did, like I said, I did a lot of work to make sure that things are quite token efficient, especially, like, with the heartbeat system. A lot of work I put into that over the last couple of months. It used to cost like.
a dollar per run, instead of 5 cents, because I used to have it actually, like, do all the gathering of information through the agent instead of deterministically. So, a lot of optimizations there.
All right. Very cool. So I'm going to take a pause for some questions here. Again, and then we're going to get right into creating our PRD. And this is where you guys can really start to follow along. And we're going to be building things from scratch. So just give me a moment to look through the chat here.
And we'll do a little bit of time for Q&A.
Kashik said, if you use a hook, you need to use the agent SDK. So is it okay to use the SDK programmatically? For that aspect, I think we should be good. Yep, so if you're calling Claude through a hook, like we'll actually do for our whole memory flush thing, I… again, I use my subscription. I don't have to use the Anthropic API key for that.
Um, okay, so Ivo asked, when do you expect to publish the video from this workshop? You said you'd be taking snippets for a new course, but is the unedited workshop video going to be available like the others? Yep, so our recording here, the unedited version, I'll have that within 24 hours, just posted in the description for the event.
It's only going to be the more edited one that would be probably, like, sometime next week. It'll be a good amount of effort to edit it down, but I'll try to get that pretty soon as well. But yeah, the recording, the full 4-hour recording, if you guys are only here for part of the workshop or whatever, will be available.
later today. Uh, it takes a while for Zoom to process for our meetings, I've learned, so it won't… definitely won't be for a bit today, but it'll be, like, before tomorrow morning, basically.
All right. Um, oh, okay, Danny asks, is there any connection from this second brain with Tiago Forte's second brain? So, I have… I've heard a lot about Tiago Forte.
But I have not actually studied his content, or his second brain. So I would not say there's really a connection. But this is a cool opportunity to say something. Thiago Forte, he actually just started a cohort.
teaching people how to build a second brain. But believe it or not, in order to join that cohort, it is $3,000. I'm sure that it's very, very comprehensive. And so maybe it's not like totally fair to just, like, say this, but it's like, you guys get to build your own second brain.
With me right now, and all you have to do is be a part of the Dynamist community. And I'm giving you guys something that saves me 20 hours a week. I don't know if, like, Thiago Fortes would save, like, 40 hours a week, but I really doubt it, right? So he's charging 3 grand to be a part of the cohort.
It's kind of crazy. So yeah, I mean, I've heard good things about.
Thiago Forte, I've never met him, but I met, like, his… actually, kind of funny, um, in Jan… or February, I met his, like, personal assistant in person, which is kind of cool. So, I'm sure he's a very respectful guy, but, like, man, $3,000 for a cohort is like.
Really? Like, come on. So, yeah, it's funny that you bring that up, Danny. So, yeah, not really any connection here, but, uh, yeah, I mean, they're probably good ideas to take from that as well, honestly. And that's the thing that I'm really trying to, like, bring home for you guys here, is that, um… Building a second brain is all about just, like, taking ideas from how other people are using it. Like, that's what I'm trying to give a ton to you guys right now, even if you already have your second brain, just more and more ideas. And, excuse me, and, like, taking inspiration from, you know, Thiago Forte's Second Brain, if you follow his YouTube content, or if you do actually join the cohort.
and pay the $3,000. Or if you're, like, looking at OpenClaw or Nemo Claw or whatever. So, just so many different ideas, and your second brain can handle more integrations and more skills. We're gonna be building something that's very scalable, so you don't have to be.
worried about, like, if I add this integration, am I gonna start overwhelming my second brain? It's really not gonna work like that. So, the world is your oyster for what you're able to build into it.
All right. Josh asked, uh, what options would you recommend for something more private than Slack? Will this work with Matrix? Claude code natively doesn't work well with Matrix.
So, the kind of easy answer to your question, Josh, is that any platform is going to work.
Because we're not relying on Claude code working with the platform. And this is like really important to specify. We'll talk about this more when I build the chat platform towards the end of our workshop, but the chat platform is just the entry point into the Claude Agent SDK.
So, all Slack does for me is it gives me a way to send a message into Claude code. So within my Python code, I receive the message from Slack.
And then I prompt it… I prompt the Claude Agent SDK with it. And so, my second brain, it doesn't actually really know that I'm using Slack. It literally doesn't care. That's just my kind of way to get to it, right? Like, when I'm on my phone.
And I don't want to use the Claude code CLI directly like I'm doing on my desktop because on my phone, I don't really have that, right? So there's a clear delineation there where there's not, like, some MCP server or some kind of, like, integration or connection that we're doing between our chat platform.
and the Claude Agent SDK. So, you should be able to use Matrix. You can use Microsoft Teams, WhatsApp, Telegram, GitHub, I mean, the world is your oyster for, yeah, like Danny said, Discord, you could definitely do Discord to talk to your second brain as well.
I have not set up my second brain with anything except for Slack, but I have set up Archon with Discord and other platforms, and so it's similar for… because they both use the Cloud Asian SDK under the hood. So certainly, you'll be able to do whatever you want.
So when we create our PRD in a little bit here, that would just be one of the things that you specify. And actually, if I go into the template here.
There is a place where you specify like exactly the integrations that you want, and, like, this is where you can say, like, I want to use Microsoft Teams in order to talk, like, for chat messaging, I want to use Discord, I want to use Teams, I want to use Slack, like, you can specify that, and then my skill is going to, like, automatically customize the PRD, so, like, that will be your remote entry point into.
the Claude Agent SDK, or whatever SDK you're using. Again, you could use, like, Codex or OpenCode or something if you wanted to.
All right. Um, okay, so… Let's see, someone mentioned the master.env. So the master.env, that's something a bit more specific to me.
That's, uh, so he's talking about this master.enb.example. This is, like, super specific to me.
One of the things that maybe I shouldn't have included in… it's not like this, because this is just the .env.example.
So, it's not like I have my secrets in here or anything, but this is, like, really specific to my setup. I don't think that it's worth covering this too much right now, because as you build out your own second brain, it'll let you know, like, okay, we need to set up these environment variables for Slack, and it can guide you through that.
And then you'll build up your own environment variables over time. So I don't necessarily need to, like, cover this whole thing. So, yeah, definitely, like, with the template that I have for you guys, I probably went, like, a little overboard with what I'm including, where it's like, yeah, that's a little specific to Colt. Like, I probably don't need to care about that part. That's one of those things.
Um, so yeah, let me say, like, trust me guys, it was really, really hard to take my entire second brain.
And, um, take out all the parts that are, like, really awkwardly specific to me. Like, this is a good example where it's like, Cole, what the heck is this? Like, this is, like, awkwardly specific to me, with all of my different environment variables for things like circle, and… and I have, like… like, what… I have, like, some things prefixed with CE, that's short for content engine.
And then I have some things that it's short for, um, or where is it? Um… Where's my video processor?
I don't know, I'm… see, I get lost in this myself sometimes, but yeah, so don't worry about some of those, like, really specific things. And you can always, like, ask Claude Code to explain the setup workspace script. This is like another thing that's really specific to me.
You can see that, like, I tried to make it general so it doesn't, like, call out just my username, but, like, you don't have this repository, right?
So again, this whole repo is meant to be a reference for you, not something that you're going to set up directly. And that's why we're gonna go through and create things from scratch with a PRD here.
All right. Um, David said, how can I share my brain on two computers? I have five on the network with Tailscale, okay? Three for me, 2 for my remote team members. Currently, my brain's on a Git repo, and there's a bit of a push-pull going on, but I want an improved system.
Gotcha, yeah. So, I have two computers accessing my second brain, because I have it running locally, and then I also have it deployed to a VPS on DigitalOcean.
And, um, I think for the most part, David, I will answer your question when I get to the whole VPS deployment and a Vault sync.
So I don't want to get, like, too deep into the question right now, because I think that, like, it'll just be much easier to explain things, like, as I'm actually building it.
But, uh, really, it's like, wherever you store your information, you just need to make sure that there's a sync process, or a way for both computers or, like, multiple computers to not override each other.
Otherwise, though, it's just going to be the same as using Claude code across multiple devices. Like, they can work on the same repository or the same notion or the same Obsidian if you have Vault Sync set up.
Um, yeah, so you just want to make sure that, like, wherever you're storing your memories and managing all of that, like, you have some sort of real-time sync set up between your different devices, because you don't want them to feel like they're working in isolation. So, all of my… memory files and daily logs and everything. I have that all synced in Obsidian, so when I'm… when I, you know, tell my second brain, like, hey, I want you to remember this important thing about me, and it goes and updates the user.md.
within, I believe, 2 minutes is, like, the timer that I have where it runs the get sync. Within 2 minutes, my user.md will be updated, you know, here locally as well.
So, yeah. Oh, I got rid of the diagram on accident. Let me open that back up here.
There we go. All right. Yeah, so this is… this is my user.md.
I'm not really, um, worried about, like, showing it here, because it doesn't have, like… this is, um, the business address for Dynamis, that's not my address. I don't live in Texas, you guys know that I live in Minnesota.
Uh, but yeah, I'm just showing you, like, a little bit of what it looks like here. So, like, key points, like, or key project, like, these are the things that I'm working on. Here's my, you know, current role within my business, right? Like, your user on MD, you can track whatever information you want to. Um… Very flexible for how you use these memory documents. So definitely you can take inspiration from how I do it, or you can just, you know, tell in your PRD, like, I want it to remember these things, and these things, and ask me about these things.
All right. Okay, so I'll answer a couple more questions here, and then we will get right into creating our Prd.
So Sunol said, I just joined Dynamis community a few days back. Well, welcome to Dynamis, by the way, planning my app with a local host Llm model. Want to power off my computer every night and start back again. Is it possible to do that by remembering what was discussed before powering off?
I did the same on ChatGPT, but at the end, uh, it forgot lots of stuff.
Yeah, so this is where conversation history comes in. So whenever you're talking to your agent through Claude Code or Ollama chat, or if you built your own, whatever it is, you want to, like, store the conversation somewhere. Like, Claude Code is going to handle that for you, or if you're building your own agent, then you'll store.
the short-term memory in a database, so you can resume the conversation.
So, Sunil, I don't know if this is, like, a second brain question exactly. It might be something that's better fit for our office hours that I have every single week, because if you're using Claude code, then you don't really have to worry about the conversation tracking yourself, because they store the messages in their own database.
So, it sounds like you're building something kind of different, like a separate AI agent. So I'd be happy to, like, answer more questions, or even, like, dive into that with you in next week's office hours. That's definitely what the office hours are for.
Um, yeah. All right. Jason said, which repo are you starting from? Can you share the link?
Yeah, I'll put the link. Well, actually, um, Brandon sent the right link, so yeah, thank you, Brandon.
Um, and then lock what you shared, that's a… that's a good link as well, but that's for the public YouTube video that I put out. Now, it is, like, a very, very similar, um, Claude Second Brain PRD skill.
And so, yeah, I'll just go to my browser here.
So, within the link that Brandon sent, um, we have the Claude code second brain, and then within .claude.
skills… we have the Create Second Brain PRD. This is what I'm about to use right now to build it from scratch.
So, if you guys want to follow along with me, you can clone the repository, and then you can copy this create secondbrain PRD skill, and you can bring it into a new folder that you create on your system. And, uh, that is exactly what I have here.
What you're looking at right here… This is where we're going to be working in for the rest of our workshop, and we build it from scratch. I have my .claude folder, and then within it, I have all of the commands from the agentic coding course, because we're going to go through PIV loops to build this in phases, and then I have the create secondbrain PRD skill.
in the .clad skills directory. So if you want to start from scratch like me, I would recommend having exactly this setup as well.
And, um, by the way, all of the commands are also here in the commands folder. So everything that you need to copy, and if you want to follow along exactly with me, that is all available in the link that Brandon sent, the Claude Code Second Brain folder.
In our workshop repo here.
All right. Cool. So yeah, I'm going to go ahead and continue here. Let's go ahead and create our PRD. And I'll keep getting to more questions as we have time as we wait for Claude code.
So, I'm here in a brand new session with Claude Code. If you have copied over the skill here.
Then what you want to do is open up the My Second Brain Requirements Markdown document, and just fill this out. This is your starting point to tell Claude Code or whatever coding agent you're using, what customizations you want. How do you want the second brain to act? What integrations do you want?
You can fill that out however. And so, just for the sake of brevity, because it's hard to, like, type things out and explain at the same time, I have actually already filled out a template that I'm going to use today.
So, um, I'm going to fill this out, or I did fill this out in exactly how I would have for my own second brain. So I'm gonna build, like, pretty much the same second brain I use for myself, same integrations, using Obsidian, but you can answer however you need to.
Um, so I'll just kind of, like, go through this quickly, and you guys can fill this out at the same time if you want, or if you just want to follow along with me, definitely feel free.
So I just gave some information about me. You can kind of just, like, specify whatever you want here. It's totally up to you. If you wanted to add more things, you could. So, my name, I'm the, you know, founder of Dynamis, what I do daily, I build agents and automations for AI coding and teach others how to do the same.
Got a little bit of an elevator pitch for me. Um, so, as far as, like, the vault folder name, let's just call this, uh.
Dynamis Workshop. All right. I actually want to change that from the dry run that I did, because I want to make sure I don't have an overlap for my Obsidian vault.
And then you can specify the platforms that you're using. So you can say, like, you know, X. I'm using email, and then I filled out and saying that I'm using Gmail specifically. So you could use Outlook, or maybe you're not using email at all, whatever it is. I'm using Google Calendar. Asana is where I do my task management. I'm sure a lot of you guys are using like linear or Jira or something or notion instead.
for my chat platform, this is where I'm using Slack, and so this is where, like, if you want to have a totally different setup than me, you can just specify these things here, and the PRD will automatically be custom when we run the skill command to actually create our PRD. So fill this out, then I'll show you what it looks like to run it.
I'm going to be using Obsidian to store my knowledge. Google Drive for my cloud storage. So whenever I need to, you know, like create a script for a sponsor and, like, share it with them, or share something with a team member, then I'll create it in Google Drive instead of Obsidian, right? So I can, like, share it through a URL.
or if I have, like, a Google Form that I need to create for one of our mini hackathon submissions or something like that.
And then, um, using GitHub for my code, my community is Circle. And then I don't actually use a CRM for anything. So I put that there because a lot of you probably would be, but you can also feel free to add any other kinds of platforms to this list if you'd want.
And then just to start to give an overview for our second brain for like what we want to actually do, I have a section here to list out, you know, three to five tasks that you'd want your second brain to handle proactively. Like, for me, I want it to.
draft emails to help me manage my inbox. This alone saves me so much time every single week. It's crazy how busy my inbox gets. Help me track deadlines, remind me of things before they're due, so I don't always have to be, like, super, super on top of my Asana.
Summarize what happened in Slack, monitor my community to what we guys have here at Dynamist to make sure there aren't anything that slip through. Because as much as I am in Dynamics with you guys every single day, there are once in a while those posts where it's like.
I thought I had replied, or, like, I looked at it at a bad time, so I moved on, or something like, this will catch it for me. It's really, really nice. And then also helping me keep my meeting notes organized and searchable.
So, the really important thing here is, like, for my second brain, and honestly, I probably should have said this, um, at the very beginning, is I am never using it to fully automate something that, like, you guys would ever see, right? Like, I'm not using an AI avatar, I'm not posting AI slop on LinkedIn, I'm not doing any of that. It's not replacing me.
But it's augmenting me. I use my second brain to research, organize, and ideate. Those three things. So it's going to help me with drafting emails, but I still send the email. It's going to help me organize my meeting notes, but it's not attending the meetings for me, I'm not doing anything crazy like that.
Uh, but it still saves me a lot of time just by helping me organize, ideate, and research.
All right, and then we have the proactivity level, so how bold you want your agent to be? This is pretty important, because some of you guys might want to start with it just kind of notifying you of things, or what I like is the advisor level. So it drafts things for my review, but it's never going to, like, do something end-to-end that it's going to be sent out to the world.
Or, if you wanted to, you could go as far as the partner. You could create an agent, and, like, a lot of people do this with their open claw. You could certainly build this for yourself. A lot of people want it to, like, actually do something end-to-end, like, fully send emails, or have an AI avatar join meetings, or make cold calls, or whatever it is.
Um, you can build that if you want, so I wanted to put that in there because then you can customize the PRD for that specifically.
And then security boundaries. Obviously, security is something very important that we'll cover a lot more at the end of the workshop as well. What do you want the agent to never do without explicit permission? So, you know, send emails on my behalf, post to social media, kind of going in line with productivity level, but just be more explicit here, I think really helps with the PRD.
And then the memory category is what types of knowledge matters to you most. Infrastructure. So, like, I'm running this on Windows, and then I'm going to also deploy it to a cloud server. And I'll show you what that looks like at the very end of the workshop here deploying to DigitalOcean.
And then, um, just integration priorities, just to help you… it'll kind of help create the phases of work in the PRD. So ranking the top 3 integrations, like, I care most about Gmail, Asana, and Slack to start, and then definitely all the other ones will come soon after.
So that is all you have to fill out here as your starting point. And again, that is just this file that I have. So within the link here, and I'll just link to this one more time.
So, within the… so I put that in the Zoom chat just now. So within the .clon… We have the skills directory, and you can just copy over the create second brain PRD. And hopefully, for those of you following along, you've already done that, and you have the template filled out here.
So, once you have your template filled out, now all you have to do… is go into your terminal and open up Claude code, and you want to open up Claude Code in this directory, right? So it has access to the create secondbrain PRD skill. So now I can do slash.
Create second brain PRD, and then you just have to give it a path to the template that you just filled out, the requirements. And so that is my coal second brain requirement. So I'll just copy the full path here. So just right click in VS Code, copy path, and then paste it in.
So again, open up Claude Code, where we have our skill, slash create secondbrain PRD, give it the path, and then we let it whirl. There we go. So it's not going to build anything right now, but it's going to create the full PRD. It's going to lay out all of the phases.
for us to build literally everything that I covered in the diagram here.
And the best part about this is I have this whole like architecture reference document. You guys don't have to care about this, but I'm just showing you behind the scenes how it works a little bit. And this has, like, all of the core components and even some of the gotchas and lessons that I had to learn along the way as I was building my own second brain.
So this PRD, it has a lot of things built in that'll save you time, right? Like, I went through it the hard way, now making it easier for you guys to build, because this PRD has the lessons built right in. And so when we have our coding agent go and build this phase by phase.
It's going to know about those things that, you know, cause me a world of hurt before. So, you guys get to go on the fast track here. That's the point of what I'm building for you guys here.
All right. So, I'll keep knocking out some questions, uh, while it builds the PRD here.
Danny said, can you have more than one option in the platform? 100%. Yep. This is flexible enough where you could say, like, I want to talk to it in Slack and Telegram, and it can certainly build that for you.
Yeah. Um, and then, Sean, I saw that you had your hand raised, but just for workshops, I usually don't like have anyone come off mute just to keep things chugging along nicely. So if you have a question, you can feel free to put it in the chat as well. I'll get to it for sure.
Alright, so, uh, question from Chris here. Are we okay to work on a VPS today, or is local better?
So it's easier to build your second brain locally at first. You definitely can create it right away on a VPS. I'm not discouraging you from doing so, but it would probably be a bit easier for you to follow along and just, like, in general, work on it if it's, uh, you know, just something that's on your computer.
Um… Brandon's saying, can you share the links again for where we can download the latest skills? I'm in the workshop tree, but I'm unsure which one I should be downloading. That is the most current and up-to-date. Yes, so, good question, Brandon. I'll go ahead and put a link to the skills in the Zoom chat again.
Everything that we have here is up-to-date. This has my Excalidraw diagram skill, my skill for, like, helping me ideate for a LinkedIn posts and creating PowerPoints and PDFs. All of this is up to date right now.
And I do want to, like, actually manage these and, like, keep them up-to-date over time as I evolve them for you guys as well. And I think I will… I might do it here, or I might actually create a separate repository in the Dynamis community, so that it's not just within the workshops repo.
I'm gonna figure out how I want to organize that to maintain it for y'all going forward, but I'd love for that to be a resource for everyone in the community, so that you guys can constantly evolve your second brain with me as well.
Alright. So, Steve asked, what are the best practices for running multiple second brains on a hybrid of cloud and local models? So we just have two different Obsidian vaults. Yeah, Steve, it really depends on if you want both second brains to access the same information.
But if you're working on a company or for a company or whatever, where there's multiple team members that all want to have their own second brains, I would recommend having separate Obsidian vaults. I think it makes sense to have complete isolation for each team member.
Like, for me and my wife, we… I mean, I only have one vault, because she's just using a second brain basically as me.
Um, but yeah, if you want people to have their own instance, basically, I would keep it fully separate. Like, you can host all of them on one machine in the cloud, but, like, separate vaults would be good.
Yeah. Uh, Carsten said, can I pin the comment of the URL? You know, I don't think you can pin in Zoom, unfortunately.
I'm looking at the options here, and I don't see it.
Yeah, I wish I could. Um, just know, though, that I link to it here in the description of the workshop, so I'll put this link in the Zoom chat as well, if you guys want to just have this popped up. It's always available for you guys to go here, and this is also where the recording is going to be posted after as well.
All right. And then, um, let me go back here. So we still got some agents running. Sandeep said, can I type the command you used to create the PRD? Yep. So it is slash create PRD.
Oops, let me copy that. Slash create PRD, and then path to your template.
That is the command that I used here. And also, it does show, it does say at the end of the template, it gives you the exact command. So after filling it out, you run slash create PRD path to this file where you just filled out the template.
and also I did control C, so I accidentally cut it off. So let me just tell it to continue here.
All right. So a question from Mike. Any thoughts on using the anthropic auto dream concept to reconcile your MD dedupe organized, standardized format or cross linking.
So that is a really good question. So Claude Code has built something quite similar to my whole memory flush and daily reflection system, because they have AutoDream, where it, like, looks through your conversations over time, and then it dreams, as in, like, consolidates information down into.
a smaller file, kind of like my memory.md. And the cool thing is, this is how humans actually work.
Because humans, they process a ton of information throughout the day, and then your brain, while you're sleeping, this is one of the reasons sleep is so important. It takes this onslaught of information from your day while you're awake, and it stores the important stuff deeper into your brain, so that you can recall it later on, more easily.
And so that's why Claude Code calls it Dream. Now, Mike, to answer your question, I'm not really thinking about integrating it, because I feel like I've already built everything that Claude code has with AutoDream. So when I show you guys building the memory layer and how we have this, like, promotion process from the daily logs into the memory.md, and then we're always loading the memory.md into the agent, like.
that has the exact same effect. Maybe there are some cool things I can learn from AutoDream, like the way that it organizes or standardizes, but anything that they do, we could build very easily into the whole daily reflection system that we have here. Like, if we want to, like, automatically.
do research based on things in the log, or like, you know, sort of, like, enhance the information. You could build all of that so easily, because one of the things that we'll talk about here as we're building is anytime you see room for improvement in your second brain, you don't have to.
spend a lot of time building that in. Like, you can just tell your second brain, like, hey, I noticed that you didn't do this very well, or I thought you were able to do this, but you're clearly not. Like, what can we do to make that happen? And it is just going to be able to knock it out so easily, because.
in building our memory layer, like, as we are building on our second brain, it's going to remember how we've evolved it. Like, it builds such a good, like, meta understanding, as I call it, like, it knows how it works. Its own internal working so well that, um, you don't really have to do much.
context curation when you go into building an improvement. Like, it just can kind of immediately dive into the implementation. So, we're definitely going to be using the PIV loop.
In order to build our second brain initially, like, I'll go through the priming process, and then planning, and then building, and validating, like, we'll go through that, but I will be honest, like, at this point with my second brain, whenever I want to build something new, I kind of just vibe code it. Like, I just say, like, hey, I want this new integration, or I want to talk in Telegram instead of Slack, and it can just knock it out so easily. I don't even have to.
do very much planning, because the memory layer, you know, the whole dreaming process, it literally just takes care of that. It's really cool.
Um, and yes, Renata, so I know you… I'm kind of behind on questions, so I'm… this is a question Renata sent at 1137 AM my time, but yes, that is the right URL. So, yeah, the cloud code second brain within the workshops directory in Dynamo, yep.
Um, Bob asks, are you hosting the CouchDB locally, or just local storage? So, I'm just hosting everything locally as markdown documents in Obsidian. I don't think I'm using CouchDB. I've heard that, like, Obsidian uses CouchDB under the hood, but, I mean, really, all this is just.
Markdown documents stored on my computer in a folder, and then I am using SQLite for the RAG part that we'll talk about when we get to that part of the memory layer.
Um, and then when I… I guess there's one caveat there. I have started to use Postgres, because I want my remote instance and my local instance to manage the same database, and using SQLite synced between two devices is a big pain.
So, what we're gonna build today is using SQLite, but I have evolved it to using Postgres so that I can have one database across different devices. So that is one caveat that's really important to mention, but it's very easy to transition from SQLite to Postgres. So again, it's just one of those things where it's like.
When you're ready to take your second brain and move it to the cloud, or start having other devices access it, you can just one-shot that. Like, so many of these things just start to become one-shottable, and, like, that's what I want to give you permission to do right here, is, like, just start… just start one-shotting stuff.
Once you have the foundation laid out. And I think that's actually a really good way to put it for our workshop here. Like, the eight modules that we're going to go through, and what we're going to build here in our four hours right now, that's going to be the foundation, where the agent's not really ready to self-evolve yet. Like, we're still going to be kind of hand-holding, going through piv loops here.
But then after our workshop, like if you follow along with what I have right now, after the workshop, you're going to be able to start one-shotting things so quickly, because you're going to have a standard for your skills and the proactive nature, and you're going to have a standard for your adapters and where you're talking to your agent.
So it can reference itself to build on top. It's really, really cool.
All right. Sean said, since you are using Obsidian, can you suggest how we can diverge and use agentic RAG, for example? What would a prompt look like?
Sean, I think you might have to elaborate there what you mean by agentic rag.
Can you suggest how we can diverge and use agentic RAG?
So, one thing I will say here is I am already using Agentic RAG.
Because hybrid search is an example of agentic RAG. So… And part of the reason I asked for elaboration is because agentic RAG, it can mean a lot of different things. The general idea is that you're giving your AI agent, or in this case, our second brain, the ability to search through knowledge in multiple different ways. So it can kind of figure out, like, what is ideal.
based on the user's question. So we have both semantic search and keyword search. That's agentic RAG, because it has two search strategies. And we can even use them together, because keyword search works really well when you have, like, a very specific word or ID or phrase that you want to find across your memories and your daily logs.
And then semantic similarity search is going to work better when we are trying to relate things conceptually in the question we have for our second brain. So it's good to have both. That is agentic RAG, and it's performing agentic RAG over everything we have stored in our Obsidian vault.
All right. Cool. So let's go back to Claude here.
And of course we'll keep going through questions as I can, but we have our plan now. We have our PRD it just created. So, 922 lines in total. It's going to be pretty comprehensive, because this is outlining all phases that we have here. So, it says 9 phases, but that's because I'm going to do the last two in parallel. So there really are 8 modules that I have, because I'm going to knock out the deployment and the.
security at the same time. So, uh, if you just had it go with the default path, it's going to create your PRD in the .agent slash plans folder. So right here, this is where we have our full scope of work for our document. What we have right now.
This is going to guide the entire implementation, the entire foundation, and then the sort of promise here is once you build everything here, that's when you're going to be able to just start one-shotting things in your second brain, like add this integration, add this adapter, whatever it is.
So we have our phase one. This is the memory layer here. Phase two is we're going to be adding in the hooks. And so, again, everything here is going to correspond directly to the sections that we have in the diagram here. And by the way, this diagram, as well as the other one for why we want to build our own second brain.
These are also both available in the workshop folder here. So I got those diagrams available.
So anyway, going back here, phase three is going to be our memory searching. So this is where we're going to have our hybrid or agentic RAG, if you will. And then phase four is going to be building in integrations. So adding in like Gmail and Asana and Slack, and you guys can customize this to be whatever you want.
And then, let's see phase five is adding in skills.
So that's going to be a nice and quick one.
Phase 6 is gonna be proactive systems. So this is where we add in our heartbeat and reflection, and the whole dreaming, memory promotion process. It gets very exciting with Phase 6, because that's when the agent starts to do things autonomously.
And then, uh, phase seven is going to be the chat interface, so I'll be adding in Slack. This is where you would add in Teams or Discord or whatever you're doing, maybe even multiple platforms, like someone asked about earlier.
Um, and then phase 8 is our security hardening, and then we're gonna do that at the same time as our deployment here.
So, all right, that is the plan. So we're gonna take this PRD and we're just going to shoot it off one phase at a time going through PIV loops. We're going to be following the exact same process that we have with the agentic coding course. Like we're going to build this just like I built the examples in the agentic coding course.
Also, Sean, I see so this happened, but, um, I'm in the browser for Zoom, so I can't actually see the image, if you sent an image. So, sorry, I'm not sure what you're referring to. Assuming it said same here, so I hope it's not, like, an issue you guys are dealing with.
Um… Block script can't yeah API keys and credentials must never enter the context window. Yep, so if you're using… If you're using my template, like, that is one of the protections I have for a pre-tool use, which is a good thing.
Oh, wait. Oh, it wasn't actually able to read your PRD?
The security hook blocked the write because the PRD contains literal patterns like cat.env.
Oh, okay, I got you, Sumit. Yeah, okay, so guys, if you are trying to run the command to create the PRD.
Make sure you don't have the Claude hooks yet. You don't want to have those yet, because we'll build them as a part of phase number two anyway. So you just want to take that out of where you're currently running the create PRD command. That's why I was being specific here, like, you don't necessarily want to, or I wouldn't recommend running it.
in the repo, like, if you guys cloned my repository here with my template, even though, yes, I have the skill right here and you can run it right here, that's why I recommend copying it out to a new folder. Like I did for our example here, because that way you really are starting from a blank slate.
Um, because, yeah, you guys ran into one of the very important hooks that I have for the second brain. We force Claude Code to not read from a .env, because we never want our API keys to go into the context window of the LLM. That's one of the big no-no's with OpenClaw, where they really suffer from that.
So I have a hook to enforce that, but it just makes it kind of inconvenient when sometimes it, like, blocks something that you don't want it to, but it's just a… it's a give and take, right? Like, it's one of the things we have to put up with, because we want it to be secure.
Um, Jason, you can have the other skills if you want. You could bring those in right away, but we're also going to do that as a part of Phase 5, so we'll bring them in when it comes time to, like, integrate that with the rest of our second brain.
Uh, Renata, the .agent folder is created automatically. So whenever you run, if you fill out the template for the PRD and then you run slash create secondbrain PRD, it makes this automatically because that's the default place it puts the PRD.
So if you go through this process, this whole process, it'll be there automatically.
All right. Cool. So, uh, Dom, credentials will come throughout the phases. So, like, the first time we'll deal with credentials will be phase four, when we do our direct integrations.
Alright, and then, uh, Danny asks, can I please share all of my Obsidian plugins? Yes, I'd love to. So let me go to that really quick. So settings, plugins. There's not too many that I use, because I actually like to keep it quite simple.
These are… so, okay, actually quite a few of these I don't even use. The main one that I use is the Excalidraw. Like, actually, I really don't use any of the other ones. The Excalidraw Obsidian plugin is the only one I'm really using. I've experimented with a couple of other ones. I guess Iconize is really good as well.
Because that gives me the nice icons here, like, more than what you can do by default in Obsidian, so I guess those are the main two that I'm using, these two, but otherwise, I've tried experimenting with other ones, and, like, they just aren't that necessary for the way that I work.
A lot of them, like, the, um, commander and Quick Add and tasks, like.
My second brain is managing so much for me, and Obsidian is just where, like, I'm storing and connecting info that I just, like, don't need the UI to be very verbose for me, or very robust, if you will.
So, yeah, those are the two that I use.
All right. Cool. So, without further ado, let's get into building the first phase, and I'll really start to have more time for questions as we do that. So I know we've gone pretty far in the workshop here, but it's important for me to, like, really set the stage for everything for you guys before we build. Because now at this point.
We're gonna get into building it from scratch, but you guys already have an understanding of, like, why do we care about building this ourself? What are the different components that we're building? What does it actually look like? And so, we're going to be able to move pretty quickly here, and then, you know, answer questions as they come up, but.
We've got the core down of, like, what we're actually doing here, what's the purpose of our brain, let's get the PRD created, let's understand how the different components work together. So now that we have all that, we're just going to start building.
So, what I'm going to do here is I'm going to open up a brand new Claude Code instance.
and I'm going to start with my classic piv loop. And if you guys have gone through the Agentic coding course.
You know that I always begin my planning sessions with the prime command.
Not that there is much context to gather right now.
But it will at least know to read the PRD here, and it'll recognize that we've just started. We're going to be on phase one. Let's build out the memory layer for our second brain. And then once we actually have things built out in future phases, it'll be good for our agent to explore.
or what we already have built right now, and get a sense of what our codebase looks like before we plan the next phase.
Alright, so it'll just take a little bit of time to prime, and then we'll get into the planning here. So I'll answer another question.
Um, so Rafael said, how do you decide when to use Claude code and when to use the Claude's second brain? Or is it just always just a skill in Claude code?
So, Rafael, for pretty much everything that I'm doing, I'm just using my second brain. I think what you're asking here is, like, when do I, you know, use my second brain to perform work versus when do I just, like, open up Claude code in my code base?
I just use my second brain all the time.
Because I also have the Archon skill built right in, so it can invoke my Archon workflows to handle GitHub issues or review pull requests, or whatever I need it to do.
So, it can get to the point with your second brain, where it's just, like, you're only ever opening up your Claude Code CLI in your second brain, so it's loading in all your context, and then you're just pointing it at other repos that you want to work on.
All right. Cool, so our prime finished here, and it understands that at this point, we haven't really built anything, but these are the phases that are outlined in our PRD. And so, generally, right after the priming, when I get into the planning process for a phase.
I go into my speech-to-text tool. I'm just using Aquavoice here. I love Aqua Voice. There are a lot of other good options, like Whisper Flow or Epicenter Whispering, but I recommend using some kind of speech-to-text tool. Makes it so much easier, especially during the brainstorming part of the planning session. So I go in and I say.
Alright, fantastic. So we're gonna go ahead and start with phase number one here. So I want you to do a little bit of research and help me plan out what we should be building for phase number one. Give me some ideas here.
And then, another thing that I recommend doing, I probably won't do it here, because it's only phase one, but it's good to have Claude Code ask you questions. The number one thing that you want to be doing in planning is you want to reduce the number of assumptions that your coding agent is making.
So if you haven't asked you questions, you guys are really getting aligned on even the nitty-gritty details. That is really important up front.
And so I'll show that more in future phases. Right now, I'm going to start really simple, because phase one is very, very basic. So you can see it even says here that the complexity for Phase 1 is low, and then for getting into, like, hooks and memory search and integrations, it's medium. And then, uh, towards the end here.
That's where we're going to get into the more complicated stuff. Definitely phases 6 and 7 are the most complicated, but we're still going to be able to basically one-shot everything here, because, like I said, I put a lot of effort into how I split everything out into phases, and the context that I'm giving through.
through the PRD. Like, this PRD is such a good starting point.
So, alright, we'll let it do some exploration here.
All right. Jeffrey asks, what command did I use to prime? Yeah, I simply used the slash prime command. So within the .claude commands folder, I have the prime command right here. I just took all of these directly from the agentic coding course.
And so I'll show this one more time. In our main repository for today, I have all of these commands right here in the .claw, so you can copy these over along with all the skills for the second brain.
Not that we're gonna need the piv loop commands and everything, like, once you have the foundation of your second brain, like I said, but, like, when we're building it at first, it's definitely useful, like I'm showing right here.
All right. Cool. So, it looks like the sub-agents are almost done here. Or, actually, they did finish, so now Claude Code is just reasoning. Okay, there we go, now we got the final answer.
So, alright. Phase 1 is the foundation. This is what we're building here. So, we're going to set up the initial vault structure. So this is where we're going to create our soul.md and user.md. All of the core markdown documents that drive our second brain. This is what we're building in phase number one.
And, uh, we're also creating a claw.md. So, generally, for my second brain, and this is, of course, very, very flexible, but usually for my second brain, my claw.md is where I describe the technical details. Like, here are the commands that you need to be able to run for.
memory searching, things like that. So, again, it's soul.md describes the behavior of our agent.
Usura MD is our profile. Memory.md is like core memories about things we're working on, or decisions that we've made.
And then the claw.md is the technical details. Like, here's how we work with our integrations or our memory searching.
And then we also have the bootstrap.md. So this is another idea that I took directly from OpenClaw. When you first have a conversation with your agent, it's going to guide us through a conversation of just getting details about us, so it can start to fill out these files. So we'll see that after we implement the first phase as well.
And so it has a couple of questions for me. Again, questions are very important to make sure we're aligned on everything. So I'm going to go into my speech-to-text tool and just start answering them.
So a vault route, a Dynamis workshop as the Obsidian Vault, or a different name. Yes, Dynamis- Workshop is the correct vault route.
Uh, link styles, uh, you know, WikiLinks is good. I think that works well.
Um, yeah, for the soul.md, feel free to draft.
The agent personality, but also the bootstrap markdown should specify the questions we need to ask here, at least to add on to what we have specified in the PRD.
And then, uh, for question 4, nope, I think what we have here is great.
All right, so I'll send that in, and I'll just say, just acknowledge, because right after this, I'm going to run the next command. I'm going to run the plan feature command, like I've covered in the agentic coding course. So, alright, summarize, looks like we're on the same page.
Um, for the sake of brevity, I'm going to move right into creating the structured plan, but if you guys really want to take your time with this, which I would recommend going a little bit slower than I am as you continue to build it out. But, like, right now, as we create the foundation, and because I'm just demoing it here, I'm going to go.
Kind of quickly here, but I'm going to go right into creating our structure plan. So I'll say, alright, this is great, let's go ahead and create the plan for Phase 1.
Alright. I mean, you can kind of just specify whatever we want here, or not even say anything at all, because it knows to just use our short-term memory to guide creating the structure plan. That's the part of the command that we have here.
All right, so we'll let it go. And this is going to take a little bit, so more time for Q&A.
All right, Sean asked, can user.md contain multiple users? Example, my wife and I. Does that make sense? Yes, Sean, it definitely can. The important thing to keep in mind, though, is if you want your second brain to be able to delineate who's actually talking to it.
You would need some kind of way to make that distinguishment. Like, if your wife is talking to it in Slack, it would need to know that, like, okay, this Slack user ID talking to me right now is Sean's wife, so I should care more about, like, the part of the user.md that's for her.
Or if it's Sean talking, then let's make sure that we're using his information in the user.md. So, it's up to you if you'd want to separate it into two user.md files, or just have it be, like, one file it reads, but it's delineated in the prompting.
either would work. Drago said, will the recording be available? I missed the first 2 hours today. Um, bank holiday in the UK.
Uh, yes, uh, yep, so the recording will be available, and it'll be posted, like, later today, probably.
Probably, like, within, like, 8 hours after, because Zoom has to process the whole thing, but yeah, it'll be available. And uh, yeah, so it is actually… it's a stock market holiday today in the U.S, I guess bank holiday in the UK. I think… I kind of, like, forgot about that when I scheduled this, even though I do celebrate Black Friday myself, so… Or, sorry, not Black Friday, goodness, Good Friday. Wow, I just said Black Friday. It is not November, guys. Yeah, so for those of you who do celebrate, happy, happy Good Friday. Well, I can't believe I call it Black Friday.
Oh, man. All right. So next question here from Josh.
What are the pros and cons of combining the agent memory with the direct integration? I have a memory set up right now with Obsidian and Supabase, and I'm going to use this to build out my integrations and skills.
All right. Let me read that last part again. I have a memory set up right now with obsidian Superbase, but I'm going to use this to build out the integrations and skills.
So, it's not really an either-or. Like, your direct integrations are the arms of the agent. It's how it's able to access things in your life, right? Like, it's able to see emails coming in or see tasks in your task list. That's separate from the memories, though. The memories are more fundamental. It's more like understanding decisions that you've made.
or things that you're currently working on. I mean, I guess there's a little bit of overlap there, where, like, remembering what you're working on could be in the memories or in your task list, but I would say that, like.
Your integrations are more ephemeral, right? Like, it's more like, here's what's happening right now. In the memory, that's what's, like, building up over time.
So I wouldn't… like, I know you asked, like, pros and cons. I would say that that's not like a either or that you have to wrestle with there, if that makes sense. You can feel free to elaborate on your question as well. I hope that helps.
All right. Cool. I think that Jesus guy is pretty forgiving, so no worries, right? Yep. I appreciate it, Mike.
Oh, man, alright. So, yeah, next question here. Karsten said, regarding the heartbeat, how have you defined what's valuable or important for you to require immediate attention? Ah, yes, that is a very good question. So I'll give you a shorter answer right now, because that's one of the big things we'll cover when we get to phase six.
But the thing that I… that it comes down to is, at first, it's not going to be perfect.
You're going to describe at a high level, here's what's important to me, these kinds of emails, or these kinds of posts and whatever forum, right?
And that might not be the best prompting at first, and it might miss important things. But the important part is you catch that, and you say, like, hey, you reply, you drafted a reply to this email when I didn't even want you to waste tokens doing it. Like, this isn't the thing I care about. Or you missed this email, and I had to draft it, or I had to create the reply myself from scratch.
And then you ask it to figure out, what do we change in the prompting so that you get that better next time? It's the same system evolution mindset that I covered in the agentic coding course. It 100% applies to evolving the second brain as well.
And so you just have to have the fair expectation that things are not going to be perfect. It's not going to have the best email drafts. It's not going to draft all the right emails at first.
But you improve that over time. And there's flexibility there because we're not trusting the agent to actually send the prompt or send the email.
But it's just drafting it. So if it doesn't decide to draft an email when you want it to, it's unfortunate because it saves you a little bit less time, right? Because that draft's not there, but it's not like it did something malicious, like send an email saying, like, oh yeah, I'll attend that meeting, even though you weren't planning on it, right? Like, that's why we have those protections in place, and so it gives you the flexibility to.
you know, have those mistakes happen at first, and then you improve it over time, and then as you improve your agent and you trust it more and more, that's when you can give it more permission as well.
And, uh, yep, that's right, Fred, thank you. So, Mike, yeah, there's nothing that I run in between Prime and plan. Generally, what you do in between priming and planning is you simply have a conversation with the coding agent for what you want to build. Once you're on the same page in that planning process.
That is when you run the slash plan feature command.
to, uh, create that structure plan. That's what it's in the middle of writing out right now, so we're just waiting for that document to be done. Yep.
All right. Cool. So, Rhonda said, what if you have multiple emails? Can it go through and organize which email and all that is in there?
100%, yeah. I mean, I obviously haven't built that for myself, because I just have the whole system running on one email, but if you wanted to give information on multiple emails and have the heartbeat, like, actually check both of them and distinguish between them, you can certainly build that in. That could be one of the things that you would.
you know, add into your PRD. Like, you would save for the whole, um… Or, sorry, not the PRD, but well, I mean, yes, the PRD, but, like, in your template here, you'd specify, like, I have.
I have two Gmail accounts, actually, right? And then you can start creating the PRD around that.
All right. All right, there we go. So now our plan is created.
So, phase one foundation. I always recommend reviewing these plans. I want to make sure that our workshop doesn't go long, though, so I'm going to go pretty quick through these, but generally, I do like reading through these line by line, or at least skimming them with a good amount of thought behind it here.
So it's gonna create all of our core memory files. Here's relevant documentation to reference. This is the core structure that I always have for my plans, like I teach in the course.
This is the Obsidian Vault that we're going to create here.
And this is everything it's going to build. And, uh, so task by task breakdown, and then we also have the validation here, so making sure that everything looks good. There's not too much to validate at this point, but there is going to be the manual validation where after this phase is implemented, I'll actually create the Obsidian Vault. So we'll do that live together as well.
We're going to set up the entire thing together here. I'm not skipping anything. Maybe just going a little bit fast through the review.
for the sake of brevity here. So, as I always recommend, it is very important to start your implementation in a different Claude Code session.
Because we run the execute command, we give the path to our plan.
And this plan has all of the context that our coding agent needs to get the job done. We don't need to prime again, we don't need to do web research again, we already did all that during the planning process, we synthesized everything into this single document. Now, this is all we need to send in, because this lays out what needs to be done, the task list, the validation strategy, the success criteria.
Everything. Plan is clear. 10 tasks appear, file directory creation. Yeah, we know that this first part is going to be really basic here, so we'll rip through it quick. We will create our Obsidian vaults, and then we'll already be done with phase number one, because I wanted to, like I said, break it up in a really nice and manageable sections here.
All right. Rasmus said, only me building this of 5 sessions to implementing 3 reviewing. Yeah, you know, Rasmus, I could… I could rip through it really fast like that, and that's cool that you are, but I don't think that would make for an easy-to-follow workshop, unfortunately. And I also specifically want to do everything sequentially, just so it's easy to break things up for the modules for the course after.
But certainly, if you guys are power users, like Rasmus, you could do a lot of these things in parallel.
Um, so going back to our diagram here. Like, you could build the direct integrations at the same time you build the memory layer, and you could even build the hooks at the same time. Like, a lot of these things are pretty isolated from each other, because I purposely have them as quite distinct sections. So, you certainly could do a lot of them at the same time.
And, um, honestly, I… well, depending on, you know, where we're at with time when we get towards the end here, I might build some of these things in parallel. Like, I might do the heartbeat and the chat interface at the same time.
in separate Claude Code sessions, obviously, because they're both more complicated features, but, um, yeah, I definitely have that option, just if I want to, like, prioritize your guys' questions and, uh, make sure that we're still building everything in time that we need.
All right. When will the new course be released? So I'm going to take this workshop and make sure I put a lot of effort into editing it nicely and splitting it out. So I'm not sure exactly how long that'll take. I've never done something like that, where I've taken a live session and I've been like super intentional about like taking chunks of it.
for a course might end up being really hard. It actually probably will be a pretty hard thing. I'll use my second brain as much as possible to help me, like, call out the times to split, so I'd hope to do it within the next week.
Um, Brandon said, I'm still waiting on the PRD to generate. Oh, wow. Well, hopefully you'll be able to catch up, because I will spend time for questions, even after things are done executing. That's… that's interesting, though. I'm surprised it would take that long.
I'll need 5 parallel sessions to create the course, yeah, right, I mean, yeah, maybe I'll have them all going, parsing different sections of the course.
Yeah, 12 minutes is a while to create the PRD. You must have added a lot of customizations, Brandon. Or maybe Claude is, like, stuck or something? That's kind of strange. I don't know, it wasn't that long for me, I don't think.
Interesting. All right. Cool. So… Here we go. It completed our phase number one. And at this point, it's really just going to be a bunch of Markdown documents. So we have the Dynamis workshop folder, and within it we have… take a look at this. We've got our memory, so a bunch of folders that are empty for now. Well, I'll explain more of these as we build it out, because I have like a whole draft system.
Where, um, one thing that I didn't even explain to you guys, it's very cool, is it keeps track of all of my sent emails, and, like, replies to you guys in the community. So it builds an understanding over time of how I actually communicate and handle certain emails and situations.
And so not only does it create drafts for me, but it keeps track of what I actually sent, and it'll compare the draft to what I sent, and it'll automatically extract lessons from that.
So it's another really cool thing we'll get into when we do our integration with Gmail and the memory reflection system. We have our bootstrap.md. So the first time I talked to the agent and it does the onboarding, it's going to go through these questions with me.
And then we have the habits. These are, like, the daily pillars that I want to keep me accountable for. So this is a bit more specific to me. You guys might not necessarily need the habits part of the second brain, but I love this part for myself.
We have the heartbeat. We'll obviously cover this in a later phase, but, like, here are the things that we want it to monitor. These are all more like templates, like a starting point that we'll build out throughout the phases.
We have our memory.md, which is very short right now, but we're going to build this up over time. This starts to get quite long as you are using your second brain day in and day out. But it's cool that we even have, like, some key decisions that we made here already. So we get a little bit of an idea of what this looks like.
We have our soul.md, so I am Cole's AI second brain. I operate as an advisor, right? Because that's the role level that we picked when we filled out the template. I draft, suggest, and organize and remind, but I never send, post, or take irreversible actions without explicit approval.
And the soul.md is where you guys can really customize the behavior of your agent. You can have it use a different language, you can have it use slang, you can have it actually send posts instead of just drafting. Exactly how you want it to act, this is the main file.
Because when we get into the next phase with hooks, we're gonna make it so this is one of the files that is loaded into the context of Claude code and the Claude Agent SDK every single time.
As well as the user.md. This has all of my core information, with a lot of things still being TBD, because this is what we're going to populate during our first onboarding with the bootstrap. This is how OpenClaw works as well.
And so, um, let's actually… let's actually do this here. So, Jeffrey said he's lost. I'm sorry to hear that. I'm just kind of trying to go through the different documents here. I know there's quite a bit to digest with the initial structure, but just, uh, the easy way to think about it is.
We have the core memories we build over time.
Sol.md is, like, here's how we describe the behavior of our agent.
And then this is our user profile. Those are the biggest files for you to understand right now. This is the core of our system.
So, if you guys need me to slow down a little bit to explain things, like, feel free to let me know. I hope that makes sense, though. Basically, every part of our system is, in core, just a markdown document.
And so we can also create a new Obsidian vault here. So I'm going to open up Obsidian, and I want to connect it to this folder right here.
So I'm going to open a folder as a vault. So I'll click open.
And then the path to this right here, I gotta actually go to this. It is… Second Brain Workshop. So, select this folder.
Whoops, that is the wrong folder. Oh man, I didn't mean to do that because I need to click… I need to actually go into Dynamis workshop. So, uh, let me remove from the list.
And then delete the .obsidian here. So, you need to go into the folder that it created specifically that has the memory folder in it. So, open folder as Vault.
Then click Dynamist Workshop, or at least that's what it's called for me. It's probably called something different for you. There we go. Now we have it opened up. So here's our Obsidian. We can go into the settings and customize things as well. I usually don't like the light theme. So I'll go into the appearance here for the themes, let's do, um, I don't know, Obsidianite looks really cool, so we'll install and use this theme.
Um, and then for the base color scheme, we'll do dark. Okay, that looks way better, cool. Alright, so here is our initial obsidian vault, and we already have our memory system started in here, so I'll zoom in a little bit so it's easy to see this. So we can open up all of our documents in Obsidian, everything's really organized well.
So it knows how to format things at the front matter for Obsidian, like we're seeing right here.
Very, very cool. So, not much in this right now, like, we don't have any daily logs or anything, but this is our starting point. So phase one is all about just getting the initial infrastructure set up for our memory system, and we're connecting it to Obsidian as well. And so now, really, the last thing that I can do for phase one.
And then I think we're kind of at, like, the halfway point for the entire workshop, so we'll take, like, a 10-minute break here. But the last thing that I want to show right now is I want to show what it looks like to have that initial conversation, where we do the bootstrapping.
So I'm going to start Claude Code. The important thing to keep in mind here is that the sole user and memory.md are core files. They're not loaded into Claude Code automatically yet, because that comes in the next phase with hooks.
But we do have the claw.md. This is loaded in automatically, so it understands.
that, uh, I… that it is a second brain, and it has some general information. So we have this just as, like, the highest level index of our second brain.
And so what I can say now is walk me through the bootstrap.
And this is the… we only have to do this once. Just when we start for the first time, because this is where it's going to fill out some of those things, like in the user.md, that are left as TBD right now.
So we'll try to go through these things really quickly.
Can I… Um, can you show the Obsidian part again? Yeah, of course. So, all I did here is I opened up Obsidian for the first time, and I clicked Open Folder as Vault. So we can bring an existing folder that already has content as an Obsidian vault.
And then I simply selected the folder that it created for me in phase one. This is the folder that has the memory folder within it, right? So like whatever name you specified for your vault when you created the PRD, you selected this folder.
And then it opens it up here as a brand new Obsidian Vault. Then you just go into the settings in the bottom left, and this is where you can customize everything. Like, I added a custom theme here called Obsidian Night. I mean, you could just use a default if you want. I'm just showing you how to make it look nice, because I don't want to deal with a light theme.
And then I just changed the base color scheme to dark. That's all I did to set up things initially. And you can, of course, feel free to add in your own plugins and things, like if you wanted to… and by the way, if you don't have Obsidian installed, but you're interested in using it after seeing it here, it is very, very easy to install Obsidian. You just go to their website is obsidian.md.
So I put a link to it in the chat right here, and it's free and open source, runs 100% locally. Actually, sorry, I don't think it's open source, but it's free and runs locally as a desktop application. Everything is 100% private, unless you enable their, um, cloud sync, but that isn't on by default.
So, very private application. That's why a lot of people love using it. And then there's plugins to extend it as well. So they have core plugins that you can toggle on and off, and then also community plugins. So I can turn this on, and then I can browse, and then, for example, I can bring in the Excalidraw plugin.
So I have this one installed in my other Obsidian vault, but you actually install the community plugins at a vault level. So, like, vault by vault, I can change the plugins that I have included. So, it's very easy to, you just click install, and then click Enable, and now I have support for Excalidraw diagrams directly in my Obsidian Vault.
So it's pretty cool. Um, alright, so yeah, let's go back to our bootstrapping here.
Alright, so here's what Phase 1 bootstrapped. No, I meant go through the bootstrap.
Md process. So I didn't realize what I was referring to here, but that's because we don't have the user.md and things loaded in yet, so maybe I should have done this process after Phase 2, so it actually, like, knew to go to bootstrap.md right away.
So, but anyway, now it knows. Alright, let's do this. So, hi, I'm your second brain, let's… let me get to know you so I can be the most helpful. Uh, so, you know what I'm gonna do here? I'm actually gonna say, just ask all the questions at once. I want to be kind of fast here. The bootstrap.md is set up to be more of, like, a full conversation.
Which is nice, like, it feels really nice, but the thing is, if I want to go a little bit faster, just to wrap up Phase 1, I do want to go pretty quickly. So, here's everything I need to fill out your profile.
Alright, so I'll just give, like, quick answers to everything.
So what are your top 2 to 3 active projects or focus areas right now? I'm working on Archon and workshops for the Dynamist community, who are key people you collaborate with regularly. Uh, you know, let's just say I'm collaborating with everyone in the Dynamist community. Yes, I create content on YouTube and LinkedIn primarily.
brief response length, brief, medium, or detail. Let's just go with medium, uh, casual tone. Yeah, we can use emojis, but not too much.
Um, any pet peeves of AI assistants that I should know about? That is a good question.
My biggest pet peeve with coding agents is when they produce text that is way too obvious that it's generated by an LLM. Like, really punchy staccato with a ton of periods. I really don't like it when AI agents are sycophantic. I don't want them to always agree with me.
I want them to be willing to push back, so I want my second brain to be willing to push back.
Uh, typical working hours is generally 6 a.m. To 4 p.m. Central Time.
When should I stay quiet? Let's do no notifications after 9pm. When something needs my attention, you should flag it through Slack. What counts as urgent to you? Definitely things that are well overdue or that need a reply within the day.
Um, integrations, what are the order for the rest? Uh, we'll just kind of do it all at once in a phase here, and you can see that from the PRD. Any specific Gmail labels, Asana projects, or Slack channels I should prioritize? Uh, yes, actually. So… Let's see here, I gotta actually pull this up on my other monitor here.
But I'm gonna give you my full Asana URL that has my to-do project. I actually want you to use that specifically.
And then let's see. I also have a Slack channel.
I'll give you the link to that as well, so I'm just kind of dumping my links here so that you have, like, the right IDs for things up front, because that's where I work, like, that's the Slack channel I use, that's my Asana, my primary Asana task list.
Alright, the Habits.md has 5 daily pillars. Build, teach, connect, health, and learn. Do these resonate, or would you tweak them? Actually, let's tweak them. So for those of you guys who are watching this with me right now, I'm just gonna say really quick, like, these are the five habits that I legitimately track myself every single day. It's a little bit personal, I'm just sharing you, like, exactly my five habits.
My five habits are, um, I want to do something to improve Archon. My second brain itself.
the Dynamis community. My relationship with God and my marriage. Every single day, I've… it's a successful day. If I have improved all 5 of those things.
And then the last question here, any personal goals or habits you're currently tracking? I kind of already answered that. Um, so yeah, there we go. That's my answer to everything. All right, so again, always recommend using speech-to-text tools to just give that brain dump there. And so… This is really helpful. I know you have to, like, kind of take your time at first to really get through setting up your initial memory layer and, like, going through the bootstrap process. But this… this is what it takes, at least up front, to really make your agent personal to you.
Like, I'm already getting into the very specific things here, because now it's going to be building up the user soul and memory.md in ways that are already going to be helpful to me.
Not that we're gonna save ourselves a ton of time yet, but we're getting there. We're building up the foundation, and then as we get to the other phases, it'll come together very quickly here. So, we're going to… we're going to start to, like, get through things pretty fast. I know that we're halfway through the workshop, and it's Phase 1.
But a lot of it is just setting the groundwork up front. So we'll get through things pretty quickly here, and maybe even doing a couple of things in parallel. We'll figure out what we need to do here.
But there we go, so we're already getting the very specifics down.
Cool. Updating all of our core files. And then, of course, we can go into our Obsidian vault here, and we can see these things. If we want to view it ourself. I always like to say that, like, whenever my second brain is producing documents for me or working with me, Obsidian is my canvas, right? Like, it's my way to view things.
and edit things in a much better way because we have rich Markdown formatting, and the plugins we can bring in for Excalidraw, and we can render PDFs that it creates for us, and things like that. I'm creating PDFs, actually, quite a bit with my second brain, so it's nice to, like, view those, and even, like, images as it generates thumbnails for me. I can just do that all right in Obsidian, so I'm not managing things through, like, clicking around in folders on my file explorer.
All right. I appreciate it, Ralph.
Um, Kasha Khmer said marriage should be the first one. I agree. Yep, that is not in priority order. I'm just kind of listing them off, but 100%, like, certain ones, like marriage would, uh, take precedence over others.
Yep. All right. Justin said, if we have an existing second brain that we want to leverage, what I've learned about how yours is set up, should I go through setting up a new one from scratch, and then point it to existing? Or do you think that I should just do the PRD, then hand that to my existing and say, add what's missing from this PRD?
Justin, I would do the latter. I would work with what you have existing, and then you can either create the PRD like I showed in the workshop here, and then point your agent to it. Or you can just point your agent directly to the code base here.
That I have shared with everyone. So this entire Claude Code Second Brain code base, I'll just, you know, link to that in the Zoom chat again. You can just point it there and say, like, you know, take a deep dive into this. What are some, like, really cool features from Cole's Second Brain that maybe I can include that we don't have already?
So you can have it spin up sub-agents to, you know, explore both your second brain codebase and mine, and just see what differences there are. Maybe it'll find things that are way better than yours, who knows, but hopefully it'll find some cool things you can bring over from this.
All right. Cool. So let's go back to our Claude code here. All right. Bootstrap is done. We are now fully done with phase one. So we have the core set up. And so now for the next phase, what we're going to be doing here… is we're gonna make it so that the core memory files are actually loaded into our conversation. We're going to set up all of the Claude code hooks. And this phase is actually going to go by very quickly.
And then, uh, Jason, for the prompt for the bootstrap?
All I did is I told it to just read the bootstrap, and then go through the process. So, the PRD, like, when we do phase one, it creates that bootstrap automatically and puts it here, and so then we can just point cloud code to it and say, walk me through the bootstrap.
And then it automatically deletes the file after, because we only have to do that for our first conversation with our second brain. And then, of course, we can keep, like, improving the user.md and soul.md and everything going forward, but… the initial stage has been set now.
All right, cool. So we are at the halfway point for our workshop here.
Uh, so I'm gonna take a… I'm gonna let us all take a 10-minute break. So, get some food if it's the lunch hour for you, if you're in the States, or if it's dinner if you're over in Europe. Well, I guess it'll be a little bit late for dinner in Europe, but I'm gonna go and get a little bit of food myself, so I'm going to mute and turn off my camera.
And I will be back at 1:20 my time. So in 10 minutes from now, 20 minutes past the hour, I'll be back and we'll get right into phase number two, building the rest of our second brain. So don't go anywhere. And also, this is a time for you to catch up if anything is going long, like Brandon creating his PRD.
So use that time if you need. Otherwise, I will be back in 10 minutes. All right.
Alright guys, I am back. Sean, what is the issue you're having exactly with your cloud code?
That sounds really unfortunate, I'm sorry.
We'll get… we'll get rolling in just a minute here, but I wanted to ask that first. I was just looking at the chat a little bit.
When I got back to my computer. It's not writing the PRD.
Are you not in bypass permission mode, or… Oh, after 45 minutes, okay. So I've had this happen before.
Actually, it just happened to me twice yesterday, where Claude just gets totally stuck. You just have to double hit escape and then tell it to continue.
Yeah, it's… it's also possible they could be having, like, a regional outage or something as well.
So, um… There are currently… so here, I'll pop it up on my screen. There's an outage with Sonnet 4.6, so maybe you're accidentally using Sonnet. Also, if… whenever there are outages like this, sometimes there's, like, smaller regional outages for, like, Opus as well, but they're just focusing on the more global one.
So there could… there could be a problem. Actually, I hope I don't run into this during my workshop here, but that is a possibility.
So, yeah, if anyone else is experiencing, yeah, I guess Brandon, um… Okay, double tap just gave, and it continued to pick back up. Yeah, that's always the way to go if it's just a fluke or a temporary glitch.
But, um, yeah, Sean, I had that happen twice yesterday at Claude code. It was not fun.
So yeah, for those of you who run anything like that, like, you can always feel free to follow along with the recording after. Always going to be available to you guys. I know there was a couple of people that mentioned that it feels like I'm going kind of quick.
And unfortunately, I do have to go kind of quick, just because there's so much to cover here. I want to do it as a live event. For those of you who want the energy and to ask questions and to follow along as much as possible.
Uh, but, like, certainly I can understand, like, this might be really valuable also as a course, where it's videos that you can pause and wait for your claw to be done and move on, right? So you're not, like, prompting and trying to listen at the same time.
Totally understand. Um, yeah, so I'm gonna make sure that it's a big priority for me early next week to turn this workshop into the edited recording.
Um, yeah. And I'll try to keep answering all the questions you guys have as well.
So, all right. Let's go ahead and get right into the next part of it here. So, while I was taking my break, I decided that for the sake of time, I am going to be doing some things in parallel.
So, going back to our diagram here. Luckily for some of our upcoming modules here.
It's gonna be quite easy to do it at the same time. So I'm gonna add in the whole, like, memory search pipeline.
and the hooks. At the exact same time.
And then we'll add in the direct integrations and skills at the same time.
So now that we understand how the second brain works, and we've built the initial foundation, it should be relatively easy to follow along. Like, I can still go a bit slow.
and explain things, but I do want to build it at the exact same time.
So, what I'm gonna do is go back to my Claude code and I'm going to start four sessions here.
or well, I'll start with 2 sessions. So I'm going to do 2 planning sessions.
So I'm going to run slash prime twice. One for phase two and one for phase 3.
And so it's going to get very procedural now, and I mean this in a good way. It'll be easier to follow because exactly what I did for phase one, I'm going to be doing for all the other phases. I do a prime.
And then I create the plan, and then I go into implementation and do my validation. It's going to be the same every single time, very classic pivot loops. Now, I should have probably actually made a commit after the first phase.
Doesn't really matter, though, because it's mostly just the markdown documents at first, but I do recommend… doing the commit, like, making a commit at the end of each phase.
Dom asks, how do you determine which phase is primed? Well, it's doing a whole general prime of the code base. It's not specific to a phase. So it's after it does the prime that I'm going to say, like, let's work on phase two. I'm going to be doing phase 3 in parallel. And then I'll do the opposite in the other session.
So, okay, uh, here's the prime report. We have our general structure. Okay, very cool. So we did foundations. We did phase one. Next, we're doing hooks.
Great, so I'll just go in to my speech to text and say, alright, fantastic, let's go ahead and add in the hooks. So give me a summary here of what you plan on implementing for this according to the PRD.
There we go. Cool, so there's the first one, and then for our second conversation here, I'm just going to go past the hooks, because the other one is handling it.
So I have another conversation that's handling phase two. So let's actually do some planning for Phase 3. I want to do it in parallel. So let me know, according to the PRD, everything that we should implement now for phase 3.
There we go. Now, be careful with this. You know, you can't always do parallel development if the coding agents are going to step on each other's toes a lot. I'm just letting you know for what we're doing right here, it's going to work.
Because they… they're gonna be doing a pretty isolated changes in our code base here. They don't have to step on each other's toes.
So, alright, here's our plan for phase number two. We're going to be creating our three hooks here. So this is where we're creating our start hook. So we are automatically injecting the core files into our session at the start.
And then we have the pre-compact and end hooks. So whenever we're about to do a memory compression or end a session, we need to send the conversation to Claude Code to figure out what we want to save and store in our daily logs. And so this is how our agent is able to remember.
All of our interactions. We're starting to set that up now through our hooks.
And so it gives me a summary of what this looks like here. We're invoking this special memory flush Python script. This is the most important part of phase two. This memory flush Python script is the separate process that runs Claude code.
To summarize all of our conversations. And so, both of our pre-compact and session end hooks, they're actually going to invoke the separate Claude code session.
And if you guys didn't know, all Claude Code conversations are actually stored as JSON-L files on your local system. So our separate Claude Code session can read the entire conversation and summarize that, and then put that in our daily logs. And we'll see that in action after we build this as well.
So I'm going to do plan feature. Um, we can say, like, alright, great, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for phase number two.
Send that off. And then in parallel, we can take a look at what we found for our memory searching. So, yeah, let me know if I'm going a little too fast. I'm gonna try to be as slow as possible and break down what we're doing here. I'll keep referencing back the diagram.
As we are talking about what we're building here. So now, what we're going to be building in Phase 3 is being able to search over our memories. So this is where we are adding RAG into our second brain.
And so we obviously have to deal with embeddings. I'm just going to use a local embedding model. And if you're not super familiar with RAG and embeddings and everything, don't worry. The PRD handles all of this for us, right? So we have our SQLite database.
And then we're gonna have a couple of scripts, because we need one script to be able to search through our memories, and then we need another script that handles indexing, right? We need some process to look through our daily logs.
And then capture all that into our database for RAG. That is what the memory index handles. And it even gives me an explanation of this as well. So, as you're going through and building your own second brain, or taking ideas from what I have here, if there's anything you don't understand, you can always ask Claude code.
And it can give you an overview of everything we're doing here.
So, honestly, Phase 3 is where it starts to get a little bit technical under the hood, talking about the embedding model and the database, and how we are handling the tables in the database. But you can ask as many questions as you need to understand what we have going on under the hood.
And like I said, one of the main advantages of building our own second brain is we do get to actually understand the code base, because we're building it along with Claude code, and we can ask questions along the way. So even if you aren't as technical.
You can raise yourself to a level of understanding where you really feel like you have a grasp of your code base. That's what I want for you here.
And so, uh, for me, I already understand all this because I built it already, so it's quite helpful right now. But if you wanted to dive deeper into everything that we're building here, you can definitely have a conversation with Claude Code before you just go into, you know, planning the feature here.
Yes, this all makes sense. Let's go ahead and create the structure plan for Phase 3. There we go.
So we're just going through the motions here of the piv loop.
Nice and easy. All right, so both of these are in the middle of running here.
All right. So I'll go through some more questions here.
You know, what I'm going to try to do is I'm going to try to move a little bit faster through the questions, so I'll give, like, simple answers.
And then I'll let you know when your question is going to be answered more as we're building the other phases.
So all right. Sean asked, is there a way that we can have our second brain access Dynamis posts?
Unfortunately, not, because the rate limits aren't actually that nice for Circle, so even if I gave an API key to everyone, then it would blow through the rate limits. So, I wish. That would be nice.
Uh, Brandon said, what I've come to conclude is that my AI agent is essentially a coding agent first and foremost. Why wouldn't we use Archon or a coding agent to actually continue to monitor and build themselves out?
My use case is an AI executive assistant, adding skills, capabilities. I love to just talk to them on Slack and have them code it themselves, rather than going into a terminal to create, maintain code.
Am I thinking about this right? Yes, Brandon, 100% you are. That's right.
Yeah, for whatever you're building, you can have it improve itself, because… and that's kind of what we're doing as a second brain, like, it is a coding agent first. Like, that's the whole point, is we're laying out the foundation here so the agent can evolve itself, right? We're kind of just like… that's why we're using Claude code as the foundation for our second brain.
So yeah, that's very, very good. Dom said, one thing I'm missing is a connection to a local server instead of a cloud installation, like hosting it at home.
Yeah, if you wanted to run the second brain on your computer, and then you could, like, set up, um, you know, TwinGate or Tailscale or something so you can access it when it's running on your desktop from other devices on your network, you definitely can do that.
Oh, I forgot to answer live. Okay, there we go, answer live, done. Moving on to the next Q&A. All right.
Mike said, uh, learning loops. Have you implemented a pattern, anti-patter detection learning algorithms and systems for updating memory docs?
Yeah, so… I do have the whole daily reflection. This is how I'm updating the memory over time.
As far as other sorts of learning loops. I've actually intentionally left it more manual.
And so, as far as, like, improving our skills automatically, or direct integrations, I want that to be more led by you.
So, when you figure out that a skill isn't being used quite right, or a direct integration isn't being used quite right, that's your opportunity to just talk to your second brain and say, hey, I don't think you built the diagram in the right way.
Or this PowerPoint doesn't really have my tone of voice. Like, let's take a look into the AI layer and the skills and see what we can make better so that going forward, the system has evolved.
And I like being in the driver's seat there. I don't really want something like Carpathy's Auto Research, where it's kind of just, like, evolving its own skill.md or whatever file.
Because I think the human in the loop is still really important there. Otherwise, the second brain just kind of goes off the rails, and it's not necessarily aligned with you when it's doing that self-evolution. So you could definitely build that in if you want. You could even add that into the whole PRD here. But for me, I want it to evolve its memories, and that's enough.
I want to still be the one saying, like, let's change this skill in this way, or help me think about how we would change this skill.
All right. And then John said, can you please share the exact folder structure to start with, i.e, how do you create the proper folder structure from the repos? I want to start, but don't want to run into the issues I'm seeing from other starting from the wrong repo base.
Uh, yeah, John. So, put it really simply, all you need to do is take the commands folder.
And the skills folder, and you just copy that into a brand new directory in .claude.
Right? So, like, what I have here, I have my .claude folder where I copied over the commands I copied over the skills, and that's it. Just super simple. You start with nothing else. And in fact, the only skill I started with is the Create Second Brain PRD, because I'll copy in the other ones in phase five.
So, nice and easy. You don't have to start from the other repo. That's what was causing problems for other people, because it was loading in the Claude code hooks that I have in my example here that were blocking, like, reading and writing some files, because the .env keyword.
All right. Cool, so it's, um, in the middle of writing the structure plans here, so we got time for some more questions.
Um, Danny said, will it be enough with a Claude Pro subscription, or should I have Max? A pro subscription will be enough. The second brain is not too token heavy. Like it'll take a decent number of tokens as you're building it and evolving it, but a pro subscription should be enough.
Uh, Bart said, can you answer this, please, Cole? Is there a starter repo to follow along today? Yeah, so this question was answered a little bit ago, or asked a little bit ago, so I assume that you've seen the answer from me, but I'll link to this in the Zoom chat again. And remember that it's linked in the description for our workshop here as well. This has my entire second brain ready for you to reference.
and also has the skill, the second… the Create Second Brain PRD skill for you to use as your starting point.
All right. Um, so if we wanted to code along, should we use an empty project? That is right, Eddie. Yep, yep.
Can I use this locally on my private computer with sensitive data? Lucas, yes, you can. It just depends on how comfortable you are with sharing that information with, uh, like, the Anthropic API, like through the frontier models. If you want to run the entire second brain locally.
You can use something like Ollama to power your Claude code, so it's not actually going out to a cloud LLM. It is very realistic to make this entire system run 100% locally, not going out to any APIs as far as like sending out your information.
So, if you're interested in doing a 100% local implementation, I would just make that very clear when you create your PRD up front, because then as you go through each of the phases here, it'll keep that in mind. Like, let's make sure that for Lucas's second brain, we're not using a frontier model, or we're not sending out API requests with sensitive information.
So we can still have information come in from the internet through our integrations, but it's just we don't want to send data out, right? So you can use something like Ollama or Light LLM to run local models if you want.
All right. Um, is that the full repo in the description? Since it doesn't seem to have a lot in it yet? So it is Bart. That's actually because most of what we have here, like, I know it doesn't seem like a lot, but most of what we have is in the .claude folder. Within scripts specifically, this is where you'll see.
all of the memory scripts and the integration scripts, a lot of it is just stored right within .clon.
So there is actually a lot here, trust me. It just doesn't look like it when you look at the root of the repository. So totally fair observation, but yeah, it's all there. Yep.
Alright, cool. So let's go back. Alright, so we've created our plan to add in hooks.
And then we also have our phase three plan for our memory search. So let's take a look at this really quick. And again, I'm going to go a little bit quickly through reviewing the plans here, but as you're building the implementation for yourself, feel free to ask as many questions as you need to understand what we're building here.
The whole point is to take inspiration from my solution, so you can dive into each part with Claude Code, or whatever coding agent you're using.
So, with hooks, every cloud session starts cold, or without hooks. So we have the global rules, but the agent has no automatic access to our core files. That's what we're building for phase two. Sold.md, user.md, memory.md. We're going to read those all in up front.
And then, uh, we're gonna spawn that background Claude agent SDK session to summarize conversations before we compact and at the end of every session. So, this is exactly what we've already gone over together in the Excalidraw diagram. This is looking really good.
And I just want to scroll down to the validation in the plan really quick. I'll kind of skim past everything else here.
We're gonna do our basic checks, security check. Okay, honestly, we're not checking too much right here, because it's more gonna be up to me to start a brand new Claude Code session. I'll actually, like, show you what it looks like to start a new Claude Code session after this phase is implemented, and we'll see that it'll, like, automatically have access.
to the information in these files through the start session hook.
And then we can even test, like, the end session hook as well.
So, okay. We have our plan here. I'm going to start a brand new Claude Code session to go into the implementation. So I'll copy the path.
slash execute. And there we go. We are off to the races. All right. So then we'll go on to phase three with memory search. Let's take a look at this structure plan really quickly here.
All right. So we're going to be building a chunking, embedding and search pipeline that enables semantic and keyword search across all Vault Markdown documents. So even all of our daily logs, this is important.
Because they're… as you use your second brain, when you use it for months and months and months, there are going to be so many files here. We need semantic search, because it's not going to be realistic for our agent to, like, manually read all these files once there's a lot of them to find information.
So we're building our RAG pipeline here. We're keeping it very simple.
with just a SQLite database right now. All right. And so let's actually see. So it's also going to create the scripts to, uh, you know, bring things into our SQLite database, the indexing is going to create the search script as well, so that's what it's laying out here in the task list right now, like this right here is our indexing script.
We don't care about all the underlying details, you can feel free to ask Claude about it if you want, but I'm just kind of curious what the validation is going to look like here. So here's our testing strategy. So we're going to do some unit-level validation.
We're gonna actually try running the script, that's really important. So it's going to do some indexing, it's going to actually do some testing.
We're gonna make sure that it's very thorough here, right? Like, it's gonna run the full index, it's gonna do the hybrid search, it's gonna make sure that, like, you know, how our second brain is going to search and index going forward right after the implementation. We're going to test all those things. So we're going to let the agent test its own work.
So, very good. Let's go ahead and kick off this implementation as well.
So slash execute. Give it the path to the phase three plan.
And we're off to the races. All right.
Um, yep, I want to allow access. Claude code does this thing sometimes where even in bypass permission mode, it'll, like, ask me for permission. It's a recent glitch that was added to Claude code, which is honestly kind of frustrating. I don't know if anyone else has seen this recently themselves.
But I'll go in YOLO mode, and it still pauses for permissions, specifically when it's editing something in its own .claude folder. Don't really know why it's doing that. So I'll have to kind of check once in a while here. But while we're waiting for these to run, I'll go ahead and answer more of you guys' questions here.
Um… will we get access to the chat messages later along with the recording?
Um, yep, so, yeah, Pat is… that's correct. The chats are posted as a part of the recording. Yes.
Um, Kashik said I saw that, folks are saying YOLA mode is going away or deprecated. Yeah, it seems like they're doing something with that, for sure. I don't know… yeah, see, even this one, it did the same thing, like… We'll see if it keeps asking me. Let's see, like, this file it created fine, but then, like, the one before, I don't know, it's kind of weird.
Um, yeah, interesting. So I just kind of have to, like, keep clicking back and forth, making sure we're good to go. Whatever, I'll go on to the next question here.
Bart said, I use Zulip instead of Slack and run it on DigitalOcean. Very good and easy to set up. That is super cool. I've never actually heard of it before. But yeah, so I guess if you guys want a self-hosted version of Slack, take a look at Zulip, if I'm saying that right, Z-U-L-I-P? Cool.
Chris said, can we use a local LLM? Would it work just as well as using the agent SDK?
So, uh, let me be clear, you are allowed to… or not allowed, you can use local models with the Claude Agent SDK.
So, here, I'll even, like, do a quick search.
Or, actually, no, sorry, I don't… I don't… I can't… I can't go and do that right now, but if you just, like, do a quick search for Ask an LLM, like, how do I use Ollama or any kind of local LLM with the Claude Agent SDK, it can walk you through that. Very easy to set that up. You can make this entire system local, Chris.
Um… So Ivo said in the Archon repo, you have a .agents slash .claude architecture, but Claude expects it at the root of the tree.
You do this in the second brain repo. How does it work for Archon? Uh, no, so they are not nested. They just live side by side. So anything that I want Claude code to load automatically, it has in the .claude folder. The .agents is just for me to organize other parts of my AI layer.
that I'm not, like, integrating directly into Claude code. Like, files that I would specifically tell it to reference or something. So they're not necessary. Like, you can see they're at the same level here.
If there is actually anything where there is a .claude in a .agent, that is a mistake. So, I don't know if that actually is how I have it in Archon, but I don't think so, because I would have had a lot of problems if that was the case. When did the .agent appear? Dom, it created this automatically when it built the PRD. That's just a part of the PRD skill.
Or this is, like, the default location. So it just makes those folders automatically.
Yep. Karsten, that's exactly right. So you just have to set the anthropic base URL to point it to Ollama instead of Claude, and that's how you use local AI with both the Claude Agent SDK and Claude Code CLI itself.
Very easy, you just have to… you have to set up that, and then there's, like, another environment variable to set that defines the model ID, because you have to specify the model in the new provider as well. Just two environment variables. And if you ask Claude or, like, Google, it'll come up really quick.
Yep. Uh, all right.
So, let's take a look here. So, it actually already built… The hooks here. So Phase 2 is done, and we can even test this now. So I'm gonna open up a new session. So it built the three hooks.
And it did some validation here. Looks really good.
Um, okay, well, hold on. It said I need to include the Anthropic API key. This isn't quite right.
So, uh, I actually want to use UV for package management. So let's do UV instead. I want you to install the requirements, and then the Claude Agent SDK, I want to just use my Anthropic subscription. So, I want you to search the web for that. We can use that just like we do with Claude code. I don't need to set my Anthropic API key.
Uh, so I want you to take care of all this for me, and then make a commit. All right. So I'm doing quite a bit here. But yeah, so sometimes Claude doesn't realize with the Claude agent SDK, we don't have to set our Anthropic API key. So you might have to correct that yourself. That's why we're building live together here. So you can see.
some of the gotchas as they happen, and we can address them together.
So I'll just make sure that gets things set up right, and then I'll test in a new Claude Code session here. So we'll test a couple of the hooks to make sure they're good. Obviously, I recommend testing every single phase before you move on to the next one, or test the ones you did in parallel before you move on to the next ones.
Looks like phase three is still in the middle of building here, so… Let's go to a couple more questions now.
All right, Dave said, is there a specific Obsidian Vault layout or architecture that I recommend or use? Yeah, so let me go to my primary vault here.
Because, uh, if you want to take a screenshot of this really quick.
You can definitely feel free. I mean, some of these are very specific to me, like the two coarse ones at the top.
But the way I like to operate is I have my content ideation folder.
This is where I just, like, dump a ton of ideas per day, and then I just, like, have a process that automatically, like, archives them every so often.
So I ideate my content here so that when I'm, like, creating YouTube scripts and things like that, I have a folder for my daily notes that I take, a folder for my diagrams, and then I have meeting notes. I have all the memory, this is what's for my second brain.
I have permanent notes, so these are just, like, any notes I'm taking as a, you know, like, reading books or anything like that. Um, reference notes, this is specifically for… Um, any, like, external information that I want to bring into my vault, I don't use it that often, but this is a part of, like, the Zettelkasten technique, if you've ever heard of that. It's just a technique for organizing your knowledge for your second brain in Obsidian, or even, like, in physi… Zettelkasten was around before the digital age, even.
Those are the main ones, and so it's really, like, these that are all the main ones. They're, like, storing, like, recordings as well. Uh, personal, I just have, like.
couple little things in there, so… I don't have it, like, perfectly organized, so it's mostly, like, what I'd recommend is content ideation, daily notes, storing diagrams if you have them, uh, meeting notes, permanent notes, and reference notes.
All right. Jeffrey asked, does the folder organization method in .claude also apply to other coding environments like VS Code or Cursor, especially if you're using tools besides Claude Code?
So, you can organize it like .claw, but it'd probably be… I mean, like, it's not going to be used automatically like it is the Claude code, so you can kind of just call it, like.agents or whatever you want. When I'm working with other coding agents that don't have the concept of, like, a .claude folder.
Then I'm usually just calling it .agent or .agents. And I'm just putting all of my like second brain AI layer stuff right in there.
Um, I use speech-to-text for coding. Can you do this on your phone or tablet? So I just use what's built into my phone. It's not as good as Aquavoice, but it definitely suffices. So, when I talk to my second brain in Slack, I'll just use what's built into my phone, so… I don't think Aquavoice has a mobile tool. Maybe they do, actually. I would be interested in using that if they did.
All right.
Cool, so…
Let's see, uh, how are we looking now? So, it's still in the middle of Phase 2, and… okay, phase three is actually done.
So let's see if we can validate phase three really quickly.
All right. Okay. So here are the completed tasks.
Set up the requirements. Um, embedding wrapper… hold on. Uh, I actually switched to UV for package management. I did that in Phase 2, that I was doing in parallel. Let's make sure that we update that. Okay, I just… I just realized that it did step on the toes of Phase 2, so I'm just fixing that really quick. But anyway, we have the embeddings.
the database abstractions, this is where we connect to SQLite, and then we have the indexing and the memory search.
They had to fix some things in the middle of implementation as it was validating. But take a look at this. It actually did a full index, so it already indexed my memory files into my database. And then it did some searching here. So it ran everything that a second brain would usually do in order to search, and so.
We could go into another conversation, though, and we could ask it to search through our memories. Like, we already have the index and everything set up. I know that it feels like we're doing it kind of quickly, but we're using the PRD to guide our implementation, so we're able to move pretty fast.
Okay, and so let me go to bypass permission mode again.
Carson asked, uh, what are my Aquavoice stats? I'll show you.
Almost at 900,000 words. 27-day streak, time saved, almost 11 days. Yeah, I use it a lot. Uh, so Aquavoice DOM is not free. It is $10 a month, but it is, like, the best $10 a month I've ever spent.
But I know there are some free and open source options out there, like Epicenter Whispering, that are pretty good, but this is, like, the best I've seen.
Whisper flow is really, really good, too. Ivo said there are Aquavoice mobile apps. Okay, I need to get on that for sure. Okay.
All right, so how does my second brain know about the searching capabilities when I first start a Claude Code session?
Does it have access to that through my Claude.md? Like, do you have the indexing and search functions documented there?
Because one thing that I'm asking about here very intentionally, is, like, how does our second brain know about the capability that we just built? This is a good, like, golden nugget for you guys. As you are building your second brain.
And you're adding in the different phases, you need to make sure that the second brain understands that it has that capability, right? And that's typically… that'll go in something like a Claude.md.
So you can see right here that, like, the built-in commands I'm documenting this. Like, we don't have things for the heartbeat yet, but we just implemented phase three, so we have the ability to search.
So we have that documented, and so, yeah, now I can go into a brand new Claude Code session.
And, uh, wait, it's phase two. Okay, phase two is done as well, so we can actually test this here. Okay, so we're going to test a couple of things. We just built phase two, which means we have the start session hook. And so now I can say, without reading the soul.md, because you should have it injected through the start session hook, I want you to.
Summarize your role based on the soul.md file. Alright, so what we should see here is it shouldn't have to make a tool called a read-a file. It should just automatically know about it. So this is the moment of truth. This is our first test for phase number two.
There we go. All right, so no tool call based on what got injected at session start, here's my summary. My role is Cole's AI second brain. So, boom, there we go. The session hook is working here.
And if you want to look at this, we can see the settings.json. These are the three hooks that it built for us here. Nice and simple, just using UV to run these Python scripts, and then we also have the whole memory flush process when we end a session.
And so, for example, I can say, I want you to search through my memories to find out some information about me. I'll just do, like, a really generic question here. So this is now testing phase number three, because what we should see here.
is, uh, just search anything. I want to demonstrate the memory searching that we just built. So I'm just going to give it kind of a generic request here, just so we can see the tool call for it using the memory search script. Take a look at that. So, the claude.md, our global rules, describes how to.
invoke our memory search, and then it specifies a parameter, like, um, my background and interest. We can see that it got the vector search score, so it's performing RAG with semantic search under the hood, and then everything that we see.
In the logs here are the chunks that we got back from our, you know, vector database through SQLite.
So there we go. Got some information from each of them. There we go. Very cool.
Looking very good. So there's phase three. Nice. And now, the other test that I want to do for Phase 2 is I want to test what happens when I end a session. Because remember, we need our daily logs to update with a summary of every single conversation. We want our agent to be able to learn from every single conversation. So.
If we look in the daily logs folder right now, we have one for today.
And it's pretty sparse right now. We just have, you know, like, our Bootstrap completed. We established the pillars for our habits, right? Captured sauna project ID, we built phase one, right? Like, super basic right now. We haven't captured much yet.
But if I close the session, take a look at this. I exited the session. I don't know if you guys saw that, you had to watch, like, really closely, but there was a terminal that popped up for just a split second, because that is invoking the underlying Claude agent SDK session.
To summarize the conversation, and then update our log file here.
So it's not updated yet, because we're invoking Claude, right? It's gonna take a little bit of time for that to run, and then for us to update this file. But the goal here is when we end a session, or whenever we do a memory compaction, it's going to automatically reason about, like, what part of this conversation do I care about.
saving, like, let's create a summary of it, and then we'll put it in the daily logs. And then later, remember, when we get to phase, the next, or daily reflection phase, this is supposed to be phase 6, not 3, that's when we're going to have the process set up to run every day and do essentially the Claude Code dreaming.
So we'll take all of the raw summaries of conversations and figure out what important lessons we want to distill down into our memory.md. So we'll come to this later, but we have the infrastructure set up now with our hooks and the whole memory flushing process like I described.
So let's go back, and let's see if it is done. So I'm going to go… Open the file again… hold on… Let me go… Okay, so it's still not updated. Maybe something's actually broken here.
And it's not fair to expect that we're gonna, like, build everything perfectly right away. There might legitimately be a problem.
So, it does feel like it should have been done by now.
So I'm actually going to ask it here. So I'm going to go back to the session where I implemented Phase 2, and I'm just going to say, hey, I ended a conversation, and I'm not seeing anything updated in my daily log. I'm not confident that the whole memory flush process is actually working. So I want you to look into this and try to see if you can, like, run it, and.
Do a dry run to see if you can get it to work, or figure out what the error is, if it is not working. That was not a very eloquent prompt, but it's good enough for what we need here. So, let me check. Yeah, so the file's still not updated. I mean, maybe it actually is still running. Maybe I'm being a little impatient, but… I think it might be broken, but it's okay, because we're just going to, uh, let it rip.
And let it figure it out.
Okay. So in the meantime, while we work through the problem in phase 2.
I'm not going to focus on this too much because you guys get the idea of when you encounter a problem, you just let it know in the same session where you're building that phase.
Right. And so, what I'm going to do here… is I'm just going to move on, and I'm going to start the planning process for phases number four and five. So I'm going to open up two more Claude Code sessions here.
We're gonna make sure… I'm gonna make sure that we build everything, uh, that we need for the next hour here.
Okay. Oops, I mean to do that. Alright, so I'm going to go here. I'm going to run the prime again twice. So I'm just going to keep setting that context up front.
And, uh, these two phases are actually going to go pretty quick. They don't take that long. So we're gonna add in the direct integrations.
And the reason this is going to be really fast is because we have a standard template.
for our integrations. I'll actually show you guys this really quick here. It's pretty cool. One of the big resources that I built for you guys. So, within the repository, and the PRD creation process actually references this.
If we go into .claude and we go into scripts and Integrations, we have this integration template.
So we're going to use this as a starting point to build any of the integrations, the arms, for our second brain. So, if you want to ever build a new integration, you can just point your Claude code to this file. I'll put a link to… it's not like ultra important, but in case you're interested, like, I'll put a link to this in the Zoom chat as well.
But this is, like, a good starting point for how I always set up my integrations. And so, uh, that's going to make it really easy for us.
that, um… like, it's gonna be very easy to build these integrations, each one of them, because they're going to follow a very similar format. And then the other thing that we're doing in parallel here is just adding in the skills. And this is so easy, because we're just going to copy all of them in the reference repo that I have for you guys.
Like, the Excalidraw diagram skill and the whole, like, um, PowerPoint skill and social media skills, mostly, like, that's why I'm gonna rip through this really fast.
Just some hint that the video recording is going to stop soon. Uh, that's just from one of the note-takers, Dom. I appreciate you mentioning that, but we're good here for that main recording in the workshop.
Alright, so let's go back. I want to quickly check on the cascade and all the okay.
The memory flush pipeline is working correctly. I ran two tests. While you didn't see anything from your previous session, the hooks were just created during this session. Your prior session ending didn't have them registered yet. I don't think that is true, actually.
Because I had started a new session. No, actually, I had started a new session, uh, after the hooks were made, so there is something that is wrong here. Don't get lazy on me. I need you to figure out why the hook didn't fire correctly, or why the hook didn't run right.
It got lazy on me here. It told me that it was just because I needed to restart Claude, but we obviously saw the start session hook work, so we know that we loaded in all of the hooks after we built them, so… we'll work through that. Yeah, fair enough, let me actually dig into this properly.
Multiple potential failure points to check. Alright, so we'll let it work through that.
let's go into Phase 4 and 5 now. Alright, so right now it gave us an overview through the prime. Next up is phase number four. So we're going to add in our integrations. For you, this could be way different, but for me, it's going to be Gmail, Asana, Slack, calendar, and Circle. All right.
So, let's go ahead and start planning for phase number four. So, based on the PRD, let me know what we're going to implement, and then also, now that we're going to get into some environment variables for our platforms, tell me what you need for environment variables, because I actually want to just set this up front for you, so we can go right into the implementation and validation.
This is another golden nugget for you guys here.
is whenever you're about to go into something that you know needs API keys, like, we're gonna integrate with Gmail and Asana and Google Calendar. We want to get the environment variable set up ahead of time, so that way, once we go into implementation.
The agent can write the code and do the validation in one shot. We don't want it to write the code and then, like, try to, you know, sort of, like, half-validate things, but it doesn't… it can't actually, like, interact with our services yet.
And so, um, it's much more efficient to just set up the environment variable right away. So it tells us what we need for Asana and slack and Gmail.
Um, so this part… this part is, like, really custom to me. So you can just follow the instructions that it gives you for yourself, but actually what I'm going to do is I'm going to copy over the .env.
That I have from… My, uh… other repository, so I'm going to copy this file. I'm going to do this off-camera really quick.
I'm going to paste this here. Alright. And then I'm going to also copy my Google token.
So, give me a second to do that. And for whatever integrations you're setting up, remember, just ask Claudeco whatever you need to do.
So I'm gonna copy my Google credential. Paste that… And then also my token copy paste.
Okay. There we go. So I copied over these files. My master environment variables from my main second brain.
Um, well, actually, maybe I should do that one. Hold on. I'm going to do it from the dry run that I did yesterday. That actually is going to be much better.
Um, let me actually find that… okay. Okay, let me go off camera again really quick. Sorry, guys, I knew this was going to be one of those, like, annoying things I have to do off-camera, but I'll make it really quick.
Um, copy the .env, copy… put that into .claude, paste it. Okay, there we go.
So here's what I got. I got my .env.
I have my Google credentials and then the token that we generate here. This is just specifically how I have to connect to my Google services.
Okay, so I'm going to tell it that now.
I'm gonna say, um, copy path. I don't want it to read this file.
But I wanted to know that, like, this is where I have the environment variable set. So I have these mbars set in this file. Don't read it, but you can use this.
So, I'm going to paste in, so I have the Asana access token. I have the slack bot token, slack app token. You can ask your coding agent for help for setting up all of these. I have the circle admin token just for all my integrations. I went through the process.
Before this, obviously, too. Get all these things set up.
Um, boom circle community URL.
Um, heartbeat Slack channel. Uh, what else do I have here? Just whatever it tells me it needs right?
Um, GitHub token. And then, um, I also have… and then I'm going to give it the path to the Google credentials.
and the token here. Copy.
Copy relative path, paste it. Use this for Google.
services off. All right, there we go. So Justin said, why don't you just let it read the tokens? It has access to the entire file system, so it already has access to the keys, no?
Uh, so it's not actually… Justin, that's a good question, but it's not reading the environment variables by default. And we can also block it from ever reading the environment variables, and so, uh, no, I don't want it to ever read it. I'm just going to tell it, like, hey, you have these environment variables in the .env, so you can set up the… integration scripts to use these environment variables, but I never want to actually send them into the context window of my agent, because it's going out to a cloud model, and just for security, it's pretty critical, yeah.
So, all right. Very good. And then we did a prime for phase five. So I'm going to say I'm working on phase four in parallel. So now for phase five, let's work on the skills here. So according to the PRD, just like we've been doing before, let me know what we should do for phase five. And I can even give you some skills.
to copy over. Because basically for phase five, when we add in the skills.
It's just gonna be bringing in all the ones that I have for you guys in the reference repo. So this is gonna be very simple to knock out in parallel.
So while these two are running here, I'm going to check really quickly on what we're doing for Phase 2, because remember, we were having some issues with Phase 2, where the session end hook was not working. So, wow, it's actually still debugging this here.
Um, okay, so it found a bug in the settings.json, and then… Okay, so I think it fixed it, actually. Let's take a look. So if we go into our memory here…
Um, okay, so… so you're saying if I start a new conversation, and then I talk to Claude Code, and then I exit the session, now we're gonna see an update to the daily log folder for today.
Let's see what it says. I want to make sure we're actually good here.
Because one thing that's kind of weird is the fact that it didn't actually change anything to this file.
Let's see, or maybe, I guess maybe it just reverted it, because, uh, it was just testing. Let's see, let's see what happens.
Yes, that's the expectation. Okay, well, let's try this out.
So I'm going to go into… Um, another Claude Code session here.
And we'll have a little conversation with Claude. Uh, wait, hold on.
Oh, it has another error here. getting this error when I start a Claude code session. All right. So we're not quite there yet. We're not quite there yet.
Well, that's okay. I mean, when I was building the second brain myself, there were definitely a couple of phases that I had to knock out correctly, or that it had to iterate on to knock out correctly. Um, so… okay, the only actual change I made is adding masher to session end, since the error said hooks was undefined, which means schema requires it.
Okay, well, I don't really know how much I trust that here.
So, we'll try. We'll have a brief conversation with Claude.
Alright, I want you to search the web for the latest on the Claude code leaks.
Right, so we're just doing, like, a little bit of something here. I want, like, some substance here that would need to be, like, captured as a summary within our daily logs. So let's let it do that, and then we'll end the session, and we'll give it some time for the memory flush to run, and we'll make sure that this file actually gets updated. This is a core part of our second branch, so I want to make sure this is looking good.
All right. And then we're still in the planning phase for phase number 4.
Okay. So plan feature. Okay, I'm gonna give you a path to a bunch of skills I want you to bring in. Let's just go ahead and copy in all of those skills instead of creating new custom ones.
So one thing that your PRD might do is like give you a couple of options for skills based on how you described you want the second brain to work for you. For my case, though, because I'm kind of just showing you guys how I built my exact second brain, I am just going to.
copy over the exact skills. that I use myself.
So, I'm going to say… Uh, look in this path.
And I want you to bring in all of these skills. The only ones that we're really going to have to customize here is the, um, memory search and Obsidian Vault structure skills.
All of the other ones are general enough where, like, I can just bring it right here and use it immediately.
Right? So, I know I'm kind of, like, trumping its planning, and I'm just kind of saying, like, alright, here you go, this is what I want to build right now. And sometimes that's what you gotta do with Claude Code. Like, you know what you're looking for, and you're like, you know what, like, I appreciate your ideas, but no thank you. Like, these maybe are cool skills. Like, this one to help me capture.
And, like, manage my meeting notes, like, that's actually pretty cool. Maybe you want to build that from the PRD. But definitely for the sake of my demonstration here, I just want to bring in the skills that I have in my own, like, second brain that I actually am using.
Alright, cool. So we'll let that go. And all right. So we did some web web research. So we're back to validating phase 2. So I'm going to end the session here.
There we go, so we started… we started… okay, this is actually working now, I think, because now the terminal is kept alive. If you guys remember from earlier, when I ended the session last time, when it didn't work, the terminal popped up, but then it, like, immediately closed down.
So now, there we go. Okay, there we go.
Now we got it. So this is the summary from the conversation we just had, because we asked Claude Code to research recent Claude Code source code leaks.
Now this has ended up… and the cool part is, we don't just dump the entire conversation, right? Like, we have that background memory flush cloud agent SDK summarize things. So, yes, we still want to do that promotion process to the memory.md that we'll get to in just a little bit here, but.
We still want our daily logs to not be, like, super convoluted, like, just dumping tokens after tokens of tool calls and questions that we're asking it and everything, so it's good that we have something relatively concise. But even this is, like, gonna get pretty unruly over time, as you have a lot of Claude Code sessions every single day, so that's why we still need to.
you know, eventually promote the really important stuff to our memory.md file. So that's what we're going to get into in just a second here, after we are done with phases 4 and 5.
So, alright, this is working perfectly right now, so go ahead and make a commit. After we're done, we always want to make a commit.
It's another reason we split things up into phases from the PRD. We want focused work, and we want to commit at each stage, so if anything goes wrong, you can revert to what we had when things were working.
Cool. All right. So we're still planning phase four.
And then, uh, we are also planning… Phase 5. All right. So let's see what questions we got here now.
Let's see. Tristan asked, is it easy to adjust the proactivity level after more trust is built? Yes, it is. Yep. And this is something I've done myself where I'm just going back to our diagram here for the integrations, like with my email integration, for example.
I started by only giving my second brain the ability to read emails. It was not allowed to do any kind of even drafting.
But then once I got comfortable with how it was handling my inbox, I'm like, okay, it really, like, gets me now. I think I can actually trust it to draft emails. All I had to do was tell my second brain, like, hey, you're doing a good job with my email. How about you go ahead and make it so that you are able to draft emails as well? So edit the integration so that we add new capability to the email integration.
And then also change the heartbeat so that every 30 minutes, it drafts emails to anything new that landed in my inbox that doesn't already have a reply or a draft.
And then also, we can change the soul.md because we're kind of giving it that next level of proactivity, right? So we wanted to, like, describe, like, in its identity, it's gone from being an observer to, like, actually being an advisor, as I put it in the template for the PRD.
So whenever you want to add that next level of proactivity, it's generally, like, you change things in your integration, you change something in your soul.md, and then if it's something that's kind of like doing autonomously, then you'll probably have to change the heartbeat as well.
Yeah, awesome question. Um, Tom asked, do you use any speech-to-text when you talk to your second brain on your phone? I know you like Aqua Voice on your Windows machine. So, yeah, I guess I already answered this because someone else asked it, but I'll just say it really quickly again. I just use what's built into my phone, but we… I did just finally hear that, uh.
Aqua Voice has a mobile app, so I will be using that on my phone going forward.
Um, smoke that says, I assume we're building the second brain using the piv loop methodology. 100%. We are. Yep, that's what we're seeing here. So, a lot of these questions were asked earlier on, because I kind of have a backlog of questions, so yeah, some of them, I think, have already kind of been answered here.
But, uh, yeah, all right, so let's go back here, because we now have our plan.
For both phase four and five. So.
Claude code did this other annoying thing just now, that it sometimes does, where it will go right into plan mode instead of going through my piv loop, where it creates the plan as a markdown document.
So it's kind of annoying. But, you know, I'm just gonna roll with it right now. I could, like, retry and have it, like, write out to a markdown, but whatever. I'm just gonna let it go with this. So, it's going to create… the foundations for our integrations here.
So, Google, Gmail, Asana, Slack, Circle looking good. The important thing I want to make sure I understands here is that we have the environment variables already set up.
Okay, it actually knows that, yep, so we have the .claude slash .env with all credentials already set up.
Um, so yeah, I'm gonna go ahead and send it off to implementation here.
I would probably want to iterate on this a little bit more. I'm a little bit short on time here.
Um… Yeah, I want to make sure it knows all the environment variables that it has access to. Actually, you know what, I'm going to iterate once on this. I'm going to say, okay, you need to call out in this plan all of the environment variables that it has access to, not just a shortened list.
Where you have etc. At the end, right? Like, we can't have that. Okay, so we'll we'll iterate once, and then we'll go into implementation. I just want to be really careful, because this is something that, um, coding agents in general just mess up on, is they don't quite.
They don't do the best with configuration and environment variables, so I want to make sure that's very explicit here.
Okay? And then for phase 5, adding in our skills. We're copying all 17 skills from the my other second brain. So all of these skills, they are available to you guys in the repo that I link to in the description. So dot cloud.
skills. I'm just gonna bring in all of these. Like, it's super simple, there's not much work that I have to do for this phase, because I'm just going to bring in all the capabilities that I already use. I'm building my full second brain for you guys here.
All right. So here are all our different skills, and then specifying that for these two specifically, I'm going to have to customize, right? Like, my memory search that I just built from scratch in Phase 3, that might look a little bit different. So the skill that, you know.
really tells Claude Code how to search through my memories, and how I want it to. That might need to be different, because the script is built differently.
And then also for it to understand my Obsidian Vault structure, because the name of the vault itself is different. And then the way that you organize your Obsidian Vault might be different as well, so… This is actually one of the most important skills for my second brain, because it essentially describes, like, when you're going to start looking through my Obsidian vault, here's an index of it, here are the core folders and how I usually organize my information.
Alright, cool. Sean said, just getting started with phase one. Oh, man, I'm sorry that Claude is going slower for you guys. That's a bummer. Um, but yeah, I mean, luckily, this is all recorded for you to go back through it at your own pace. So I totally understand that for a lot of you guys, you might have to do that. But yeah, whatever it takes for you guys to.
To get through it, the important thing is… Even if you have to invest quite a bit of time up front building your second brain, it pays dividends so incredibly quickly. Like, I was spending, like, 20, 30 hours a week back in January or February when I just was getting started with it, and it was definitely taking me more time to build it than it actually saved me, but now.
It is definitely flipped. Like, it's saving me so much time. And I am able to… Um, to evolve it, like, really quickly now. Like I said, like, what we go through in this workshop, it'll take some time, but we're building the foundation so you can pretty much one-shot everything you want to build on top of it after.
So, okay, let's go in and I'm going to start a brand new Claude Code session. We can see that the end hook started again. So we're going to update our daily logs from that session.
I'll do slash execute, and then we will execute phase 5.
There we go. So let's go ahead and bring in the skills.
And then for phase number four, it is calling out all the exact environment variables in the .env. And remember, it didn't read it, I just listed it out explicitly in this conversation.
So we are good now to move into creating our integrations. And this will be cool because after phase four is done, we can have it run these queries. It can search through my recent emails, it can go through my Asana tasks. We'll do a little bit of testing here.
Uh, hopefully it doesn't reveal anything too sensitive. But yeah, we'll have it ripped through this as well.
All right. Carson said, I'm still waiting for my limit to reset, oh boy. That's a bummer.
All right. All right, Claude's doing its stupid glitch again. There we go bypass permission mode. All right.
Cool, cool. We are off to the races. So… Alright, we got… Oh, that's great. Why does it, um… Oh, and this is my old Zapier thing.
I don't care about this. I don't care about… So this key is obviously not in use anymore. I don't care about Zapier.
get rid of that. I don't know why it's found a real API key. Well, it thinks it's a real API. Well, I mean, I guess it was at one point. Sure, whatever, just get rid of that. I'm not using that anymore.
I did actually play around with using Zapier as a way to connect to my services at one point. And so I was using this for real at one point, but I just started building my own integrations, like I'm teaching with you guys here. Um, so yeah, luckily this isn't something I'm actually using. I don't know where that even came from.
But I guess that's checked into source control, but it's deleted key, so that's funny, though.
All right. Okay, so while this is running here… David asks, do you self-improve skills?
Um, so the thing is, David, I don't have my coding agent improve its own skills.
I go through the process myself. Right, like, I talked to Claude, and I say, like, hey, this skill didn't do as good as I wanted to, like, let's have a conversation here about how we can make it better.
And then I have it maybe adjust the skill after I, like, approve the change, right? Like, I want to be in the driver's seat when I evolve my skills. You definitely could create a process, like in the daily reflection or something, where it would figure out how to make the skills better, but I don't really have that level of trust yet, you know?
So, yeah, that's a good question. All right.
Let's see, so next question here. Evo asked, how did you generate the Excalidraw diagram you are showing? It's so elaborate, but well structured.
Yeah, so I really just use the Excalidraw diagram skill that I have shared with you guys. Now, obviously, for something as elaborate as this, it took a lot of prompting and a lot of iteration. So it's even close to one shot this, it took quite a bit of work, but… Uh, the beauty of the Excalidraw diagram skill that I have shared with you guys is it also has this whole, like, process of being able to render the diagram, view the PNG, and then, like, figure out discrepancies and iterate on it autonomously.
And so it is able to, like, improve itself over time. Or, like, evolve the diagram before it comes back to you for feedback.
All right. Cool, so let me go back to the logs here… See where we're at. Oh, it already finished that, wow.
Okay. So, oh yeah, because this is the skills one.
Um… Yeah, alright, well, there are our skills. I mean, that's phase number five. It's really, really quick, because we're just bringing in all of our skills here. So, now we have everything that you guys can bring in. I mean, I don't really even have to do that much testing for this, because I've covered all these… a lot of these skills already, like, we can create PDFs now, we can create remotion videos.
Very cool. All right. So now we're just on phase four here. Alright, so let me continue with phase four.
Excuse me.
All right. Um… You can go back to the chat.
Jeffrey said, I set it up using cursor, and I think it's working now. Thanks so much. Okay, awesome. Glad it's working for you, Jeffrey. Very cool.
Um, let's see, smoke dev said, do you utilize Archon to delegate coding to the second brain?
It's kind of the opposite, right? Like, I have my second brain delegate the coding to Archon.
So, in my second brain, I'll show you guys, like, the actual repository.
It's a little bit of a mess, you'll have to bear with me, because this is the belly of the beast here. This is where I'm working. Let me close out of this here. This is my, like, full repo for my second brain. And, um… Within my dot cloud skills, I just copied over the Archon skill, so it knows how Archon works, it knows how to invoke workflows.
And it will, uh, when I want it to, like, you know, handle a GitHub issue, or review a pull request, it knows automatically to load the Archon skill and then invoke an Archon workflow. So it's delegating all of the coding tasks to Archon, which is, you know, also using the Claude Agent SDK, but it has the whole Archon system built around it.
Alright, very cool. So, yeah, you can see here that Phase 4 is in the middle of implementing, and it's actually testing, like, take a look at that. We are navigating our inbox, so we're able to query our inbox now. Very cool. So now we're just building the Asana integration as well. So it's knock it out step by step.
And it's testing all the integrations as it builds them. Super cool.
Mike asked, are there any first brain dependencies for the second brain to work?
Um, you gotta have some comfortability with Claude code, that's about it, honestly, for your first brain.
And you have to, like, already have, um, you know, things to integrate with, right? But I assume you already have, like, some kind of task management software, some kind of place to store knowledge.
I assume that you are asking mostly as a joke, but that is funny, Mike. I wanted to give some kind of answer, though, still.
Okay, cool. So, by the way, guys, we are done with Phase 5 now.
Because, um, there was not much work that had to be done here. Like, obviously, we had to do a little bit of customization for the Obsidian Vault structure, so we have the Dynamist workshop slash memory, and then it's just outlines, like, here are all the core files that we have here. And if you guys are using Obsidian to do a lot more than just the second brain memory.
Like I showed with my vault, there's a lot of other things I'm storing for content ideation and my diagrams, everything. Well, then you can have your second brain update the Obsidian vault. Like every once in a while, what I'll do is I'll tell my second brain to analyze all the folders in my vault.
and then make sure that this skill is up to date, right? So, sometimes you'll just have a task every once in a while where you just want to, like, make sure that the system is up to date. That's just one example of that.
Cool. Ras has said my brain just slain I don't know what's lane. I assume it's a typo labeled 2,000 unread emails in my personal email in unsubscribed to 100 plus newsletters. I hope that was intentional, Rasmus, but if it was, that's very cool.
Oh, wow. 2.30 a.m. Here in Thailand, my brain has stopped working. That is pretty late, or early, I should say.
Uh, Jay said you said Obsidian is private, but isn't open source, which seems, um, oxymoronic. Any actual open source recommendations versus Obsidian?
Yeah, I don't know of… I mean, there are quite a few things out there, but it slips my mind, specific names of them right now.
Um, but there are a lot of, like, actual open source options. But when you install and run Obsidian, like, it is 100% local. It's just, like, the source code isn't on GitHub, you know?
All right. So yeah, anyway, let's open back up. Let's see where we're at with module or with phase number four.
We're almost there. So we're just building the circle integration. Then we have to document things like our claw.md, because remember, our global rules is where I store commands, right? Like, here's how we search.
Here's how we index our memory into our database.
Okay. Oh, yeah, it has to figure out. Okay, this is something that I've noticed before. It doesn't realize that circle is up migrated to a version 2.
Um, let's see, yeah. So, Circle has actually migrated to a V2. I know my API keys are valid, so this is just a problem. You have to figure out the right, uh, documentation for Circle.
So, it's just, like, a little blip there, but anyway, I'm going to start the other Claude Code sessions to get ready for our next builds here.
All right. Yeah, uh, Jay, I thought that Obsidian was open source, but I found out pretty recently that it's not actually.
I did think it was, though, too. Okay, so what I'm going to do here is I'm going to prime.
I'm gonna get everything primed, ready to, uh, go into the next phases. So, we'll… we got… we got time still, so I'm gonna let it… I'm gonna let it finish the phase four.
And we'll do a little bit of validation as well. So we've got the skills done already. We've done everything with our core memory layer and hooks and our memory search pipeline, so we're making really good progress, and we're in the middle of adding in our direct integrations. That is almost done now.
And we'll just do, like, a little bit of validation to make sure it can, like, find my tasks in Asana and things like that. We'll make sure that everything's documented so our second brain knows how to leverage these things when we want it to, you know, like, what tasks do I have that questions should directly translate it to.
doing a search in Asana. So we'll make sure that's the case as well.
And then we will get into the heartbeat daily reflection, and the Slack chat interface. So we'll try to knock all of this out.
in parallel here, because both the daily reflection and heartbeat is actually Module 6, so there's just, like, a little bit of a mislabeling in the diagram here. I'll have to correct that, but yeah, all right.
So we're doing a prime here. Okay, so good. Yeah, while while this keeps running, I'm going to go ahead and answer some more questions here.
Yeah, so 30 minutes left, we're gonna be on grind time here for the last part of this. Uh, I might have to go a little bit over, just because I want to make sure I have time for you guys' questions, and we'll have to make sure that we don't rush too fast with these things.
But, uh, definitely when I have the edited version of the course out, like, it's gonna… I'm gonna be able to cut out quite a bit and make it really nice and concise, because we'll cut out, like, when we're waiting for the agent to finish coding and things like that.
All right. Um, Bob said, Claude says that vector tied to Obsidian speeds things up a lot. That's why we're doing it. Yep, everything local markdown in Obsidian with the SQLite vector database, it is blazing fast.
Um, let's see, Sean said… Since you are using Obsidian, can you suggest how we can diverge and use agentic RAG? I thought I already answered that, Sean. I already answered that question earlier, so for the sake of time, I'll move on here, because I talked about agentic reg and how we're doing hybrid search.
Um, I answered your question specifically, and then…
Oh, I haven't, okay. Boy, that's so weird. I don't know why this is popping up now, because I've already answered all these questions.
Yeah, okay, so all 3 of those, Shawna, have already answered it. So I assume that you just sent that earlier on, or something. I'm not really sure what happened.
Okay. See. So Pat said, how would you approach this if we had started with the second brain from some of the previous trainings and want to improve it?
Yeah, that's a good question, Pat. So, if you already have something built off of other workshops that we've done in Dynamis, or you're following along with OpenClaw running that or something, and you want to improve what you have, then all I would recommend doing is pointing your.
coding agent, or your second brain to this repository. The one that I have linked in the description. Just point it there and say, hey, I want you to spin up sub-agents to research this code base and also research my second brain and see if there's any good ideas that we could pick out from Cole's second brain.
So you can let the coding agent guide that entire conversation.
Yeah. Cool. So all right, let me go back… See how far we are? Okay.
Phase 4 is complete. We have Gmail, Asana, Slack, and Circle.
Um, all the integration files that it created…
Okay, very good. Good, good. So let's go ahead and test this now. So I'm going to open up a new conversation.
I'll actually just do it right here. So I'll open up a brand new conversation, and I'll say, uh, what tasks do I have in Asana? Or, okay, here, actually, I'm going to redo that because I'm not even going to say Asana. I want to prove to you that it already has the understanding that, like, when I'm saying tasks, I am talking about Asana.
What tasks do I have due next week? Right? Like, super simple question. Like, we want to be able to just ask basic questions to our second brain, and it should automatically know, like, here are the integrations, here's the process, here are the commands that I run. Like, this should just all be super automatic. That's the goal of the second brain. It needs to feel like it knows us.
And, like, that's a cool demonstration of this. It's pretty sweet. Like, even though we've just got it started building our second brain, this is already a nice and simple example of, like, it gets us, right? Like, it knows how to search, it knows I'm using Asana. I didn't have to say anything.
So now it's just ripping through a ton of different tasks here. I guess I'm giving you guys, like, a little bit insight into what I got going on here, because it's just showing everything, but that's why I picked Asana, because I don't really mind that. I mean, it might be a little bit weirder if I did, like, my inbox or something.
But this is definitely good, so… Unfortunately, your sawn tasks don't appear to have explicit due dates. Uh, well, yeah, I mean, that's just how I have things set up here, but… Anyway, you can see here, like, for example, I got my Archon video going out on Wednesday, so…
There we go, that's what's going on. So, just a quick little example there, and then if I were to, you know, close my session here, now we've got the Claude Agent SDK popped up doing the summarization to put into our daily logs. So every single conversation, all of the different components of our second brain are.
coming together very, very nicely here. So, let's go ahead and close this out.
And, uh, now we are ready to move on to our next phases here.
Uh, Carson said, ooh, wait, something clicked. Aha, I can also integrate the company Jira to my second brain and use that as to-dos as well. And yes, that is 100% right, Carsten, love that. Yeah, yeah. So I don't use Juro myself, but you definitely could, like, I mean, I just use Asana instead, right? But yeah, certainly a company Jira would be fantastic.
Do you have your second brain help you manage the things that are due for you there?
Yeah, all right. Cool. So we have primed. We have now finished with our integrations.
And our skills. And we are now blazing on over to our heartbeat daily reflection and chat interface. So here's what we're gonna do. I'm gonna try to go through this pretty quickly so we can end decently on time here. So I'm going to say…
Alright, let's go on to Phase 6. Let's create the proactive systems with the heartbeat and reflection. So take a look at the PRD, and let me know what we need to build based on what's laid out there. Alright, again, maybe not the most elaborate prompt, but it's all good. Alright, and then for the next one here.
I'm actually building phase 6 in parallel in a separate session, so I want to move on to phase number seven. We're going to create Slack as my way to talk remotely to my second brain. So I want you to analyze the PRD, let me know what we should build for my second brain.
Also, keep in mind that in my environment variable, so I'm going to give you the path to the .env again.
I'll copy this path. Um, and send them into the prompt as well.
I already have… The environment variable set up for my Slack bot that I have created.
And so I have the two environment variable names that I'll paste at the start of the prompt. I have these set up already. So we're good to go. We have the bot already set up.
And, um, it's already installed in my Slack workspace as well.
So it's actually quite nice that I already have this set up because that way I don't have to spend time doing all of that. Just know that, like, setting up Slack in particular is a little bit tricky sometimes, but Claude Code knows how to walk you through it exactly.
Like, I had to do no research myself, I just said, like, hey, let me know the permissions, let me know how I can enable socket mode for security and things like that, and it just, like, walked me through it all. It was so good. And, uh, also, it's good that I don't have to go through that, because you guys might not be using Slack anyway, right? Like, a different platform, so I don't want to spend too much time setting up a very specific platform that might not be a part of your second brain.
So all right. So here we go. This is where we're going to be building for Phase 6, our proactive system. So we have the heartbeat, this is what's going to run every 30 minutes during our active hours. That's going to use no large language model. So for token efficiency's sake, we're going to gather data from our different APIs.
So this is where we are connecting the integrations with our heartbeat. So we're talking about this step right here. Gather information, then send it into the Claude Agent SDK.
So the Agent SDK reasons, and then we can optionally send a Slack channel post. And this is where I typically am reviewing my notifications from my second brain that every half hour when it alerts me of things that need my attention.
All right. And then we're preventing it from editing soul.md. This is a file that I really want to protect. I don't want it to self-evolve this file, so I've actually explicitly… I'm going to be explicitly blocking the heartbeat from editing it by itself.
So just an example of how we want to have certain parts of the brain protected from the agent changing. So I know we've talked a lot about having the agent self-evolve itself and its skills. You can add that if you want, but a lot of those things, I'll like purposely prevent it from changing.
All right, so yeah, this is looking good to me, so I'm gonna, of course, just do my plan feature.
This all looks great, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for phase six.
And boom, there we go, send it in. And let's see what we got here. All right, good. So… Uh, here's the full picture for Phase 7 with our chat interface.
We are creating our bot. This is the adapter, so this is where you receive messages from Slack.
And then we're using socket mode, so there's no public URL. This is actually something very important that I've set up for Slack.
The bot connects outbound to Slack via webhooks, so there is nothing that… there are no public URL that can be attacked. That's one of the big things that we've seen with OpenClaw.
It's gonna listen for direct messages, and whenever we mention the bot in a channel, each Slack thread, this is important, each Slack thread maps to one agent SDK conversation. The key of the conversation is the Slack thread ID.
So that way we have conversation history in each of our Slack threads.
So we can continue the conversation, and the kicker is, even have parallel conversations with our second brain remotely, because we can have multiple threads going on at the exact same time. Kind of like I showed you guys at the start of our workshop here, like, this is our… this is my actual Slack channel where I talk to my second brain. I have all these conversations.
Going on in parallel, or at least I can. I mean, this is just, like, kind of an archive, but you get the idea there.
All right, so I think this is actually great. So I'm going to go ahead and do all right. This is good. Let's go ahead and create the structure plan for phase seven.
and send that off.
All right. Renata said, I'm loving it. But I have to tell you, it is not easy to do that from a 20 minute YouTube video. I know, I understand the YouTube video is just an overview. Good that we have this kind of workshop. The Dynamist membership is really worth on value. I appreciate it a lot, Renata.
Yeah, I'm glad you guys are getting a lot out of this workshop, and… One other thing that I wanted to say is, um, I just want to acknowledge again, like, I understand, like, even for 4 hours, this is a lot that we're doing here.
So you guys are totally good. If there's still questions coming up in your mind, I really want… honestly, like, the whole month of April to be focused on, like, let's get questions from you guys. Like, I want you to DM me, I want you to make posts in our community, attend office hour sessions, like, ask away.
For anything that's not super clear to you here, any questions you have around building more for yourself and how to customize it more, like I'm open to all of your guys' questions.
And so I have full expectation that, like, there's gonna be a barrage of questions. Like, I'm ready for it, guys. I want to help you build your second brain. Like, I'm really passionate about this because it's crazy how much time it saves me.
So, yeah, I'm there for you guys, and I hope that this, like, even though I'm going, like, kind of quick here, even for 4 hours, I hope that you're getting a lot of golden nuggets out of this, and of course, like I said, I'll edit this down into the course material that'll be quicker to go through, and you can pause along the way, so… Even if it's, like, you're here absorbing things as much as possible, and then you refine your understanding with the course after, I think that'd be a great way to do it as well.
Um, yeah, Renata said I cannot do it now, I have to do it on my own time, start little by little, and that's totally fair, I love that, yeah. This is something we can even do for customers. Consultation for customers that want this kind of work. Oh yeah, let me tell you, in the next 5-10 years, there is no way that most companies.
won't have something like this for all their employees, because it would just be way too much of a loss if they don't.
Yeah. Pat said we're gonna need a couple of second brain ama sessions. You know what? I might do that. So last week I dedicated a couple of our Dynamis sessions to.
Archon AMA sessions. So doing the exact same thing next week for our second brain. I actually really like that idea. So thank you for bringing that up, Pat.
Because, yeah, like I said, I totally expect you guys to have a lot of questions, because I'm breaking things down as nice and simply as I possibly can, but there's still a lot. I totally… I'm totally acknowledging that.
Yeah, so Will asked, is there a special section to ask these questions in the community?
So, um, you know, there isn't right now, but that is also a really good suggestion.
So I could create specifically like a second brain section of the community, and then also do some AMA sessions next week, and maybe even the week after as well, because I want to give a lot of time for you guys to ask what you need.
Um, so yeah, okay, yeah, thank you guys for the suggestions. I'm definitely gonna, uh, well, I mean, my workday is pretty much gonna be done after this. I mean, this is also a lot for me, but yeah, tomorrow I'd love to get that set up, and I'll get some AMA scheduled here.
Um, Omar said, Microsoft will probably add a second brain co-pilot feature that will miss the mark on everything it should actually be.
It needs to achieve the first brains, Jason. That's hilarious. You guys are too funny. I mean, I'm not disagreeing. Well, I mean, the problem is, anything that produces a… like, any kind of platform that builds a second brain, it's never going to be everything you quite need. Like, OpenClaw or like Claude code building all these features in that, like, kind of makes it a second brain.
It's always going to be more powerful to build it yourself, and that's why we're covering it in this workshop.
Um… David said a demo of you using the second brain. That could be a good session as well. Yeah, like kind of getting into the nitty gritty of like how I'm actually using on the day-to-day. Yeah, yeah. Okay. Wow, you guys are giving really good suggestions now. Thank you.
Um, Pat said, would you be so kind to update the diagrams as the ones you were showing are slightly different from what is in the repo? I didn't actually know that. I'll take a look. Yeah, yeah. Okay.
Alright, cool. So… Alright, it's writing the plan for phase 6, and then it is, yeah, okay, writing the plan for phase seven as well. Okay, so we're almost there for the implementation for phases six and seven.
Okay. Actually, yeah, plan for Phase 7 is done. Good, good. So let's take a look at this.
Uh, I want to build a Slack bot so I can talk to him in Slack, DM, or at mention. Looks good.
So, okay, see, this is another cool thing. It's easier for the second brain to build on itself over time, because we can look at the memory flush.
To have an example of how we're already using the agent SDK. We have a tried-and-true usage of the agent SDK already, so now we can build on top of it. This is a clear example.
of one of the most important things I'm sharing with you guys today. Every single time we build on top of the second brain, it's easier than the last. And because we can reference existing implementations.
We got our environment variables all good to go.
And, uh, we got the task list here, everything we're going to implement. We have our testing strategy as well.
Okay, so we're gonna make sure the bot can reply to itself.
Or no, that it probably doesn't. Yes, we don't want it to reply to itself. We're testing all the edge cases here. Okay, that looks good. Good, good, cool. So, I'm going to go into a brand new session here.
And then we'll do slash execute, give it the path to the plan. All right, there we go. So we're off to the races setting up slack.
Uh, Dom, Phase 4 was implemented. We took care of Phase 4 with the integrations, because remember, I gave the example where I searched through my Asana tasks, so we're able to connect to all of our services now, and then the heartbeat is going to take advantage… so actually, Phase 6 is reliant on.
Phase 4, because our heartbeat is going to pull data from our email and Asana and things like that.
All right. Cool. So, Phase 6 is done as well, so let's take a look at the plan for this.
Let's see. So proactive system, heartbeat and reflection. So we're going to have scheduled proactive systems that monitor our integrations. That's why I just said it's dependent on Phase 4 being done. Generate draft replies, track habits, curate memory, notify Cole of urgent items in Slack.
So, advisor mode, right? Like, that's the core of our sold on MD. Draft but never send.
All right, very good. And then we also have the memory reflection. So this is… we read yesterday's daily log, promote key items to the memory.md, and trim if it's over 200 lines. So this is the whole promotion process, which I don't want you to forget that, because this is, like, just one part of our phase six, but this is one of the most important parts of the system, so I want to call it out that that's what we're working on right here.
the whole promotion process that I covered, um, in this part of our diagram right here. This is the daily reflection that we run once a day. So, alright, this is all looking really good. So we got our implementation plan.
for our self-validation here. And by the way, usually I would iterate on these plans more, like the self-validation isn't, like, the most ideal from what I've seen in some of the prior phases, but it's good enough for what we need for a demo right now. Like, obviously, everything's been building pretty good. We only have that one hiccup in Phase 2.
So, we're going to validate our hooks, we're gonna do a dry run of the heartbeat, so this is really important. Hopefully, your PRD understands that we want to build a dry run for the heartbeat and the memory reflex, so that way we can quickly test things without having to run, like, the entire process.
or, like, post notifications to Slack. So, we're also… but, like, in this case, we're just building it for the first time, we're also going to do a full run. So we're going to promote things to our memory.md, and run the heartbeat.
And so, let's actually go in our Obsidian Vault really quickly here, because I want to show that once we implement this, we're going to see the memory.md grow for the first time. So we have our key decisions, important facts, like, OK, take a look at this, take like a snapshot in your mind of what our memory.md looks like right now.
Because we're going to see it get decently longer after we implement phase six, because it's gonna actually, like, take a look at our logs, so… We have our daily logs, and by the way, this is growing quite a bit, because we've been building on top of our second brain over time, right? It's remembering all these things from past sessions, here are the lessons that we've learned, so this is good, but now we need to take only the most important stuff from this and put it in the memory.md. So we'll see it added here.
After. So, I'm gonna go ahead and start a new session here.
And then I will do a slash execute and then give it the path to phase 6.
And there we go. We're off to the races.
And oh, dang. Well, of course, it asked for permission, so we haven't moved too far in Phase 7 either, but we'll let these implement at the same time here.
All right. So we're definitely going to go a little bit over for the workshop.
I totally understand if, like, if you guys blocked out just 4 hours of your day and you have to drop. Um, but I do want to make sure that I get through everything here. So, luckily, we're going to be pretty much wrapped up with Phases 6 and 7 by the 4-hour mark, so it's really gonna only be, like, the last module.
that I'm gonna have to go over with. And then again, once I have the edited version for the course, it's going to be way less than 4 hours, actually. So, if you want to review things after, go through the recording, or wait for the edited version of the course.
Um, to go through the last modules if you don't have time now, you definitely can. So, the only thing that I'm going to go over time to… Uh, you see my Google credentials in green, don't push them to GitHub. Yeah, thanks, Dragos. I will make sure that that is get ignored.
Uh, yes. Well, this whole repo, I'm gonna actually, like, not push.
or I'll just wipe the history before I push. But yeah, thank you. Make sure that we have that covered there. So yeah, make sure before you push anything, if you have any kind of credential files like this, it should be in the get ignore not okay to push that ever.
It's all… it's all testing accounts anyway, so it's not a big deal.
John said, one more try, is this the starting point?
Um, John, that looks like a really good starting point.
Yep, you got all the commands, you have the skill… yeah, yeah, that's perfect. Yep.
Beautiful. I'll give a nice heart on that there. It looks good. Or a party popper emoji. All right, cool. Yeah. So one thing I was going back to saying here… We will have literally everything in this diagram implemented today, in the 4 hours, except for the last part here with the security layer and infrastructure. So this is the one thing that I'll go a little bit over time to make sure we cover here.
And it'll be the last module for the course, but pretty soon here, we'll have the Daily Reflection Heartbeat and chat interface done, and we can validate it after. Let's see, how far has it come along now? Oh, it's almost done. Okay, so we get to test Slack pretty soon here.
And then for the heartbeat system, uh, it's lagging a little bit behind. So we'll test out Slack, and then hopefully that gives it time for this to finish, and then we can test out our daily reflection and heartbeat.
And luckily, it'll be pretty easy to test, because we'll just see, like, what happens when the memory.md grows. Like, we should watch this grow in the middle of it doing its own validation, and that'll be kind of the confidence that we need.
Okay, so very good. So it created the Slack adapter. It's saying that all we have to do is start the bot, and then we can DM it.
So, actually, what I'm going to do is say, uh, I actually want you to run the bot yourself. So run it for me, and then I'll go ahead and test it.
All right. It's gonna be pretty cool to see, like, how quickly this comes together. We're already going to be able to talk to it in Slack, so it's going to run it as a background task.
Let me check initial output to make sure connected. Okay, again, bot is live and connected in Slack. Go ahead and test it and send a DM or mention it in a channel. All right. So here we go. Moment of truth.
So I am using the same Slack bot that I used in my dry run. So what you're looking at right here, all of this, like, log output.
This is just from some testing that I was doing earlier.
But, uh, I had this running on a DigitalOcean instance that I tore down. So now the only instance of our bot running is what we just started with Claude. So now we're gonna see if our current implementation.
is working. So I'm going to send in a message.
Let's see. All right, I said hi. Hey, there we go. Look at that.
So it says that it's currently thinking. And there we go. Hey, Cole, what's up? How can I help you today? So what else can we do? I could say, give me the or… What is the latest post in the community?
Right? And then we can… we can even do, like, another message, like, what is the next task that I have?
Oh, whoops, I forgot to mention it. So when you're not DMing it, you have to mention it, or, like, that's how it's set up in my PRD. So I'll say, what is the latest post in the community?
And then we can test the parallel nature of it right now as well. So I can, in another… I can start another thread here and say, uh, you know, what is the next task that I have due?
Right? So we can see that they'll both operate at the exact same time here. We can switch between threads, and I can do everything from my phone as well.
So there we go. All right, the latest post in the community is code deep wiring reference. Let's see if that's actually true. So I'll go over here, go to the feed for Dynamis, and there we go. John posted code deep wiring reference. Awesome. All right, so good. We got our circle.
integration tested, all from Slack as well. We can continue the conversation, so I can say, like, for example, you know, what did I just say? So we can make sure that conversation history with the Claude Agent SDK is really being managed properly, um, on the thread level.
We can check our other response as well. My next task due is, you know, the one that I'm working on right now. Second Brain 4-hour workshop. Very cool.
And then we'll get our response here. You just asked, what is the latest post in the community? I pulled circle post and showed you the top five with the code deep wiring reference. And take a look at this. We even have links to all of them as well. So it even pulls the full links that it got from the API as well.
Now everything is, like, really starting to come together, because we've got the session hook loading it up with information so it knows how to use my integrations, we're able to use the integration, do it remotely, I could talk to it from my phone as well. Like, you can start to see how it's, like, every single time I talk to it, I'm demoing, like, everything that we got here.
So, pretty cool. All right. Um, let's go back and see where we're at with phase number six now.
So, Slack is done. Like, we validated that already. Um, oh, of course it got stuck again.
Alright, well, yeah, so phase 7 is done. I mean, that's all we need, right? And the other thing I'll say is that I'm not running the bot on Slack on my computer, I'm hosting that in the VPS. That's one of the last things I'll show with you guys, with the little bit of overtime that I want to give for our workshop here.
I'm just, like, right now, looking at my phone at the alerts that I'm getting for my real second brain that I actually have running. Cool. All right, so we'll let this go.
Maybe what we'll do here, I'll tell it to, like… All right, Slack is working great. Go ahead and make a commit.
And, um, yeah, the other thing is, like, I'm gonna leave this session up, because it's running the Slack bot, so I'll just let that go.
So let's go ahead and start a couple of new Claude code sessions. So we can get ready to implement the security and the VPS deployment stuff. That's all we're going to need. So I'll run the prime twice here.
to get things ready for that. All right. Let's see where we're at with. Okay.
So it's building the heartbeat right now for phase number six.
Friends don't let devs push secrets and keys. Git leaks detect secrets or truffle hog. It's funny, Mike.
Alright, cool. So, while we wait for this to run, I'm gonna go through some of your guys' questions here.
Okay, so Loc said, how can we capture and organize knowledge into a second brain system as a natural byproduct of working on a software project? How can we keep a second brain and code base project in sync, feeding each other continuously?
Yeah, Locke. So, my recommendation there is when you're doing coding, and you want your second brain to remember the work that you're doing, I would just open up your Claude code in your second brain repo. So you would actually use your second brain to work on the code base. So.
You talk to your second brain, but you give it the path or the GitHub repo for your code base, and then you just tell it to, you know, work on it there.
So that way, as it's making changes, you know, we have this whole, like, memory flush system that I've been demoing for you guys, where we've seen the daily log build over time. It'll remember the things that you're doing in the Claude code sessions working on your code base. So it's gonna remember how you're building your codebase over time.
And then, when we… let me pull up the vault again.
Then when you, you know, promote things into your memory.md with the whole thing that we're building right now with Phase 6, then all the key decisions around, like the big things that you're building into your code base and the issues that you're fixing, like, all of that really important stuff will be logged here to the memory.md.
So your second brain is going to constantly remember how your code base is evolving over time. So that'd be how you'd kind of keep them in sync.
Um, Renata said, I'm just awesome, I appreciate it. Jeffrey said, this is awesome. I think we need to… I need to rewatch this. Yeah, I totally understand. I'm glad you like it, and I appreciate you being willing to, like, go through this again to really digest everything, because I know there is a good amount that we got here, but… yeah, just, I want to give it all the way to you guys. That's what I'm doing here.
Yeah, sounds good, David. All right, uh, Chris said, so init git is not a good idea for privacy. So the important thing is, Chris, there is a difference between Git and GitHub. Github is your cloud hosting of your repo, but Git is just all local. So you can initialize a Git repo even if you want it to be 100% local because that just runs on your system.
So I did initialize it as a Git repo.
All right, Benjamin said, on to phase five. I mean, you're getting there. Like, I'm going decently fast, because I have to, but, like, getting up to Phase 5 already is pretty awesome.
Uh, would local AI be capable to do it? You can definitely use local AI for the second brain. It's not going to be quite as good as using something like Opus. Like, I use Opus for my second brain.
But certainly, like, if you're using a more powerful local model, like at least 32 million parameters, I'd say, like the new Gemma 431B would probably be my recommendation if you want a smaller model to run for your second brain, it'll still be impressive.
Yeah. And, uh, Carson, I won't skip Vault sync, that'll be, uh, when I'm doing the infrastructure part of the last phase.
All right, cool. So let's go back here. Okay, it says the heartbeat is run.
Very good. Okay, alright, we're done with Phase 6. Let's make sure it's good.
Okay, so it made sure the sold.md edit was blocked, and… We okay so did you actually run a full heartbeat and reflection, not just the dry run or is the dry run all we need to do here to validate everything? Because it says that it ran the heartbeat, it gathered 68 items across Gmail, Asana, Slack, and Circle.
And then, uh, so that, like, that's actually good. Like, we sent that in to the Claude Agent SDK. That's actually great.
And then for the reflection, it found today's log. Wow. Look at just during our workshop, it got up to almost 8,000 characters.
Um, the dry run only validates data gathered in basic flow. Oh, okay, they skipped the agent SDK reasoning. Got it, got it. Okay, so yeah, we need to make sure we actually run these end-to-end. So, and it even found a bug when it did that. So, actually, Claude Code got a little bit lazy with the validation here.
Um, because we specifically told it to run the entire thing.
Oh, no, never mind, that is my bad. It says manual here, so I didn't catch this. I probably should have updated the plan to say, like, no, you can actually do it yourself, but that's all good, because now we're doing it. Now we're running it.
Okay, so we'll let it continue to rip through this here. And so in a little bit here, we should see the the full reflection. We'll see the update to our memory.md. So it'll capture all the important stuff from our conversations with it today.
Alright, so David asks, do we open a specific folder as a vault in Obsidian? Is it the root of our second brain or the subfolder? Yeah, good question. It will be the subfolder. So if you go through the full PRD process, like I'm doing in our workshop here, it'll be, like, this folder that has the memory one within it.
Like, I… in my template, I specifically called it Dynamis- Workshop. Whatever name you gave, you'll have that subfolder. This is where you'll open the folder as an Obsidian vault.
And then it'll automatically create the .obsidian file here. That's our folder. That's how you know that you have it set up as an Obsidian vault.
All right.
Yeah, okay. So it's running the heartbeat from scratch. This is good. All right, good, good.
Scott said, doesn't need to be there. I mean, if you're not using Obsidian, it doesn't have to be there.
Or, oh, sorry, no, okay, even if you are using Obsidian, you could have it go somewhere else on your computer. Like, you could point… as long as, um, your second brain has the full path to it.
Like, it's just kind of convenient to have the vault right here within my second brain repository, but if you want to have it somewhere else in a claw.md, say, like, you know, like, here's the full path to the Obsidian Vault, or you could even put that in, like, your soul.md or user.md. You can definitely do that as well. Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's totally good.
Obsidian does not seem to like WSL paths. We'll have to install it to WSL. Oh, that's good to know. I didn't… I didn't know that. Rather than browsing in a WSL from Windows, yeah, exactly, yep.
Right, of course, yeah, exactly, Scott. So if you already have Obsidian Vault stored somewhere else, and you want your second brain one to be there as well, that works 100%. Yeah, this is just a convenience thing for me to have it here.
Oh, Erasmus says this works beautifully, Cole. Awesome. Now a brain believer. I appreciate it, Rasmus. Yeah, and also that reminds me, I saw your question from above, which, by the way, guys, like, there's so many awesome questions you guys have. I wish I had time to go through everything.
Yeah, Rasmus, your question. If you could skip rag, you definitely can. I mean, I find it's pretty effective. But if you want to just do like regular expression blob keyword search for your daily logs, you certainly could.
But I found… I found it to be very effective, and it's simple to set up. So I would recommend Phase 3, like, I have it here for a reason.
But if you're not a believer in RAG, you just want Claude Code to search how Claude Code searches, yeah, I mean, it's not… oh, sorry, not this whole thing, just this part, this part with the memory search pipeline is optional if you really don't want to have RAG, but… I find it effective.
All right. Cool. Regarding obsidian, how do you integrate the vault?
So that's the beauty. I keep saying the beauty, this workshop. That's the beauty of Obsidian, is you don't really have to have an integration.
Because your vault is just marked on documents in your file system. And so that's how Claude code works natively as well. So this is my vault. Just open up in my VS Code right here. That's all it is. There isn't any kind of MCP server that I need. It can just access the files directly.
There are Obsidian MCP servers that give it more fancy search capabilities, but we're building that ourself anyway, so there's no integration that I'm really doing.
Uh, my current vault with context… So, I mean, maybe more what you're getting at is I have this skill.
That describes the structure of my vault, so that way it knows kind of, like, how to search, and it has, like, context of my specific vault.
I guess that's kind of the only, like, integration that I have, is like, here's the skill to read when you want to understand how to go through the structure and, like, search through my vault.
Um, yeah, Jeffrey said, okay, I appreciate this, Jeffrey, because maybe that's the confusion. Don't be confused by the term vault, it's simply the name of the folder structure in Obsidian. It's just a way to organize your files, not a password-protected file.
Um, John said, no, I have my own vault, I want to use it. Oh, okay, got it, got it. Yeah, um, John, if you want to use your own vault.
Like, um, let me… Open this up here. Like… I had an Obsidian vault before I added my second brain. So my second brain is really… it's like really only the memory folder that I added in. Everything else I've been using before I even created a second brain, because I've been using Obsidian since last year, and I've only been building my second brain for the last few months.
There's not really any more I have to do to integrate, though, right? Like, I just kind of need to tell it, like, I also have a content ideation folder, right? Like, I'll just have that in my user.md, or in my global rules. So I point out the different folders, and if I really want to get specific, that's where I'll, like, describe the full structure of my vault in a skill.
So, maybe that's what you'd want to do, John, is just, like, if you have a pretty elaborate vault.
And then you could just create a skill that kind of, like, walks Claude Code or your second brain through how you're organizing things there, if it's quite elaborate.
Yeah. All right.
Very cool. So, anyway, now it ran the full heartbeat. This is exactly what we're going to run every single half hour.
So, um, it found some bugs that needed to fix.
And we also did the memory reflection, so now we can take a look at our memory.md. So this massive daily log, we have added it to our memory.md.
And there we go. I don't know if you guys can… it's not maybe, like, super easy to tell, but this is definitely longer than it was before we before we processed our daily log. So it's remembering key information like here are the new skills that we added in.
Here are the credentials that we have for a second brain. I mean, this one's a little bit random. I don't know if that really belongs in our core memory file, like the specific thing about the Circle API. I mean, maybe it is.
But the important thing is, if you want to adjust what the agent brings from the daily logs into the memory.md, you simply have to change the prompting, right? Like, I can just ask it here. If I want to change the prompt.
for, um, the memory reflect, like, what I actually promote into my memory.md, what would I need to change, right? Like, you can just ask your second brain. It understands itself. It knows the structure, and so if there's anything that's not quite right, you just tell it. Like, hey, you didn't use this skill right, or hey, the memory reflection.
Seems kind of jank right now. Like, help me out here, and it'll just tell you exactly. So, here you go, you just need to change reflection prompt in memory reflect.
Starting in line 68. So I could just go and say, like, you know, in my memory.md, it promoted this, like, really specific thing about the Circle API that just, like, doesn't belong in my core memory file. So I think we need to be a bit more strict in the reflection prompt.
Right, like, that is all we have to do to evolve it. It's that easy.
And so we don't even have to wait for this. I think we're pretty much wrapped up here, so… All right, um, that leaves us with the very last thing, so… Alright, I know that we're over time, so I know quite a few people have dropped already. I totally understand. For those of you guys who are sticking around, though, I do really appreciate it, because I'm just trying to give it all away here. So, I'm going to go another… I mean, it probably will only be, like, 15-20 minutes here, just to, like.
Show you what it looks like to run through setting up the security and doing the cloud deployment. Because there is one more big golden nugget that I have for you for the cloud deployment, because we can have our second brain set itself up in a DigitalOcean droplet. I'll show you guys what it looks like there.
We'll go pretty quick through this stuff, just because at this point we have our groove of we're just using the piv loop to go through every single one of our phases here.
So, alright. Next up, we got phase number eight, and we're going to do our security implementation. So let me know everything we're going to implement based on what the PRD has for us. Alright, so I'll send that in for Phase 8. And then the last phase is just the VPS deployment. So I'll say.
Alright, so phase eight, I'm working on in parallel in a separate Claude Code session. So I want to go on to phase nine. Let's do the VPS deployment stuff. And so, um, I'm going to actually, in parallel, create a DigitalOcean droplet.
And then I'll give you the IP, and I want you to actually set up everything for me through direct SSH access. And so, yeah, I'll take care of that. But in the meantime, I want you to let me know from the PRD, what is everything we have to implement for the Git sync and things like that.
Alright, there we go. So, I probably… I'm probably prompting more than I need to. Sometimes I err on the side of being verbose, but it's all good. So we'll let it kind of rip through that here.
Alright, so here's what we're going to do for Phase 8. So, uh, really quickly, I know I've covered the security briefly, but this is like really important. So we'll get back to coding it in just a second, but I want to lean into the security that I built into the second brain here.
Because these are some of the things that OpenClaw wishes it had.
So going back to our other diagram here. One of the parts of the lethal trifecta is untrusted content. This is the prompt injection risk that you are always going to have for a second brain, because there's always going to be incoming information like emails, that can theoretically have malicious prompts for a prompt injection attack.
overriding your instructions to have the agent do something with your private data.
And so, one of the most important things that I have for my security layer is pattern detection.
I check for common techniques of prompt injection attack.
Now, I could do an entire workshop on this, so I'm not going to get super specific right now for, like, what are those patterns, what are usual prompt injection attacks, just know that I have a lot of them documented, and we're going to apply deterministic logic to watch out for those.
The other thing that I'm doing is I'm going to have Markdown escaping. So essentially, what I'm going to do is anything that comes in from email or any other external source, I'm going to specifically put it within, uh, kind of like an XML block that says, like, hey, Claude Code, by the way, this is not my information. This is not my prompting, this is external.
You need to treat it as such. It's not like that's a perfect defense, but it's one of the layers, and it does help quite significantly.
Actually, sorry, that's this one right here. The XML trust boundaries. That's what we did right here. Um, the markdown escaping a neutralized formatting, that's just making sure we take out certain, um, prompt injection attacks where it relies on, like, malformatting things. So, we're doing all of that.
But then the most important thing that I have here is I actually have an LLM evaluator. So before we even send, like, when I'm talking to my agent in Slack, or through the heartbeat system, because the heartbeat is, like, reading in things from our external sources, before I even send it into our primary Claw and agent SDK session.
I'm actually going to send it into another session that's going to evaluate, like, how suspicious is the information that we're reading in right now?
And the reason that I want to do this in a separate session is because it's the first layer of defense, and I'm giving it minimal permissions. So if there is a malicious prompt injection attack that actually causes the agent to want to, like, do something bad, it's not going to have access to do so anyway.
So we have this as a layer before we get into our primary Claude Asian SDK that actually can do those things that makes it meet the lethal trifecta, right? So our first sec… our first agent session, it breaks the lethal trifecta, because it can't access private data, and it can't.
exfiltrate. It only has this first problem, and that's what we're evaluating in the first place. So, yeah, again, I can do a whole workshop on security for the second brain. I'm going to go pretty quickly through this right now, because I'm actually planning on doing that as a workshop.
So, yeah, cartson said, I vote for a dedicated session on security later. I would love to cover that more.
Um, yeah, sounds good, Will. Yeah, I appreciate you being here. You're very welcome. Yeah, so anyway, that's what we're going to be doing for our security here.
And so, yep, it understands all of that here. Api key isolation is another thing that we're doing here. Claude is never going to be able to read our API keys. We have a pre-tool use hook, so it's going to catch whenever Claude code is trying to read from the .env, our hook is going to catch that.
and block Claude. That's what caused some problems for people at the start of the workshop when they were building right on top of the template. The hook was preventing it from reading files where it is mentioning things like catting out a .env, because we're blocking those actions from happening.
So, I'm going to go into a new session here, and we'll go right into executing.
Our piv loop here for the security. So there's not going to be too much to demo for this. That's especially why I want to have, like, a dedicated session.
for um oh shoot. We didn't actually create the structured plan yet. Let me actually do that. So I'm going to do slash resume.
And yes, so slash plan feature. That's my bad. So yes, let's go ahead and create the structure plan for phase eight. So yeah, if you ever end a session early, you didn't mean to, all good. You can just do slash for zoom when you restart Claude.
All right. So there we go. We're creating the structure plan here. And then we'll do the same for this. So phase 9 is the deployment. This is where we're going to set things up on a VPS. We're going to get the vault sync. So that way any changes we make to our vault remotely through Slack.
will automatically be synced to the vault that we have running locally. It's very important. This is Obsidian-specific, but it is very important.
for Obsidian. So what I'm going to do here.
is I'm going to create the structure plan for this as well. So yeah, go ahead and create the structure plan for phase nine. I'm going to work on getting the instance spun up in parallel, and then I'll give you the IP for that.
Um, and we can get that set up together after.
So I just want to… I want this to… work in parallel as well.
Alright, so both of these are running. And then that's actually my queue here to go and, um… oh, and by the way, you can see that we got some… we got a second brain alert already.
So this is pretty cool. Um, which, by the way, it's kind of crazy. I did the hackathon back in February, and we finally have the funds from Amazon to pay out the winners. So, the winners are getting paid, finally. But, uh, anyway, yeah, so we got that, and then I got some Archon tasks that are stacking up, so we're gonna do some things with Archon next week, so you can see.
We have the heartbeat giving us alerts every half hour in Slack, so that's a live demo of that as well, so very cool.
So anyway, I'm going to go into DigitalOcean here and spin up our instance. This is like the last thing that we're doing here is getting the instance spun up and getting things deployed there. So I'm going to create a brand new droplet in DigitalOcean.
Remember, you can use any platform you want. You can use Hetzner, Hostinger, whatever. I'm just using DigitalOcean because I like doing that for my VPS instances.
Um, yeah, Kashik, that's right, because you're one of the winners for the hackathon. Congrats.
Alright, so I'm gonna create a new instance here in New York that's closest to me. I recommend creating your VPSs with Ubuntu for your operating system. I'll just stick with the default for the pricing, so I'll tear this down anyway after. And then I'll do an SSH key that I already have configured.
I'll just kind of create this in a very standard way. I'm not going to go through all of the usual security that I do for my DigitalOcean droplets, but I have covered that already in the AI Agent Mastery course, and so I'll just say Dynamis, Second Brain Workshop.
For the host name here. Create the droplet.
There we go. All right. So this is the middle of spinning up now. And then in the meantime, I'm just going to take a look at how it's going for creating the structure plans.
Alright, nice. So, yeah, making good progress. And there we go, our instance is ready.
So, and here's the IPv4. You guys obviously can't connect to that because you don't have the SSH key. But, uh, I'll go ahead and paste this in, say… Here is the IP address.
for my second brain instance. Alright, so we can add that to the plan as well. Now, um, one thing that's kind of a gotcha… With the deployment here. We want the second brain to be able to SSH directly into the instance. This is the little gold nugget that I have for you guys for the deployment. We want the… our second brain to be able to SSH in.
We don't want to have any kind of, like, it has to enter in a passphrase for the SSH key or anything. So I'm going to do a little bit of finagling to make that happen.
But your Claude code can always just guide you right through that. So anyway, I'll explain more once it actually has the plan created here, but it's going to do the entire deployment for me. It is a beautiful thing.
All right. So it's still working here.
Let's see if… Carson said, are you using Simple Markdown for task management? I moved to using beads for task management. Really good solution for this. Yes, Beads is fantastic.
Um, I usually use Asana for task management, but if you're talking about, um, like, something within an individual code base, like as you're building on top, I usually just use GitHub issues.
And then for individual implementations, I'll just use the task management built directly into Claude code. But Beads is a great solution.
Yeah. Um, Derek said, support for multiple connections to the same platform, like multiple Asana orgs. I have one for work, another for personal, and sometimes for client projects. Thus far, I've done that using multiple connectors, like two auth via PAT, one OAuth for native MCP, and then custom Asana router skill handles connector selection automatically.
Better way to do that. Um, that… Derek, no, that's good, that's how I would do it. You just have the… some kind of skill or some main instructions in the user.md or claude.md that would describe, like, here's how you connect to the different Asana projects and when you'd want to connect to each one.
That's good. Uh, Matthew said, I didn't watch the agentic coding course. Where can we to understand PIV, etc. Of course, Matthew, yeah, let me point you to that. I would love to. So, if you go into the Dynamist community here, and you click on courses, there's a couple of ways to get to it, but if you go to courses here.
Then I have the agentic coding course. This is the second course I've created for the community.
And it is very value-packed, guiding you through building reliable and repeatable systems for getting good results, insane results, with AI coding assistance. So I'd highly, highly recommend going through this, even before you finish your second brain. Like, this is, like, very fundamental stuff.
So all right. see here, still… still waiting for the plan to finish. Bit of a bummer.
I wanted it to go faster. How far are we with this one? Okay, so both are still creating the plan here. All good.
All right. Go back to the chat here. What is the next question?
Jeffrey said, in this step-by-step guide available, or is the step-by-step available in the readme? For example, step one could be create Second Brain PRD. Then step two might be core PIMBLUE prime, and so on.
So, Jeffrey, this workshop kind of is the step-by-step.
Because really what the repo has for you is… This skill, and like I talk about building the skill, right? Like, if you want to build your own, copy the entire skill folder into your own projects directory, and then fill out the template and run it. It's like everything I showed you guys at the start of the workshop here.
And then I just kind of am assuming that you're going to apply your own AI coding process to work through the PRD step-by-step, or if you've gone through the adjunctive coding course, you're going to know how to, like, go through the piv loop and do everything that I covered here anyway.
So, I mean, maybe I could kind of expand the README here. That is a good suggestion, but I'm just kind of assuming that, like, you take the PRD forward with whatever your AI coding process is after that.
All right. And then Chris, to answer your question. Oh, actually, Chris just left. That's unfortunate. We're going to combine this with Archon today? No, that'll be a separate workshop. So using my second brain with Archon, so we can have Archon as like the coding arm for the second brain.
I'll be covering that very extensively in a separate workshop within the next couple weeks here. I'm very, very excited for that one. Oh, yeah.
All right. Cool, cool. Let me go back and see if we're done with our plans now. Okay, there we go. Good, good.
So, we have our security, all the files we're going to create here for the different things.
that I described, so all of the layers here for security.
We have in this plan here. So, I'm going to go ahead and knock this out. I'm gonna, for the sake of time, not really review the plan here. Do as I say, right? Not as I do, right? Like, I would recommend validating it, but… oh, shoot, that's the wrong command.
All right, so we got to do security and then we're going to do the deployment in another one here. So copy path. There we go. All right, so.
Security, we're in the middle of implementing that. And now we have our deployment. All right, so this is going to cover the Vault sync, the VPS bootstrap. So we're going to actually install everything in the VPS. The one thing to keep in mind, though.
is I actually wanted to validate that it can SSH into the instance before we go with the implementation here. So I'm going to say, I want you to test by SSHing into the instance. And keep in mind that, um, because you use your bash tool, you're gonna have to give the full path to the Windows SSH. That's just something I know doesn't work.
Um, so I've kind of learned from that before. So… Um, yeah, you're gonna use root access into the SSH.
Um, and then if it asks you for a passphrase or something, just let me know what I have to do so that you don't have to do that SSH going forward.
So, sorry guys, I know it's, like, a little specific here with my prompting, because there's just a couple of things that I know it gets wrong when I've done this process before. Just know that, like, you can have Claude Code guide you through what you need so that it can SSH on its own and not have to have like a passphrase or anything.
Um, SSH works in the… we're in. Okay. Oh, no, okay, that was actually way easier than I thought. Okay, so we're good. We're good.
Let me do a quick survey of what's already on the droplet.
All right. Yeah, good baseline. Python's already there. We got 4 gigabytes of RAM. Here's everything we need to install. Okay.
Yeah, so we're good, we're good. So I'm gonna go ahead and clear this. We'll go to a new session here.
And I will do slash execute, and then the deployment stage. And so this is going to take care of bootstrapping everything. And what I'm gonna actually do as well is I have this other Claude Code session where I'm currently running the Slack bot. I'm going to close this right now.
Right? Because now, I want to make sure that when I invoke the Slack bot on my DigitalOcean droplet, that is the only place it's running, right? Because I want to guarantee that, like, we have it running remotely, I can turn off my computer and still talk to my second brain on the VPS. That's the whole point of doing this last phase here, is making sure that we can always talk to our second brain, even when our computer isn't running.
All right, very good. So we're in the middle of implementing all the security here. I'm going to mostly not cover this right here, because I would love to do that in a separate workshop, but just know that we're getting everything set up to be alert. We'll have the agent be alert of anything that's suspicious, and then we're also having that first agent SDK session up front.
That is judging everything coming in, being that gate before we send information into our primary cloud agent SDK session that actually has all of the tools set up with the exfiltration vectors.
All right. Yes, stop asking me for permissions. It's really annoying when it does that. But anyway, it's setting up the git sync for our obsidian. It's going to install everything on our VPS, so in a little bit here, we should see it start to SSH into our instance. It's really cool, like, I never even have to manually SSH into the instance. It just takes care of it all.
I love doing this, like, and this applies to way more than just your second brain, by the way. Like, anytime you need to deploy anything to production, I know that's a little bit risky, like, you might want to be careful with this, but you can, theoretically just have Claude code make your deployments to your droplets after you're done.
Working on the code. Like, it's really cool. All right.
Um, it says that Phase 9 is done. Maybe it skipped that part. I might need to prompt it to do the deployment, or maybe it already did? There's no way it already did. Okay, yeah, not yet, not yet.
All right. Here we go. Okay, so yeah, it says what's left interactive. You do this remaining work is hands-on Bps provisioning.
Actually, we just verified that you are able to SSH into the instance and set up everything. So remember to do the full Windows path to SSH, because you're running in Bash, but you can access the instance and run everything, set up everything. I want you to even run the Slack bot, so by the time you pass control back to me.
The entire second brain is set up running remotely.
Um, what size droplet do you have running for your actual second brain? It's just 4GB of RAM, like, 2 vCPUs. It's pretty basic. Like, since I'm not using any, like, local large language model or anything, it's just using Frontier models, there's really nothing that's too, um, compute or GPU intensive at all, so it's just basic, like, 4GB RAM, like.
You could do, like, a $7 a month KBM hosting or instance, and that's all you need for your second brain, so it can be very, very affordable to host remotely permanently.
All right. What's it? What's it doing here? Oh, yeah. So remember, you need to give the full path to the Windows SSH.
You're not doing that. That's why you're getting these permission denied errors. This, by the way, is just like a little issue I've run into time and time again. So I know exactly what's going wrong. Your Claude code will figure it out by itself.
I can see that works now. Your Claude code will figure it out by itself, but I'm just saving some time here. Because there's some kind of weird glitch with Claude Code. Like, you won't run into this with Linux or Mac, but for Windows specifically, for some reason, if it just runs SSH directly in Bash, it gets this permission denied, so it has to give the full.
path to SSH from within the bash command. So there we go. All right, it's going to bootstrap everything now.
Um, Brandon, how can I install and run Archon? Uh, so I'll save that next week. I'm gonna be doing a full guide on my YouTube channel for how to run and use Archon, so I would wait for that, because we're polishing some stuff up anyway right now. So stay tuned, stay tuned, coming very, very soon, because next week.
is my big Archon week, which I'm very excited for. And it's also the week that I'm going to be doing, um, the, uh, Second Brain AMA sessions, like we just talked about a little bit ago today. So, I'm gonna be excited for that as well.
All right. And then, while this is running right now, let's take a look at how things are working for the security. Okay, so we're still in the implementation here. But it looks like we're already almost done. Yeah, yeah. Okay, good. So the security is pretty much wrapped up here.
So, once we're done with that, it really is just, like, the Vault sync and the infrastructure that we're working on in our last Claude Code session.
And I'll do, like, the final validation with you guys by, um, talking to it in Slack with it running on my instance, right? Like, that's our kind of last test here. Because, I don't know, maybe this happened under your guys' nose, but really, we've tested, like.
Everything with a second brain already. We got the heartbeat working, we saw the memory.md promotion process, I'm talking to it in Slack with parallel conversations, it's able to access my integrations, both within the heartbeat and when I'm talking to it myself.
We have full conversation history in Slack. Like, everything we built at this point is pretty much already validated. It's really cool.
Um, what else do we have here? Yeah, we tested the whole memory pipeline, we indexed our Obsidian Vault, and we were able to search through it with RAG, with both keyword and semantic search.
Um, I mean, I guess a lot of the skills I haven't really tested today, but that's because I've already made YouTube videos. I've already shown a lot of them in workshops, and everyone knows how skills works. I mean, there's workshops I've done in Dynamus, if you aren't familiar with skills, but I have covered those pretty extensively.
We've tested all of the hooks already, session end and session start, pre-compact just works the same way as session end. I mean, we've literally hit on everything already. It's just the last little test here, making sure that we can talk to our agent when it's running remotely, and then we're golden. We've done everything.
Um, alright. I need to add this SSH deploy key to your GitHub repo.
Um, okay, you know what I'm gonna tell it here, is I actually have the GitHub token.
Added to the .env already, so it can actually do this by itself. So, copy path, I'm going to say, go ahead and publish this as a private GitHub repository. And then also within the environment variable path that I gave you here, I have the GitHub underscore token.
So you can just… don't read the .env. I mean, your new security hook is going to block that anyway, but you can leverage this directly, the GitHub token in there to do everything you need.
So this is just, like, a little bit of a technical detail in order to bring over the repository. It needs to have access to the repo and add the deploy key, but it can handle that automatically as long as you give it your GitHub token. And Claude code can guide you through setting that up if you want as well. I know I sound like a broken record with that, but, like, literally anything that you're like, I don't know how this works, or, like.
How do I set this up? Just ask Claude. It's going to be it's going to be golden. Like the advice is always perfect.
All right.
So another question from Bart here. How does it distinguish between emails that do not require response like newsletters, notifications, and emails that do?
Yes, so, uh, Bart, this is all done from the prompt that we send into the heartbeat.
And so that's one of those things that you can evolve in your second brain over time. You can get more specific, either in the prompt or in something like your user.md, you can specify, like.
Like here, I'll even open this up right now. Like, in my user.md, we could have a section of this that would specify, like, here are the kinds of emails we want to reply to, here are the ones we don't want to reply to. Because, remember, the user.md through the session start hook is one of those files that is always loaded into the context of Claude code.
And that includes the heartbeat. So the heartbeat that drafts the replies, it knows everything here, so we can specify this. In fact, what I could even do here, by the way, all all of our security is done. So we got the security implemented. What I can do here is I can say.
Um, help me understand, how does my heartbeat distinguish between emails that do not require response and ones that do, right? Like, I can ask my second brain, and it's just gonna know. It's gonna know, like, hey, you could specify something in the user ID, or, like, this is the prompt that goes into the heartbeat.
It'll, uh, figure this all out for me. Okay.
Uh, credentials are transferred. Yeah, good, so we're in the middle of deploying things to our VPS still, so while that waits, I'll keep answering your question here.
Um… it's still reading the file. Sounds good, Rasmus. I appreciate it a lot, man.
All right. Here we go. So, short answer, it doesn't do the filtering itself, it delegates the judgment entirely to Claude via the agent SDK, right? I mean, that's expected, right?
So, the actual triage logic is the prompt instructions. So like I said, it's something directly in the heartbeat prompt. We can address this over time.
So the summary gets injected into a heartbeat prompt.
We can edit that directly. So if you ever see a heartbeat, and actually, I do this all the time, like, I'll go into my Slack here, and I see this heartbeat. I'm like, nope, that didn't look that good. Like, at workshop second brain, this heartbeat… Or here. This heartbeat sucked. You drafted emails to XYZ that I didn't want you to, right? I'm not going to send this in right now, but you can, you know, have a conversation with it like literally as a reply to its alert in Slack and be like.
All right. We got to change the heartbeat prompt here. Like you're replying to newsletters when you really shouldn't be and you can get advice from it for how you think it should, you know, address that in the heartbeat prompt or the user.md or like whatever part of your system you think it fits, right? That's kind of up to you.
There's no right answer there. All right. Good question, though.
Kashik said, I was chatting with my AI buddy, she made a comment about Colemanis stamina when I said he is tirelessly going.
Yeah, it is… I will tell you guys that, um, doing this for… I mean, it's gonna be well over time at this point, like I said, but, um, yeah, it's pure passion driving this.
Because it is a lot, but man, I'm excited just showing all this to you guys.
All right. Renata asks, what happens when memory gets very long? As you know, the markdown when it's too long or gets or when it gets too long, it's not optimal. So how do we do when it gets to that? So Renata, that is why I have the memory promotion process. So the daily logs, yes, they get long.
But that's exactly why we're performing RAG to search through it later on, because then we don't have to read in the entire file. And then every day we have the memory reflection process that reads this file, and then picks out the most important things to put here. So this is the consolidated list that will never get long.
Or at least you should change your system if it does get too long, because that's a problem. But the point of this is to be the concise version of all the key lessons that won't get too long.
So we essentially take advantage of storing these things in a vector database to avoid it being problematic when we start to build up a lot of memories over time.
So, okay, everything is deployed. Boom. It took care of the entire DigitalOcean deployment for us, gave us a summary of what was done. It says that the bot is live and responding in Slack, so let's go ahead and try sending in a message. So, I'm just gonna do what I… what I did with my testing before, but now the bot is running on my VPS instead of on my computer. So let's just say… Something really simple. We'll say, um…
you know, search my memories. Well, okay, I'm gonna say something simple like hi first, because I just want to see, like, the quick response of it working here. And there we go, boom. It's thinking, and I could even do, like, another message here, like, uh, give me a summary…
of the implementation we did today in phases for the second brain. There we go. So this would require it to kind of, you know, search its memories behind the scenes to get us an answer, and we got the response here from the client agent SDK as well.
This is working remotely now, so I could turn off my computer and talk to it on my phone. We got all that set up live in the workshop right now. And there we go. So here's what we built today for your AI second brain, phase one, phase two, phase three. I mean, wow, it understands everything. Boom.
It even knows the DigitalOcean VPS, like, and that was a fast response, because it just quickly pulled that from our memories here to give us that answer. It doesn't have to search through the code base or anything, because it's all just a part of its knowledge now.
So, beautiful. That's, like, the icing on the cake, because that's it. We have built literally everything now. Everything that you're looking at in this diagram has now been implemented, and we've actually tested it all at the same time as well.
So, there you go, guys. We went over. We definitely went over a good amount, but uh… I mean, that really was just for, like, the last part right here, and to answer your guys' questions. So, I really appreciate everyone who stuck around. I mean, everyone who was here in the first place, thank you very much, but… Yeah, I really appreciate all of you guys who stuck around. That's it. So you have the foundation now. If you follow along and you go through this process, I know some of you guys were still in the middle of working on it, but if you get to this point here where we built all of this.
There's certainly still a way to go for adding in more integrations and really refining the reflection, or refining the searching, right? But the point is, like, you can one-shot all those improvements now, because the second brain understands itself so.
Well, you get to this point, and it just becomes so much easier. So, take that as encouragement. If it feels like a little bit of a struggle up front to understand all this and build all of this.
It is only going to get easier, because then your second brain, like, it starts to guide you on improving itself, and it's really cool. Like, you still stay in the driver's seat, but you have these conversations where it's like, I don't like how the memory reflection handled today.
Like, can we work on that? And it's just gonna be like, yeah, here's… boom, boom, boom, here are three suggestions, like, what do you think? And it's like, oh man, like, oh, this is great, like, all right. And it just gets better under your nose, it's so cool. Um, and then, of course, just being able to remember more over time helps a lot as well. And as you just add more skills.
So, yeah. All right. So and yes, Shane, it does run off of my Claude Code subscription because with the agent SDK, you are allowed as long as it is a personal application, like the second brain is.
So, cool. I know that there are still a lot of questions that I didn't get to, but mark my words, guys, for next week, I'm going to have some second brain ama sessions, and always feel free to DM me, make posts in the community. I'm in the community every single day asking your guys questions or answering your guys' questions, and obviously I'm, like, super on fire for this right now, so I'm super happy to help you guys in any way possible.
understanding what we built here, helping you build on top for yourself and your own integrations. I'm always down to help you guys out.
So, all right, guys, I'm gonna go ahead and call it here. I will get the recording up later today.
And then tomorrow, I'll get the AMA session scheduled. I'll create the section in the community for specifically questions for the second brain. And then, um, you know, in the meantime, before I have that, feel free to just put questions in the general chat or whatever. But yeah, that's everything that I got for you guys today, building your own second brain. Remember, the resources linked in the description. Recording will be after as well.
Appreciate all you guys being here very, very much. Happy, uh, you know, Good Friday to those of you who celebrate. Otherwise, have a great weekend, everyone.
And I will see you all in the community. Take care all. Thank you very, very much.